well good morning ladies and gentlemen
it's nine o'clock so the inquiry is
resumed
you'll know now that i'm going to say
there's a fresh attendance list
circulating and just a reminder that if
you've got a
mobile phone with you please make sure
it's switched off or on silent whilst
the inquiry is sitting
um
i've not got much to say now i think
i'll just
say to the parties um i haven't had a
chance yet to look through the
conditions that have been
uh handed in but i'll try and do that
and get some comments too if i have any
um by monday so that
you've got that ahead of the conditions
session
mr foster you said that you were going
to just give some further thought
overnight as to whether or not you would
have questions would like that you'd
like to put to the
appellants air quality expert you you
said yesterday you thought you did
um yes sir thank you we do have some
questions support you do okay thank you
need to make the appropriate
arrangements at the
appropriate time
um i think my my final point is mr
gardner who isn't here at the minute but
who did speak on the first day
approached me at the end of the
inquiry yesterday to make two points one
is to say that he would also like to put
question or questions to the air quality
expert but also he expressed some
concern that the
fire exit that i can see over there to
my right he felt was a little bit
blocked by people and boxes yesterday
obviously it's a bit out of my uh
range to to see what the situation is
there but if if it is in any way impeded
uh boxes or people can i just ask that
you
adjust your positions and move the boxes
so that uh there's a clear route to the
the fire escape if necessary thank you
i don't think i've got anything else to
say mr parkinson anything from yourself
no misread no mr foster
no
okay on that note then
mr can i ask you to
introduce your first witness and give me
some indication as to which additional
documents i might need
so i think i think probably the main
documents that you might need
are mr blair's proof of evidence
and appendices
yep
and
yeah and probably
also worth having the ta i think
remind me of the cd number um c
1.14 1.14 thank you i'll just get that
fold to hand
and also sorry so when i said the proof
of evidence i also meant the rebuttal
proofs as well so basically sorry when i
said the proof of evidence i also meant
the rebuttal proofs as well so the whole
okay
there might be other um documents that
um mr blair goes to but those are
probably the main ones um
and i suppose you might want to have
tanned as well just in case we gave them
the statements of common ground yeah
yeah over there thank you okay
good morning mr blair good morning
i'm just going to introduce you to the
inquiry uh your qualifications are set
out at page one of your proof of
evidence
you're peter blair you have a degree in
civil engineering and a diploma in
industrial studies both from the
university of ulster you are a chartered
engineer a fellow of the institution of
civil engineers and a fellow of the
chartered institution of highways and
transportation is that correct that is
correct
your head of transport north at the
international consultancy tetra tech and
have over 30 years experience of working
in the field of traffic engineering
both for public authorities and private
developers you've served on the north
western branch committee of the
chartered institution of highways and
transportation for 16 years is that
right that's correct
you set out in your proof that over the
last 22 years you've acted as an expert
witness in relation to highway traffic
and transportation issues at numerous
appeals and local plan inquiries dealing
with schemes ranging from single
property accesses to major development
and city regeneration projects that
you're familiar with the development
site and highways and operational
conditions in the local area all correct
all correct could you just please read
your statement of truth at
1.1.5 of your proof of evidence on page
one
this proof of evidence
which i've prepared for this appeal
inquiry is given in accordance with the
requirements of my professional bodies i
can confirm that the opinions expressed
are my true professional opinions
thank you very much now i'm going to
start please um at section 4 of your
proof of evidence
[Applause]
um which is and i really just flag that
up the the inspectors note um but
um i'd like you please to
give an overview as to your involvement
in this scheme and your opportunities to
visit the site
well when i was first appointed on the
scheme um
it was to undertake a peer review
can i just say mr bill you might need to
move the microphone a little bit closer
to you
it's easy for me because i'm looking at
you and i can hear you but i'm not quite
sure whether your voice is carrying that
clearly to the back of the room thank
you
okay uh well yes upon appointment i
arranged to undertake
a few site visits
so i visited the site on the 9th and
10th of september
i was able to observe the
early afternoon school peak
from around 2 30
through the holt farm school peak period
and stayed on site until
the evening peak period as well
observing traffic conditions at those
times
driving around the network
and i think you will see at my appendix
3
probably 50 or so photographs
that i've extracted from the dash cam
that was running at those times
those also extend to the next morning
when i was on site again
and observed the early morning peak and
stayed on site through to about
10 45 on the friday morning
my observations were that there were of
course busy periods particularly
excuse me
it always seems to happen on a p
um
particularly around the school
getting out times and arrival times i
generally saw traffic flowing freely of
course i saw some of the
busier conditions that have been
shown in my proof of evidence you'll see
them in the appendices
but i was also conscious that
i'd only been on site for two days they
were two days after travel restrictions
were lifted
and
if you can recall back to the start of
september it was almost back to normal
the schools were back
so i thought that was a good time to
visit
i was conscious that it was just the two
days so later
i also commissioned
a video survey
and that was the uh
that has produced
i called them time lapse but i see that
has caused a bit of um
uncertainty that they are
time sequenced stills
from those video shots and those are in
appendices four and five
of my
evidence
and those
show
half hour shots throughout the day
and then five minute shots throughout
throughout the school peak periods
and i commissioned that and presented
them just to give some factual typical
imagery of what conditions are like
there throughout the day and at the peak
times
sorry i turned it off because of the
echo i forgot to turn it back on again
um
thank you um next next point just want
to uh take up with you um relates to the
traffic data that has informed the model
um
have you considered how representative
that traffic surveys are
yes well on my video sorry on my site
visits
i was in possession of the
transportation assessment and the
traffic counts and queue surveys in fact
that are in that
and it seemed to
corroborate with that
conscious of course that the surveys in
the ta were undertaken in 2019
just before
well actually a year before the coveted
pandemic closed things down a little
so they are representative and of course
there was reference the other day to the
i think it's core document
5.01 one
report to committee
where the highway authority set out that
they
have tested the current data in the
ta against their own databases
and confirmed it to be representative
and was the representativeness of the
the data ever challenged by the local
planning authorities mr flexman
no not at all
you
do you have any comments to make about
the uh video
and photographs that were um produced by
the rule six party and um whether those
provide a robust basis for challenging
the traffic data
that has been used
they don't
they're not a robust basis for
challenging the traffic data which
has been
surveyed
considered benchmarked and agreed
um
i noticed in the videos yesterday that
there was platooning going on and i
think
it was mentioned later that there were
roadworks further down the down the road
it seemed to me although it was out of
shot
that that was platoons of traffic
waiting for a green signal and then
progressing through
difficult to tell of course with the
time-lapse
aspect you
um next point please could you explain
um what approach has been taken to
traffic growth
in the assessments
yes
[Music]
because i was appointed initially to do
a peer review
there were several aspects of the work
that i had to check through
and traffic growth was was one of those
um the traffic growth factors that had
been applied were
from a growth database called temporo
temporal assembles
allocated sites etc for different areas
and in my technical note 1 which is in
my
volume 2 appendices
there's a piece there that sets out how
we've looked at that
and made some slight adjustments
principally because
the allocated site that we've developed
trip generation for
also is represented within the temporo
and it's a fairly standard
approach
not to double count
that had been in the ac ace the original
work was undertaken by ardent
consultants i think that's clear from
everything that's going on but i'll just
say ace
um
so they were using slightly higher
temporal growth rates but again
that hasn't been questioned by the lpa
mr flexman or anything that's a signed
sound response um
in actual fact when we go to the results
later i'll show that it makes very
little difference indeed but it is
something i checked and
adjusted slightly
and i think those adjustments have been
expressly accepted by mr flexman in the
first statement of common ground haven't
they
yes and
i presume that carries through to
statement of common ground number two
where he says he's got no issues at all
yeah
um and just just in answer just just an
answer please to the point raised by the
rule six party in their evidence
and was scr the scr-2 site taken into
account yeah the tempo included growth
factors for area rochford 0.007 which
that site is within but also in 2019
whatever extent if it was built would
have been in the accounts anyway
um next point just want to pick up with
you is again a point raised by the rules
six party which is that there are local
peaks in the traffic um have those been
considered um in the assessment
yes i mean this this goes to the tricks
analysis
and
the peak nature of the traffic counts
and i know that the inspector said
two days ago that he was going to ask
about the tricks assessment
would it i can't really see would it be
appropriate to explain the tricks
assessment first as part of answering
that question yes please do and just
just for the benefit of members of the
public you just explain what a trix
assessment is
i'm sorry
it's
yes it's um
it's a database full of surveys which
have actually physically been undertaken
counting traffic pedestrians cyclists
and all modes of traffic coming to and
from
a wide range of
different use types
[Music]
it's set out in the ta
um
it may be worthwhile just going to it
it's a bit of a it's a bit of a goose
chase to find the figures but
ace if we could pick up the ta sir i'll
just say that's yeah
1.14 yep
so the first reference is easy to find
it's on page 56
and it's table 5.1
okay take table 5.1 yeah table 5.1
and that sets out the trip rates per
dwelling now this is a summary table i
will take you to show you where this is
derived from
but that sets out the trip rates and you
can see that private houses affordable
houses etc have all been categorized
differently
the reference in this ta which is more
difficult to find
is on an unpagented page
very well through the document um
if i may just read from it it's uh
it's the page
titled triplet calculation selection
parameters
did a tenth of the fourth 19 when the
tricks assessment was done
there is no pagination sir i do
apologize it's um
really for for the for the public i just
go through the steps you select the
areas that you want to
select sites from
you select the
number of dwellings so this was a range
of between 6 and 805 units
you select the survey days that you want
so all week days if selected and
one saturday crept in
we select the survey types they were all
manual accounts
you select a location
a few edge of town suburban areas and
edge of town
sorry the first one's edge of town
centre
residential zone 43 of the 45 sites
belong to that category
and then for populations within one mile
you can select sites with similar
populations around
five to ten thousand were eight survey
days
ten to fifteen thousand there were
thirteen survey days
we went right up to well ac went right
up to all the category of 50 000
in population within a mile
but there were fewer surveys of those
the predominance was at that level and
then what happens is
38 of the 45 sites did not have a travel
plan in place
it then follows
perhaps
seven or eight sides of naming which
sides were actually selected
so for example we have
uh
mixed houses at rhinestone then
anger ming
west sussex that was one of the sites
but there are 45
and we end up with
four the private houses
summary trip rate page
which shows you those figures of 0.126
and 0.370
which were on your table
so that's the tricks process and it's
set out
on an r by r basis throughout the day
so and
so i think just for your reference i
think it's appendix i of the ta it is an
appendix eye of the ta appendix eye okay
thank you i'll check that later thank
you
there is there is a simpler explanation
which i'm coming to which is as part of
the peer review
i reviewed all of that and i took out
the
uh saturday survey and you know that set
out
in let me just get it
tn2 traffic generation
so just to summarize where we're at at
the moment with this because i heard
someone say that they didn't understand
it it's a national database of surveys
you select the ones which are relevant
to this use type
and then what it does is it prints out
the trip rate per dwelling
across a 12 or a 24 hour period
and it's inbound and outbound
and that's uh
that's what that's what was used
so
ace actually did it by two different
methods
they did it the straight tricks way
and then they did it by looking at
the proportion of different modes
and
shouldn't have turned away from it um
yeah by mode and journey purpose and
they worked out all the percentages of
those and while you're open there
started table 5.1
you can see that breakdown in table 5.2
right beside it
yep and just draw your attention to the
education percentage for car drivers six
percent
come back to that later
and that's when car driving was 47 so
really six over 47 12 percent of all car
drivers
had an education purpose in that now ace
looked at it both ways and they chose
the higher one
when i came to look at it um
took out the
saturday survey there was a different
this is all set out in tn2
we took out further away regions like
the northwest of england etc
the most recent five years of data was
selected pre-covered
populations of greater than 20 000
within one mile were excluded richard's
population and the 2011 census was 8500
and we run through that and we end up
with just a comparison
on page 14 of my appendices
so which appendix is this this is
appendix
13.
so appendix 13 and sorry which page
yeah yeah i've got the right one it's
paginate at 14 or page three of tn2
14.
it's a results table
yeah that's it yeah okay so there's a
comparison of the trip rates that um
you produced compared to what were
originally looked at by hca
okay and you can see in the bottom line
that there was no difference in the
inbound am
30 fewer in the am out
and in the pm the difference was minus
12 in and plus 10 out
so some of them were slightly lower some
of them were slightly higher but that's
that's the difference when i went
through that additional review
okay
for all the different use types and and
it was done actually sir for 665
dwellings because that's what the aceta
was written for so not
662 or even the net increase which is
six six zero because two homes are being
demolished to make the access yeah
so that's
apologies but that's the the first half
of the answer
um the second half
of the answer is that
the traffic counts which are in the ta
were undertaken on a 15 minute basis so
their continuous 15 minutes and that
allows you to get a rolling
peak r 728 7 15 to 8 15
7 30 to 8 30 etc
and what we found what ace found by
combining
the trip rates
with the 15-minute p-cars as you can
synthesize and find out what the worst
case peak is
now later we're going to be talking
presumably junction 4 and at junction 4
that was 7 15 to 8 15.
and we have the direct traffic counts
for those
but
you have to take three quarters of the
trip rate
from seven to eight
and one quarter of the trip rate from
eight to nine to get the trip rate which
lies between seven fifteen to eight
fifteen
and that has been done
so when analyzing it right across the
piece
we know that that's the worst p car and
in actual fact in the next the next star
um eight to nine there were 200 trips
fewer on that corridor on the count that
was checked
okay
and
in respect of um
which one
yeah and
in respect to the
highways statements of common ground one
with the local planning authority
paragraph 3.2
did mr flexman agree with your approach
to updating trip rates growth dates and
the validation of base models uh yes you
did
and you've just mentioned validation
which was the third thing that i did to
check it i don't know if we're coming on
to that but
yeah do you want to tell me about
validating the models next uh
certainly i mean
for this it might be an idea to go to my
appendices
tab 10. volume 2 1 of 2 tab 10.
bear with me a moment
uh now i'm not working with the tabbed
version now because i i handed that one
back if it's volume
two
um one and two it is paginated on one
eight four one eight four thank you
yes so i'm looking at a table is that
correct that is correct
if we look down the very first left-hand
blue column
you'll see the ratio of float capacity
for the 2019 counts
when the junctions were tested
and
you will see at junction four
a ratio of loaded capacity of 1.15
so that sets alarms alarm bells ringing
because
the traffic count surveyed the traffic
that actually passed through the
junction
now that meant that sometimes isn't the
case if your queues are growing
the demand might be
what goes through the junction plus a
growing queue but fortunately ace had q
surveys done as well and we're able to
cross check that
and come to the conclusion
that more traffic got through that
junction than the ace model
predicted
so the first thing that we do is we look
at the geometry and we find the ace had
actually modeled a previous geometry and
it was simply a case of going to the
correct geometry
and that that performance
improved but it was still running at
about 1.07 so further validation was
undertaken at that junction only
validated on rfcs to reflect the traffic
that actually did pass through
the other junctions were all checked
for the geometry
validation but no no further assessments
were necessary there no further
adjustments were necessary there
okay
an agree and again that was agreed with
mr flexman at 3.2 of the highway
statement of common ground in the
previous quote you gave me here he
accepted all of those peer review
adjustments
it's always the pay
good thank you um now um i want to turn
on
that basis to the outputs of the models
and look at what um what was assessed in
respect of each of the
uh
junctions that you looked at so if you
keep keep open the table that you were
looking at a moment ago at page
184
um but there's also help
there's
there's also helpful
sorry that feedback's terrible isn't it
can you hear me at that level
i can't i can't have it on my document
so
see how we get on with that yeah
right try again so you have your your
table um open in front of you um you
also provide a summary um of the
position at pages um 32
through to 35
of your proof of evidence
just bear with me please i was in my
summary proof there
let's look 32-35
yes that's right
yeah
um so i think i think what i'd like you
to do now please is if we could just
take the junctions in turn save for
junction 4.
so just set junction 4 aside for the
moment
and just talk through please um what the
position was
with the
first the ac forecast and the highway
authority's position
and then secondly
what the position is in respect of your
revalidated model
and mitigation
yes okay
useful to follow it through on the table
of results i would say sir that the
reason the appendices are so large is
because we've put in all of the model
results but this table is just
using the indicator of the absolute
worst result in the worst 15-minute
period yeah
so the baseline rfc which is in the
terracotta colored column
at rectory road
2029 baseline
was forecast to be 1.09
with the development flows added
that jumped up to 1.17
which is in the uh clear the uncolored
cell
so two two columns to its right right
yeah and this is the ac modeling we're
on at the moment this is yeah this is
all under the heading of the ace mode
after they had undertaken
their
mitigation scheme
that went to 1.11
and
consequently the first sentence in my
9.2 is that junction one mitigations
proposed
and
[Music]
the aha found the busiest ace forecast
of 1.11
with development and mitigation to be
acceptable
being 11 over capacity but just 0.02
over the baseline rfc
so that was a position at junction one
to summarize it where
um
there was a two percent impact an
operation of eleven percent over
over capacity and the highway authority
find that acceptable
when we
looked at the
validation in the
ace flows that's the
the lighter blue sorry the mid blue
heading the next the center of the table
i may just
ignore that for a moment sir and go to
the darker blue results if that's okay
okay
what we found
is that the validated performance of the
junction
in the sorry the sky blue column right
in the middle of the table was 0.98
the 2029 baseline put it to 1.02
and the mitigation put it to 0.94
the existing layout with development
so the existing layout with development
which is the uh the uncolored cell about
five in from the right
is 1.08
so the story there is that
the baseline would have been 1.02
if we didn't do anything to the junction
it would go to 1.08
but with the mitigation scheme it goes
to 0.94
and we can follow that down now the
reason why
there are very few results in for
junction 2 is because it's a site access
oh sorry just before we move on to
junction 2 i do just want to pick up a
point in respect to the rectory road
junction that was raised by councillor
eaves and it's not a point relating to
capacity at the point relating to
highway safety but whilst we're dealing
with rectory road let's let's just have
a think about that um councillor eve's
position albeit one that was not
weighed in the balance because
councillor shaw didn't think there was
sufficient evidence in respect of it but
council reeves took the position
that the mitigation at rectory road
might not be safe because and i
paraphrased we've been here before
that well that i don't those are the
words in his proof but you heard his
evidence yesterday
um although i think he then did accept
ultimately that we were dealing with a
different scheme here than what had been
um there before
um
just want to be um clear really as to
the extent to which highway safety has
been considered in respect of the
proposed scheme of mitigation at rectory
road and your comments in respect of
that please
well as with all of the proposed highway
works an independent road safety audit
was carried out
and where comments have been raised then
there's a designer's response
which sits alongside that as part of
that formal process
which sets out what responses there
would be
at rectory road
there are no instruments well there were
no issues identified
and did the highways authority or mr
flexman raise any issues in respect of
the safety of the proposal no and the
highway statement of common ground
confirms that all uh highways accesses
are safe suitable et cetera that's a
highway statement to common ground with
the highways also with the highway
authority
thank you right sorry interrupts do you
carry on junction 2 site access
well yes the reason why there isn't a
2019 validated result or a existing
situation the result is because it's a
new junction
so at junction 2
[Music]
we simply have
the ace result at junction 2 which was
0.4
in simple terms 60 spare capacity in the
peak
um but as part of my checking of all the
models etc
uh we noticed that there was an error in
the geometry of the proposed junction
because it's a ghost island it was in as
nine meters and actually it should have
been the two three meter lens plus the
center
so when we have reassessed it
the performance of the site access
junction is now showing
in the second result uh in the middle of
the table which is 0.5
so that check made it 16 worse but still
with 44
spare capacity
junction three next please the ashington
uh road rose avenue uh dallas road
junction now this is the one uh well
actually let's let's just park that one
for a minute i'm going to deal with that
moment because that was the one where
there was further discussions with you
and mr flexman can we deal with the
amblin roundabout actually next which is
junction 5
and that's your section 9.6
yes um
so the 2029 baseline
um new development
assessed by ace was 1.11 that's the
terracotta column two from the left
then with the development flows 1.16
and
curiously post mitigation
1.16
now the reason that that result is
showing the same
is because the highway authority
requested solution there is a highway
contribution towards a future
improvement scheme
they say that they didn't want a small
scheme they'd rather do something more
holistic it's down there's an industrial
state nearby it's near the airport
they're planning something bigger in the
future
they wanted a contribution towards a
more holistic scheme
okay
so we we revalidated the base model on
geometry so that was 0.96
consequently
the uh
this is a good example to demonstrate
what i was saying before actually
that the two green columns in the middle
of the table there show
that with development
it's 1.06
and the point i'd just like to draw is
that if you go across to
the next two green columns
you will see that that's 1.04
the reason for that two percent
betterment
is the tricks and the temporal
those are the adjustments and that's why
they make very little difference but
they were a revalidation in that
direction as accepted by mr flexman
junction 5 has a
another result in there which is 0.99
and that's because
i
just wanted to cover the situation where
someone might say
that future highway scheme will never
happen
how else could you fix it so i've put in
exactly the small scheme that the
highway authority said they'd rather
bundle up for later
but that can be implemented and it takes
the
rfc to 0.99 which
comparing it back to the baseline is an
over mitigation of just a percent but
it's working within capacity
but so fully fully mitigated at that
junction
yeah okay
so
just to summarize in respect to the
rectory road junction the site access
and the amblin
junction
with mitigation to what extent are the
development impacts mitigated
well
in summary
over over mitigated
and
significantly performing better
than the levels forecast by ace which
the highway authority accepted
good
and
any issue taken by mr flexman in respect
of those junctions
good next one junction three so um this
is the one where there were further
discussions between you and mr flexman
so just just want a very brief summary
um please of uh where we're up to in
that respect well well the the final
position is that there's a slight
alternative minor scheme which mitigates
the impact of the development yeah
how we got to that was that the
ace scheme
had a two-lane approach
mr flexman thought that that wouldn't
work as efficiently as the model because
the the flows are slightly well they're
very imbalanced there's very few going
left and strong yeah so actually giving
two three meter wide lanes is actually
constraining the main flow so when he
pointed that out it said
i don't know if you're familiar with the
barbra chard approach from 20 years ago
he pointed that out i immediately said
well you know the purpose of modeling is
to inform judgment et cetera see where
we're going that seems reasonable so we
looked at different ways that it could
be made to work and we looked at three
different solutions one was putting two
line axis on
so you could have two straight through
we drew something up but we haven't
presented it
we actually
put in the correct entry width which
which made it perform better we haven't
presented that either we did a slight
adjustment to the approach
halfwidth and it resolved the problem mr
flexman saw that and said yeah that
resolves the problem
um
when i first saw his rebuttal proof
his analysis of that junction had it at
1.13
and
my first reaction was to just send a
quick email to the highway authority
which said
that i didn't know how you sir
regard his approach or where this would
end up but if it ended up that you were
minded to accept his 1.13
why would the highway authority feel
about it and that's the reference that
you were given the other day in battle
proof about them accepting it and saying
it all has to be considered holistically
that that's by the by because
there's an alternative scheme mr flexman
accepts it and it takes the rfc down to
0.98
the final thing i would say is that
i was careful when i drew up that
alternative straight scheme
not to go outside the footprint of the
two-line approach and
in that email to the highway authority
you'll see me saying that actually that
gives them the choice
because the two-lane approach
would still be
a better solution long-term if the if
the two-lane exit was on and they could
have comfort in delivering that
and knowing that over the next seven
years if traffic did
rise to the levels that mr flexman says
will will happen
then this alternative improvement could
actually be achieved with white lining
and that would that would return it
within capacity and mitigate that impact
so it's
yeah that's the position yeah okay
thank you very much so just a summary
for
members of the public then
in respect of that junction is that now
mitigated to operating within capacity
yes it operates within capacity
uh good um
and um
have the highways authority accepted um
that alternative mitigation scheme that
you've just discussed
yes they have i sent the details and the
model to them um they've looked at it
and sent them the drawing the modeling
the explanation and they've accepted
that
and this is all set out i think in uh
volume five just for the inspectors note
of your rebuttal volume five there's a
drawing of the junction there but i
didn't include the full modeling but the
full modeling was sent to both mr
flaxman and to the highway authority
yeah
yeah and the results are summarized in
the emails aren't they between you and
the highways
authority good okay
um now we're going to turn onto
non-highway work mitigations a little
bit later but does any do any of the
results that you've just discussed post
physical mitigation to the highway take
into account non-hype take into account
non-highway improvement mitigations
no they don't and that's why i still
regard my results as robust
there's no reductions in those for any
of the
beneficial medications
right junction 4 next because this is
the
[Music]
um junction 4 because this is the
junction where um councillor eves
uh still um took an issue obese of
course councillor shaw has confirmed
that on the local planning authority's
evidence not sufficient
to lead to a refusal of planning
permission
um but
let's let's just look at junction 4
appendix 14 page 45 please
um now um just just before we look at
this in detail is there is there a
typographical error in this that you
would like to
correct yes mr parkinson highlighted it
on the first day it's a 745 to 845 at
the top it is actually
7 15 to 8 15 as shown in all the model
files it's just a typo in the table
okay so sorry so i uh the the heading at
the very top which which i can see is
saying 7 45 to 8 45 he's saying 7 15 to
8 15. yes i think that's correct
and that's that's shown in the we'll
turn to the time segments um a little
bit later but that that's demonstrated
in the time segments and you've you've
produced the modeled results at the back
of this summary table haven't you
yes good okay now um second point
in respect to this um to what extent do
the modeled results here represent the
worst case
well those those are
the worst case
okay
and um the local councilor eves
councillor eves um only alleged that
there would be
an unacceptable impact in the am peak
um your view please as to the
acceptability
of the impact
in the pm
peak
please
okay
we're looking at this in the pm peak
washington road was the concern uh i
believe the impacts there are entirely
acceptable in the context of what we're
talking about at that junction
sorry sir we couldn't hear that answer
very clearly though the
though the volume is okay uh mr blair's
very dulcet tones are sometimes hard to
pick up
so we couldn't hear that last answer i
said it could be repeated please
i said that i believe that the impacts
are entirely acceptable at that junction
in the context of what we're talking
about at that junction
okay
um and let's then look at the am peak
where we see the worst case in any event
yeah
um and um
first point um councillor um eaves
accepted the position
that there was no issue in the am peak
in respect of hull road
do you agree with that yes okay
um then just in respect of
west street he appeared to take
a position
that there would be an unacceptable
impact on the west street arm of that
junction
because the rfc
rose from
1.00 to 1.03
is that a credible approach no that's
that's not a credible approach why well
because there are very few junctions in
built up areas that operate within
capacity
at peak times and it's long been
accepted that overcapacity
is the norm in such situations
um
many years ago at the beginning of my
career people held higher standards but
you could you can see that over the
years
uh higher and higher levels of operation
have been accepted as the norm yeah but
but three percent over capacity is you
know it's within
minor variations and of course i'd like
to come on to talk about why
all of those results are over robust
anyway yeah which which we which we will
do um but if we just look at the
max q in respect of pcus at west street
what what's the difference there
uh going from 44 to
sorry
yeah i'm going from 16 to 20 so it's
four vehicles yeah
so is that is that an unacceptable
impact mr blair no absolutely not and
you know again
when you consider the levels that the
highway authority thought were
acceptable at that junction this is way
below that
thank you very much and then we'll we'll
look at the um
the arm
of that junction uh that council reeves
was particularly concerned about which
is the ashington road
arm in the am peak
so that's the worst case
in terms of both the peak and the result
um for that arm
and
just just before we
look at um
those results
those are non-physical mitigations i'd
just like to pick a point up with you
please that you deal with at 12.2.15
12.2.15 of your proof of evidence
so
which is on page 50.
yeah
so this
at this point in your proof of evidence
um you are responding to a point
that was raised by councillor eves and
has been raid raised also by the rule
six parties
in response to the ta
where they say that the reliability of
modeling
um is called into question
um because of a point that ace made
which was that when junction models
forecast an exceedance of capacity they
exaggerate the results
now i just just want to you to explain
please um
what the position is
in respect of that
and
why
the models are likely to forecast
queuing and delay which is worse than
will actually occur
well it's it's long been recognized that
the algorithms and the models
are based based sometimes on the surveys
of other junctions etc that they're set
to be
accurate within those parameters once
you start going over capacity you get a
well exponential or snowball effect if
you like
where the higher over capacity it goes
then it really builds upon itself and
exponentially increases
so it's absolutely right to say that if
a junction is appearing to be over
capacity to this sort of level
then the results will be somewhere on
that exponential curve it's not right to
say
that they're somehow unreliable because
they might be too low
they're on the exponential curve they're
probably over reporting
we can't say by how much because it's an
exponential curve
um
and is there any difference between you
and mr flexman and the highways
authority in respect at this point
there's no difference between us on that
point and there's no difference between
sorry this is really fading back um
there's no difference between me and mr
flaxman on the junction either because
he accepts
that all his issues are resolved
there's no difference between me and the
highway authority because they accepted
that it was
resolved when it was an rfc of 1.37
thank you um now just just on that basis
stepping away from the modeled queue for
a moment
um if we look at your append if we take
up your appendices please
and if we turn up
page 232
[Music]
sorry which is in appendix um
volume 14 again yeah
okay
um and what
what we have there is a table and this
is for the time segment
8 a.m to 8 15
and we can see from the um
middle row
that that is reporting the worst case
scenario that we've just seen in the
summary table at page 45.
and
there is a
there is a column the first column total
demand pcus
and we see the figure 240. can you just
explain for the benefit of members of
the public what total demand pcu means
yes i can
[Music]
we're in a 15-minute time segment
so 240 is the total number of pcus which
are approaching on that arm
now pc use it
yes uh yeah i think that's exactly what
mr
was going to do yeah so a pcu is a
passenger car unit and it's a measure of
basically how much road space and
presence a vehicle has on the road so a
bus might be
two pcus we used in our analysis
for an hgv a factor of 2.3 pcus for an
hgv
a bicycle is half a pcu
it's so that the model doesn't attribute
the same amount of congestion delay etc
to
to a particular volume of vehicles
they're put in pcus and that's the
standard approach in actual fact in the
ice work
uh one of the points that mr flexman
picked up and
picked up on mr foster's comment
yesterday that
it appeared as though he was working for
the appellant uh mr flexman i can assure
you put me through the ringer on a few
um comments
and one of them was showing that the ice
work had used vehicles and we had to
re-address the modelling as well
and there's separate correspondence
between us that proves that it made no
difference in fact it's even before the
inquiry it's one of the
one of the pages in the rebuttal proof
to demonstrate that the
uplift of vehicles to pc use
made no difference no material
difference at all
can just be clear though on that that
you said
did you say that the ac work had they
had done its assessments based on
vehicles that's what mr flexman pointed
out to you and so as a result of that
you redid that work but used
pcus yes i understand thank you
so um so that's been done and uh
and that made so so the 240
is the approach
volume in that 15 minutes and that's
made up of the existing traffic
the growth factors to the future and the
trip generation of the site as
distributed across the network and
coming down to that approach
and then if we look please at page just
so we just bear that that
240 figure in mind and and we look at
um
page 224
and this is the
2029 base case with no development
yeah
and what is the total demand pc use for
that arm of the junction
in that worst case time segment there
please 215
being 25
pcus less
so just to summarize that again for
members of the public what does that
tell us
um in respect of the the difference
comparing the base case in 2029 with no
development
and then the modeled results
in 2029
with development
what it tells us that is that in a
15-minute period that development is
adding 25 pcus to that flow 103 i think
was the number for the whole r
sorry 103 for the entire r
now we also know we also know that there
is a minimum
allocation
of 500 units
within the plan in respect of this site
and if we turn up next please page
it's page 240
what is the total demand pc use
for the minimum allocation please for
the minimum allocation it's two three
four
so what does that tell us what does that
tell us about the difference between the
minimum allocation in the adopted plan
and the number of units
well say the number of units proposed
actually you've actually assessed 665
but the number of units assessed in
respect to the modeled results six trips
in 15 minutes
six pcus in 15 minutes yeah
thank you
and so um two points
um to take us back
to base
how many pcus
would we need to lose from the network
for total mitigation 25 and 15 minutes
on that arm yeah just just on that
approach here
and um in respect of
um in respect to take us back to the
minimum allocation how many would we
need to lose we'd need to lose six pcus
on that arm and just drawing the
distinction of on that arm this is the
morning peak when the predominant flow
is away from the development so this
arm's taking the predominant trip
generation there's not not so much
coming in the other two arms at all
now um
counselor is eve
raised
for the
first time
in cross-examination
so not in mr flexman's proof who we now
know agrees that there will not be
a residual cumulative impact that can be
classified as severe
not in mr flexman's evidence at all in
any case not in councillor eve's proof
of evidence
not in anyone's rebuttal
and not dealt with examination in chief
because he was talking about rectory
road but for the first time in
cross-examination
councillor eve mentioned a concern
that there might be the potential for a
cue to go back through the dayless road
roundabout at junction yes you recall i
do recall yes um and um
just just to pause um in respect of um
that point
just want you to please talk through
um the likelihood of the modeled results
in respect of cues and delays occurring
having regard to the number of reasons
that you set out in your evidence
and
and the potential impact of those
please having regard to the points
you've just made about 25 and six pcus
so first point please
peak spreading
yeah i'm just i'm just writing down a
few uh points here
i mean the first thing to note is that
this is just for a limited time segment
as well it's not for you know it doesn't
extend beyond this at the same level
um well in terms of people sorry just
sorry just just i am going to pause that
you just raised that point first point
single time segment
what's the significance of that when we
consider it considering residual
cumulative impacts
well it has to be taken in the context
of the
you know the wider network performance
over the p-car the whole day
um off-peak times as well and weighing
up all the benefits of the
sustainable measures
um
mr uh
sorry counselor eves yes when he raised
this he also said
that mr flaxman must have missed this
point
but if you look at the rebuttal proof
that mr flexman put to me
what he was talking about was a cue from
junction 3 going down the same road
to junction 4.
he did not miss the link between
junction 3 and junction 4.
and he's accepted that it's fine
yeah and just to be just to be clear in
respect of mr flexman's um technical
position and evidence to the inquiry
highway statement of common ground
number two
what's his position now in respect of
whether or not the residual cumulative
impacts would be severe
taking everything into account
his position is that he does not believe
there will be a severe residual
cumulative impact taking everything into
account
and in a paragraph before that he also
confirms he has no other issues
sorry i'll i'll come on to the point
about peak spreading right
just to recap
saving six pcus to get back to the
minimum allocation saving 25 pcus
to get back to full mitigation
so
i've actually got quite a few reasons
here that i'd like to to give you sir
um
as to why this queue will not be
anywhere near
as long as is forecast in this model
and i suppose i should also just point
out that when mr flexman raised any
issues we responded to them quickly
and had he raised this issue we would
have responded to it immediately with
the same issues they are within my proof
but not quantified in terms of trips or
percent or anything like that but
they're nevertheless very real issues
that i do mention in my evidence
and
okay mr flaxman's got no issues but he
probably knew that if he had raised it
this would have been the answer yeah and
just and just to be absolutely fair on
that point because councillor eves
produced a proof of evidence under
rebuttal proof of evidence
and you dealt with that you actually
produced a rebuttal evidence dealing
with councillor eve's points didn't you
mr blair well i had to do and and sorry
just a moment and if councillor eves had
raised this point prior to his
cross-examination so not even in his
examination in chief
but if councillor eves had raised this
point
would you have also responded to his
concerns mr blair
yes
right
the the reason why two proof two
rebuttals were produced was because we
we sought your permission for a slight
delay to specifically address
modeling agreement on junction 3
so it would have been wrapped up with
the same thing
peak spreading the effect of traveling
at a slightly different time
i will i'll give you these reasons and
i'd just ask the question i suppose
bear in mind could these make
the trips increase are they neutral or
would the trips go down because we're
only trying to chase six or 25 pcus full
of mitigation
and that's for full mitigation so just
to pause there do we need full
mitigation in terms of one one one of
the framework in any case i know the
highway authority are happy with this
performance worse than my model yeah but
but what sorry but what is this
test in the framework for nil detriment
no it is not
right so we have the 25 and six pcus 25
pcus to take it back down to nil
detriment and we don't need to go that
far in terms of the framework anyway but
that's what we will that's what we'd be
looking at
six to take it back to the minimum
allocation in the adopted plan yes so
that's the that's what we need to bear
in mind when we're considering these
points now peak spreading dealing with
that point first
mystic sorry councillor eves agreed that
peak spreading
had the significant a significant
potential
a significant potential
to bring down
those numbers you recall yes and he also
agreed that there was a potential for a
10 percent reduction
based on mrs wright's survey
correct now just like your comments
please in respect of peak spreading
and the potential for
it to be effective to bring down those
numbers do you disagree with councillor
eves in terms of those points uh no i
don't
right can i have your view please well
firstly 10 of 240 pcus is 24 pcus and
that's full mitigation
now in fairness peak spreading doesn't
shift things completely out of 15
minutes into another 15 minutes it
spreads it spreads it
so it wouldn't be that full of fact in
that in that 15 minutes
but we've heard other evidence from the
public that they've varied their times
of travel
the council's position originally before
it dropped the point
was that they didn't accept that it
would exist at all
now web tag modeling which is the big
scheme modeling
has modules within it which shift demand
if if this had been run using network
modeling that shifts demand out it's a
very simple
concept really people say i arrived
early to miss the traffic that's peak
spreading
and there's there's numerous
submissions to the inquiry of the local
people actually doing that
yeah
okay trip diversion please
uh
yes we've heard about alternative routes
and everyone's thinking about much wider
much further afield and that could
happen you know you could you could
drive down
prince avenue
up
up into rochford from the south and up
through the town center
[Music]
it's interesting that in the study area
between the anne berlin roundabout
and the whole street roundabout there is
another roundabout called south street
um
that was agreed not to be necessary to
study because the highway authority had
just upgraded it so it's not in the
study area
but if you look at the traffic counts
you'll see that
a significant number of people turn
right up into the town centre there
if anyone was coming up from the south
they can they can go up that way it
doesn't help us in this particular
southbound approach
what does help us on the southbound
approach
is that people driving down ashington
road can turn left at dallas road
and councillor shaw yesterday described
that that's exactly what she does
i know we're not talking about the queue
yet but the point is if you were
approaching
the roche avenue dallas road washington
road roundabout and there was the queue
that the model results are showing you
would turn left when you get to the
bottom
at this approach
the significant number of people are
turning left
i think there's another point i'd just
like to add in there as well if i may
another element why this is all robust
is because the trip generation is taken
from the site
sorry just just before you go on to that
one
um we've also seen a survey from mrs
wright in respect of trip diversion
does does that support
does that support the points that you've
just made
in respect to trip diversion yes it does
and second point
is that councillor eves
accepted that there was some potential
for trip diversion
do you agree with him in respect of that
yes
sorry i interrupted you next point
please
it's really to say that when we take the
trip generation emanating to and from
the site
we take it and we process it right
through the study area
it consequently assumes that no one's
stopping in the town centre or local
destinations we take we take one trip
from the side and we take it right
through the system and out the other end
so it's impacting at all the junctions
on the way
anyone from this side who's going into
the town center
they won't appear at that junction
sorry could you repeat that sir thank
you
i said that
we take the trip generation
from the side and we put it right
through the system so it comes out at
the extent of the study area
in other words a trip from a
through through the system and coming
out at b
but some people might want to go from
the site to the town centre
and consequently they could be coming
down ashington road up dallas road that
way sure yeah
but this but the model's robust because
it takes that trip and it puts it
through all the junctions to the
extremity
that's the point
okay
next point please
um
i drew the inspector's attention to the
number of trips which are associated
with education in the morning peak car
right so can we just get i can see
you're looking at a page there we have a
table 5.2 page 57 of the tv
so just on those figures twelve percent
of the cars in the morning amp car are
associated with education now we're
looking at a peak r here
between
7 15 and 8 15 and this this quadrant
this this period is the
8 to 8 15 period
when when we work on
residential schemes very large
residential schemes quite often you get
we'll build a school on the scheme
when we do that we then undertake trip
internalization
familiar with it but what it is is if
you're not driving off-site to get to a
school
then it's not a trip generated by
standard site leaving the site
we're not doing that here we haven't
taken any internalization because we
haven't built a school on site
but what's better for
trip reduction
a site with a school in it
or for schools with a site in the middle
of them
arguably five schools
we haven't taken any reduction from the
trip rates
to echo the fact that
lots of people will be within a very
easy walk of numerous schools
the trip internalization point
that we normally apply in assessments
you usually just build one school so
your your internalization internalizing
for maybe primary school trips or maybe
secondary school trips
but here we've got nurseries and infants
and primaries and secondary schools
so there's a far greater
potential
for the trip internalization effect
to apply here and reduce trips
albeits are
i don't suppose we should call it trip
internalization because there's no
school internal to the the site is
internal to the schools yeah
follow the point that you're saying yeah
and what sort of impact might that have
well uh
12 percent of trips in the amp car are
associated with with schools
um we've got
um
25
trips coming down to this junction from
the development if you were to take 12
of that you would have
well mental arithmetic three pcus
might be four um
just over three i'm sure yeah
okay and we know from the planning
statement of common ground that it is
plainly agreed that those schools are
all within walking distance of the site
that's all accepted and and we're
putting in new footways cycleways etc
yeah
good
um
next point you uh take a point about
home and flexible working um that in
re-examination in re-examination
counselor eve's
accepted i think he said would be the
norm by 2029
um but um your views please as to the
extent that those
changes in respect of home and flexible
working
might have
well well it's stark at the moment
really but that's that's for particular
circumstances but the trend is certainly
towards home working
flexible working
and the other one which falls under the
same heading is internet shopping
and we heard yesterday about the dearth
of
shops in the town centre and how they've
turned to charity shops etc internet
shopping's happening
as i say had we known about this we
could have
provided evidence in rebuttal but we
have things like the tricks guidance
note changes in travel behavior 2019.
um
i won't quote directly from it sir it's
a lengthy document that goes into
shopping et cetera but it's talking
about shopping trips being down 12
percent um all of the graphs
are
heading down i can advise you later on
that if you need a specific number
the general point is the world's
changing
and
trip rates are dropping
good um travel plan please um any points
in respect of the travel plan
yes um
i mean i should perhaps just go to the
travel plan if that's okay yeah
it's in one of my appendices
[Applause]
appendix seven
you
seven
you may have noticed sir from again
sorry i i'll need a page reference
because i've looked at the tabs in this
one there one four three sorry one four
three one four three
[Music]
and in fact i would
i would then go to 152 after that
i can't see one five two being tapped uh
well sir if you go to one four seven one
four seven is a good place to start
yeah okay okay
you may have noticed from the early
uh correspondence on this inquiry that
there were going to be three highway
witnesses for the appellant and one of
them was going to be a specific travel
plan expert
that's mr john hacker of tps
and
for various reasons this point being
accepted
it's ended up as mr hacker's work as an
appendix to my evidence and that's how
we're dealing with it
but
you'll see in the section 106 and here
that there is a
substantial travel plan and substantial
commitment to an effective travel plan
at this site
mr hacker has done
hundreds of these
the target is a 10 reduction in trip
rates
tps have been appointed already i.e
early
it's a good it's a good
travel plan and i would turn you to page
152 fma please
yep
and you you may be familiar but the
public may not be familiar with
an illustration called the travel plan
pyramid
it's a very simple concept
sets out a hierarchy
of the different aspects of a travel
plan which are likely
to lead to it being effective and
successful
so the foundation of a successful travel
plan is the location
if you have a site which is poorly
located you can fund buses you can
give people
information etc but if it's in the wrong
place
the preponderance to walk cycle
travel sustainably
is not as great
location's the most important thing this
site locations are great by all
to be highly accessible
the second level of the pyramid
second most important aspect is built
environment
and why is that because it lasts
we're putting in cycleways footways
upgrades to
bus stops real-time information
i think councillor shaw said yesterday
you could take the bus whenever they are
well they're foreign each direction and
that's just the main service there's
another five to southampton
service 60 sir
um
there's another five in our directly to
southampton it was mentioned
yeah i stand corrected
it's no wonder no one uses that one um
yeah
south end um interestingly the
hospital's a stop on that route
we were told yesterday that
people go to the hospital but they need
to drive the estimated journey times 12
to 15 by car 22 to 25 by bus
i i i digress a bit um
the built environments the second most
important element
and that's why a lot is being invested
in physical infrastructure
which will
remain and will make the travel plan
effective
the next most important level is the
coordinator they've been appointed
already in advance
highly experienced
then we have services and facilities and
you'll see in the section 106 so the
funding that's being provided there
and then the promotional strategy of
which
mr hacker will take forward in the final
travel plan so um just winding that up
looks like we have an effective travel
plan and it's one of the various reasons
why the trip generation rate out of the
site will not be as high as is reflected
in the robust trip estimates in the
model
just bear with me one second please
um
could you please turn up co-documents uh
6.1
6.1
so sorry
should have got you it's the core
strategy
um and i'm just going to take you to a
policy of the core strategy
actually i'll just read it out mr blair
it's fine
i'm just going to read out the section
to you to speed it up
um if you need to go to it you can go
and root through the boxes you give me
the references yes yes so it's it's
called document 6.1 yeah and it's policy
t5 travel plans
on page 110
um and um it says this mr blair
travel plans will be required for
development involving both destination
and trip origins
um
new schools visitor attractions leisure
uses large employment events were
required to devise an implemented travel
plan not relevant to us but then this
which aims to reduce private single
occupancy
car use
and then the travel plan will be
required for residential development
comprising 50 or more units and should
be tailored to meet the specific
requirements of the development so two
points in respect to policy t5
two points
first point
first point
has the council at any stage alleged a
conflict with policy t5
in respect to the adequacy of the travel
plan that's been produced no they have
not
second point
second point policy t5 expressly says
that the aim
is to reduce private single occupancy
car use
to what extent does the development plan
and its policies
the proposition that you are putting
forward to the inquiry
in terms of the potential for the travel
plan
to
bring those numbers down really
there is
another aspect to this as well that
i was saying that the target for the
travel plan is 10
that's 10 of the people who are coming
out of the site
or into the site
those sustainable
enhancements the built environment
enhancements the infrastructure
that's there
to the benefit of all the public in the
area for through through route
cycling walking
getting between the schools getting
between the residential areas and the
schools
so
those built infrastructure elements
may also reduce trips from the road
which aren't associated with the
development
and in fact they're being promoted
precisely for that purpose
okay
thank you very much
do you have it do you have any further
points uh that you'd like to raise mr
blair
um
in respect of this issue yeah let me
just uh let me just see
now it's really just a
an extension of that last point which is
you know if you
have the built environment the travel
plan all those other points together
they don't just apply
sorry that they don't just apply
in a reduction at this junction i mean i
i just counted there i've given eight
points
we talked about saving six pcus or 25
pcus
you know if they saved
two pcus each would have saved 16 and
that seems like a very modest
approach when you look at some of the
numbers
in terms of peak spreading in terms of
people who can diverge
the education school trips i'll not go
through them all again but
a
huge number of uh huge potential there
to divert but the point is
it doesn't just apply
on this approach those are trip
reductions off the network
and if i was to go back to
my appendix table 10
which is the results table sir
table 10 it was the
worst case results table that had just
remind me of the page
184
yep got it
you asked me the question earlier uh
was impact mitigated and i said it was
over mitigated
and that's the case if we compare the
final green columns
with the baseline
which is the
terracotta column
which begins 1.02 a directory road down
to 0.94
and we can see
that junction 1 is over mitigated the
junction 3
actually sir that
0.87 remains from the old assessment at
0.989
um because of mr flaxman's approach
but it's still
over mitigate it
[Music]
and down it and within roundabout
is over mitigated
but those over mitigations are derived
from highways improvements
the mitigations that we've just been
discussing through those eight reasons
are all additional
so not only are they not included at all
in the modeling
they are additional mitigation
so
they were over mitigated before they're
now
super mitigated or double mitigated or
you know however you want to describe it
because those effects will apply right
across the network
and if we want a benchmark
we can go to the highway authority's
position
where they said
in their report to council
at the time when they thought the rfc at
junction 4 was 1.37
that they thought those sustainable
mitigations when considered in the hole
was not only sufficient to mitigate that
they even went as far as to say no
detriment
now if they believe they're sufficient
to
mitigate a 37 well i call them percent
1.37
0.37 over capacity situation
those benefits apply likewise across the
network you can't
you can't mitigate junction 4 to the
tune of 0.37 and not mitigate
dallas road and roch avenue roundabout
on the way it's the same effect down
through the network
thank you and then um just to um
just to
pick up on the highway authority's
correspondence with you which i think is
set out in your
uh
yeah
appendix
b
volume 5 rebuttal
and it's the it's the one that's at if
you could call if you find appendix b
and then it's on page two at the top
yes
and what do the highways authority tell
us in that email of the 12th of january
2022
okay well the first thing to note
is that they were responding to my email
in advance of settling all the issues
with mr flexman this was the email where
i had said if the inspector was minded
to go with his rebuttal result of 1.13
what would the highway authority view be
i've reviewed the information below and
can confirm that the highway authority
agree with the points raised it is also
key to reaffirm that the application
must also be viewed holistically
and appreciate that the package of
network improvement measures to
facilitate
modal shift there's a typo there
form part of the highway highway
authority acceptance of the scheme
considering those points the position of
the highway authority remains remains
unchanged
and that the proposed allocated
development does not constitute
a severe cumulative impact
at the point of writing that
they hadn't seen my revised results for
all the other junction models they were
still working on the ace results
and they just they just thought that
this junction junction 3
had gone from a position of being over
mitigated to 0.9
had now increased to 1.13
and they were still
content that didn't constitute
very impact and i am afraid i'm going to
ask you to look at the core strategy now
so you are going to have to dig it out
i'm afraid
um
okay yeah i just asked mr pie crafty to
pass you pass you in a marked version
and um
it's page 105 core document 6.1
sorry what page in it at
sir thank you
and i just want to look at the this is
the trend i'm sorry just wait for you to
sorry one zero five one page one zero
i have it okay and we can see the
objectives there the objectives
of the council's
core strategy
in respect of transportation matters
objective just want to understand in
light of what you've you've said to what
extent we comply
with
some of these
so number one
to deliver developments that will reduce
reliance on the private car and that are
well related to the public transport
network yes that's achieved
to deliver
online improvements do we do we do that
well we do deliver online improvements
it says here on the east west road
networks but
yeah we do deliver online improvements
to
identify and assess locations in the
district that currently suffer from poor
highway connectivity and congestion and
work with the highway authority
to identify solutions
well we're in compliance with that
i don't think
the next one's relevant to us
uh
next one to ensure that all new
developments including residential
developments implement travel plans to
reduce reliance on the private car do we
do that we're doing that thank you
to work with the county council and
other organizations to ensure that a
safe accessible and convenient network
of cycle and pedestrian routes is
implemented across the district we do
that
we do that by providing routes and
providing contributions to strategic
routes
and then i'm not sure that the
well that
there's i don't think the next one's uh
particularly relevant
and then there's one about car parking
and we know now that the local planning
authority has no
uh
issue in of car parking correct thank
you very much so to what extent uh do we
comply
with the core
objectives of the core strategy
in respect to transportation matters mr
blair well we can play fully with all
the elements there that we can comply
with and the ones that apply to us or
could apply to us we comply with yeah
okay
i'm just conscious we've been going
about one hour 40 and i don't know how
far you are through this uh
um evidence-in-chief session
just bear with me a second sir i think
there are a couple of points yeah there
are if i just finish this point sir and
then we'll perhaps take a break and i
haven't got too much left but there are
a couple of points the rule six party
raise that i want to make sure that
we've
covered as well yeah yeah so just finish
this point and let me know when thank
you very much so um just just taking all
all that into account um all of those
points into account um mr blair
um and um just bearing in mind in
particular that 25 or six pcu point that
you have discussed
what is your position
on whether
post development and therefore
post
mitigation
measures
there will be an except an acceptable or
unacceptable impact on junction 4
in terms of delay or the likelihood of
queues backing through junction 3.
i think there would be an absolutely
acceptable impact
having gone through eight reasons
as to why development trips and indeed
other wider network trips
would move away from the busy periods
we would hope that it might even
be improved
now
i'm just i'm just simply trying to apply
some numbers and logic to the eight very
valid reasons that i've set out
individually
now then the the legal
the the test set out in case law
is that if the view of the highway
authority
is to be departed from
there must be clear and compelling
reasons
to do so
have you seen any clear and compelling
reasons
to depart from the view of the highway
authority
that firstly
the impacts will be acceptable and
secondly indeed
their judgment that there will be nil
detriment taking into account those
measures
i think their positions correct there's
no reason to depart from it i haven't
seen any evidence that would
lead me to that conclusion
uh has this point
made by councillor eves
been quantified
in respect of counsellory at what this
this point by councillor eves has he
looked because he he's queried the
effectiveness of some of these points in
his evidence
yeah
but but he accepts that there will be a
reduction
has he provided any evidence
to quantify his position
he's provided no evidence to quantify
that the only number he gave suggested
that we would save 240 sorry 24 pcus
through peak spreading alone
and so
does counselor eve's evidence does
counselor eve's evidence
represent
clear and compelling evidence to depart
from the view of the statutory council
team certainly not
and of course we aren't in any case we
aren't in any case looking
at the impact on one junction when we're
looking at framework one one one
we're looking at whether the residual
cumulative impacts on the road network
are severe
your judgment please in respect of that
point
yes there is no residual cumulative
impact
that is severe
all weighed up across the network
um it's beneficial
these these uh
built environment mitigations they're
working 24 hours a day seven days a week
to promote active travel
and
um
is that a position
no residual cumulative impact that is
severe across the network as a whole
is that a position
agreed by mr flexman firstly
yes it is
thank you
is that a position agreed by the local
planning authority's professional
officer in two reports to committee yes
it is
is that a position agreed by the
statutory council t the highway
authority
yes
is that a position
agreed by the
professional consultants that undertook
the transport assessment initially yes
and is that your professional opinion mr
black yes it is thank you what is the
professional consensus in this case
well it is
100
or total that all professionals agree
there is no
severe residual cumulative impact
on the local road network
and if we then turn up the framework
please just to
uh we've looked at paragraph 111
and we've looked at the
objectives of the core strategy
just want to have a quick look at
para 110
yes um and um it's in assessing sites
that may be allocated for development
development in plans so
would have been taken into account on
allocation
but also specific applications for
development it should be ensured that
and there are a number of criteria
a
appropriate opportunities to promote
sustainable transport modes can or have
been taken up given the type of
development in its location do we comply
with that yes we have yeah uh safe and
suitable access to the site can be
achieved for all users and we're going
to look at that in a bit more detail in
a moment but in summary
yes that's a challenge
yeah there's then a point about design
of um
streets parking areas and transport
elements any issue taken in respect of
those points no issues taken and that
can be achieved as it emerges through
the through the development of the site
and then any significant impacts from
the development on the transport network
in terms of capacity inject congestion
or on highway safety can be cost
effectively mitigated to an acceptable
degree that's achieved thank you very
much um so i do have a few points on on
some concerns of the rule six past it's
probably convenient place for a break
okay well it's fractionally after
quarter past let's go until um five past
eleven that's about a twenty minute
break so i'll adjourn now will resume at
1105.
thank you
should have said mr blair
[Music]
actually
yes
[Music]
can i ask you to take your seats please
ladies and gentlemen the inquiry is
resumed
so miss reed you said you got a few
further points to go through with mr
blair
thank you sir
um
i'm going to just deal with a couple of
specific points that have been raised
now by the rule six party
um
first point um highway safety issues
and the narrowing of the pavement
um outside the school can you can you
just i know you set this out in detail
in terms of your response and your proof
of evidence but can you just please
summarize your position
my summary position is that the proposed
layout is satisfactory
yep can you just explain why yeah sorry
um
well they took a look at it because it's
it's been raised by
various people in their evidence
and uh you know the starting position is
that the plan
the design is accepted by the highway
authority
um they said it would be it would be
satisfactory if it was greater than
three meters
it is greater than three meters um
i drew up a plan of dimensions there's a
bit of
a detected a bit of a misunderstanding
going around that it was being proposed
at three meters it isn't
the narrowest point
is
3.25
and then over 50 meters it goes up to
4.51
um
i don't know if this is appropriate or
not but i
got a tape measure out this morning
and measured between the corner of your
table and the corner of mr parkinson's
table
and that's 3.5 meters
we were told the other day that a single
buggy couldn't pass a double buggy in
that
it goes up to 4.5
meters at the
widening bit i took photographs of the
area in question they're in my appendix
too with dimensions
but
i gave this
some consideration and i noticed a few
things i've written down a list again so
i'll just go through them
the first thing is that we're also
providing new cycle routes through the
site so
people people could
ride bicycles north south through the
site we're not actually adding any
pedestrians or cyclists to that frontage
outside hold farm school where this path
is if you think about it no one from our
site would be walking on that part of
the pavement unless they were going to
that school
the school capacity is not increasing
the other point that you need to note is
that the ped cycle way at the moment
is three meters wide
so the section that we're providing over
this 50 meters is wider than what
already exists
now
i've put photographs in my
appendices again of the pedestrians
coming down at peak times
and there are the time lapse photographs
which show both pedestrians
and cyclists generally children
when i say generally children there was
one commuter in the morning peak who
cycled down the road
in the video
and there was one commuter in the half
hour peak
who
cycled down
the halt farm school frontage
and then came across at the token and
that was at about 22.
when i provided those
time snap photographs
um i just asked for them at five minute
intervals and i put them in to be sort
of fair and representative and i hadn't
actually looked at the detail of the
video but mr flexman asked for the video
and it was shared to him with the
privacy confidentiality agreement
and he looked through it and agreed that
they were representative i've
subsequently looked at it and they are
and that shows one cyclist
at 20 to 9
before it gets busy using the ped cycle
way in front of the school
and crossing at the token now
i've also
put in my proof of evidence
the full counts
because they were derived by ice from
the videos and those are in appendix
nine
and it was said yesterday that there's
hundreds of pedestrians and yes there
are
and those are the pedestrians that are
shown in the time-lapse photographs
and those are the pedestrians that are
expressed in those kinds but
as you can see from the time-lapse
photographs it's all over
from a very quiet situation to
a very quiet situation again in just
over 15 minutes
but it's interesting how it's used at
that time
because
there are
children on bicycles
the segregated white line doesn't apply
everyone just walks
wherever they want to or cycles wherever
they want to
but if you were trying to make that
super safe you would give everyone their
own personal carer and that's exactly
what they have
they're accompanied by their parents
at those busy times there's no commuter
cyclists trying to cycle through them
and when you look at the guidance
and even if you go to ltn 120 local
transport note 120 which is the cycleway
guidance
it tells you that you can have
a shared cycle facility three meters
wide
and the reference for that if if we need
it is um
it's paragraph
5.5 6.56
and you can have a shared
facility
where the through movement is slow
sorry say that one again where it is
slow
yeah slow um
and the design guidance
that it relates to
um
talks about 20 and 30 kilometer per hour
speeds but of course we're here at a
toucan crossing
we're at the end
of the cycleway on the west side of
ashington road
no one
cycles beyond that token on the south
side some of the kids don't get off
their bikes but they're safe they're on
their bicycles on the footway
so either people are slowing stopping to
use the token crossing
or they're getting off to walk on into
the school
so
the areas where
you can have a three meter shared use
is where it's slow near toucan crossings
for etcetera
where high pedestrian numbers and
cyclists exist at different times
well we don't have high cyclist numbers
at all and even if you go to the traffic
counts and look at
the cycle traffic along ashington road
where there are no cycleways it's it's a
handful it's not much at all
hopefully it'll increase in the future
when the new cycleways are put in
but it also says that the three meter
applies
for up to 300 cyclists mixing with 300
pedestrians
and what we have is a busy 15-minute
peak period
with one cyclist who was outside that
time
and that's for three meters and as i
said at the beginning
um we're going from 3.25 to 4.5
on an existing segregated cycleway which
is three
it's interesting to look at those still
photographs yes people stand around and
wait but you can see just where they do
that and it can easily be accommodated
within the
widths that are being proposed
thank you
next point raised by
sorry just in respect of
that issue
any dispute from
um
mr flexman
the highways authority
and now the local planning authority
into the safety
of that proposal
a short answer is no
no contention from any of them
the slightly longer answer is that mr
flexman wanted to explore that point but
when he saw the video he was satisfied
and he no longer retains it
um
next point raised by
rule six party um please
related to the
um
access onto percycottis road
um has that been the subject of a road
safety audit and what were the results
in respect of it
yes it has been subject to a road safety
audit and the process there is that a
firm of independent
auditors
go through the formal process
the road safety audit the express
purpose is to identify
issues which pertain to road safety
they did identify three issues but the
next stage is the designer's response to
that
so in the ta where the road safety audit
is set out
you'll also find the designers response
and their
addressing of the three issues
and have those issues being addressed
well yes the the the development will
accord with the recommendations of the
designer yeah
and then if we can again please turn up
the core
strategy core document 6.1
[Music]
and this time page 74. sorry mr mr pie
croft
provided last time i'll see if i can get
myself this time 6.1
think i've just got the wrong page
reference there
i've got the right page reference but
the wrong document it's called document
6.2 the allocations plan
got it page 74
and um
it's just just what the policy um
was telling us or is telling us sorry
about percy cottis
um road and it's paragraph 3.244
at the bottom of page 74.
i'll just read it out so everyone can
follow it says
if access in egress points to the south
at the site are considered acceptable
the arrangement of the roads on site
should be such that it would not
facilitate the creation of a through
route between ashington road and the
drive
cottis road as these are residential
areas to what extent has the arrangement
of the roads on site responded to that
policy requirement or can it that policy
requirement is reflected in the design
of the on-site roads they are in a
convoluted
so it would not encourage rat running
through
it's been laid out to avoid that
thank you
and
any issue taken by the highway authority
or the local planning authority
or mr flexman
in respect of the appropriateness of the
secondary access to percycotis drive no
issues taken
um
yes uh final
point please
um
in respect of rule six comments
they have
made reference to a ringway jacobs
report
and just just by
summary in summary do you have any
points to to raise in respect of that
report
yes i reviewed it when i saw the rule 6
evidence and i won't go to the
note that i made sorry
the note that i made i'll try and do
this from memory but
i read i read the report and i noticed
the important notes at the beginning of
it
which
said things like don't quote selectively
from it
it's prepared solely for the purpose of
the client essex county council
i saw that
the allocations were in it including sar
2 on our own side
um
i don't wish to quote selectively from
it but i saw that the site was regarded
as being
highly accessible with a good
[Music]
likelihood of achieving active travel
and sustainable bus uh
use
um but then i mostly just noted the
conclusions um which say
that it has been prepared solely to
inform
considerations for the local plan
and to
help
define the scope
for assessing
applications and developments as they
come forward
and
if you put those things those few things
together
what it means is the essex county
council
were fully informed in 2017
of all of the issues within that report
all the issues described by the rule six
party
and
the express purpose of it is so that
they would be
that well informed when it came time to
define the scope of assessment for
developments coming forward
that was in 2017
this application came forward
the scope was agreed in 2019 with the
highway authority
if anything what that report says to me
is that that highway authority was
probably better informed
better able to define an accurate scope
and form a view
than might normally be the case
and i think you mentioned previously
there's confirmation in the planning
officer's report
um that
the highways authority
checked the data the travel data
that had been collected
by the appellant
and confirmed that it was consistent or
inconsistent with the information that
they held now they said it was
considered i don't think they used the
word consistent i think that they
validated it against the database of
their own data and confirmed that it was
appropriate yes
and i'll ask
mr pycroft about points
relating
to the emerging plan and not you mr
blair okay um and
um final point then um councillor shaw
yesterday
confirmed that when she considered
um mata's um as a whole
the
proposal was
compliant with policies t2
scr8 insofar as it relates to transport
issues
because you're not concerned with the
remainder of it and dm 31. yes do you
agree with that i've reviewed those and
i do agree with that thank you very much
yeah and is the proposal compliant in
transportation and highways terms
with the policies contained in the
framework it is yeah
thank you very much mr blair if you wait
there i'm sure there'll be some
questions for you
yes thank you
so uh mr parkinson's just
double check you'd said um
i think you've said
an hour to an hour and a half sorry an
hour and a half to two hours
are we still i think we're on track for
that yes sorry still on track yeah
that's fine
okay in that case would you like to be
in your cross examination thank you sir
good morning mr blair good morning can
you hear me okay i can okay what i want
to do is divide this up into topics so
i'll just go through
what they are now so we know where we're
going
the first topic is the existing position
then we're going to do the correct
approach under paragraph 111 of the mppf
then we're going to do is the residual
cumulative impact severe
based on the modelled figures
and then finally
we're going to do can that situation be
improved and we'll cover there your
eight points that you went through in
evidence and chief
okay so that's the that's the agenda
we'll start off with the existing
position
and i want to establish
a few points that i think we can agree
at the outset so the first is ashington
road
is a key strategic route connecting
washington and rochford would you agree
with that
uh yes yeah
and on a wider level
ashton road is classified as a priority
one road by essex county council that's
correct isn't it i understand that yes
yeah and what that means is across the
district as a whole
it's one of the key traffic arteries
okay yep
and if we can just see that can you take
up cd 6.04
you might just have to bear with me a
moment while i get that sorry so i also
haven't given you a list i don't know if
it helps to have one now or just as we
go i don't think anything's too unusual
the point is table space is limited so i
i don't want too big a list because it's
uh too difficult to juggle them i've
kept open those we've had open already
so let's just do it one at a time just
pause each time so i can locate it okay
i'm struggling as well i've got i i'm
sorry
so it's um
i think
i can't remember if ms reed took you to
it was referred to i think is the
spatial options
consultation paper
cd 6.04
i think mr pycroft's going to hand you a
copy yeah i just don't see it here no
that's i think one's coming your way
and then once you've got that can you
turn to page 124
[Music]
and there should be a heading there road
connectivity
okay
let me know when you got that yes i've
got it
okay so we can read the paragraph the
district benefits from two main
strategic routes the a127 and the a130
which both act as economic corridors and
provide connectivity beyond our borders
to to the various locations identified
there and then there's this sentence
these are supported by a network of
important inter-urban boots
including the a129 the a1015 the a1245
and the b1013
warf lane ashington road and lower road
which together connects our towns and
villages to one another and that
description of ashington road is an
important inter-urban route that's not
something you would disagree with is
that's right
and ashington road is particularly
important
for north south trips across the
district that's right isn't it yes yep
and hall road junction junction 4 which
we'll come on to in a minute that's a
key junction on ashington road and in
rochford town centre
yes
and during
at least the am and the pm peaks the
ashenton road and the hall road
roundabout is already congested
i've seen cues there but it also
operates freely during the peak periods
at times
so in terms of whether
it would be a fair description to
describe the hall road roundabout as
congested or not in the am peak what
would be your answer would you describe
it as congested in the am peak well i
would say that there are cues at times
but i've also seen it operating freely
and the photographs in my
evidence show that and the accepted
traffic cue data shows that
okay well let's see what the plan
says
and then we'll see on what you you base
that judgment on and how how many times
you've been to the site so let's start
with the plan
cd
6.01 which is the core strategy
and once you're there if you can turn to
i'll let you get it first
56.01 yeah it's the course
um
you don't need the spatial options
document anymore i think you can put
that fully to one side so it's just the
cool strength the consultation paper
it's just the core strategy
um and if you can turn within it to page
107
i'm sorry can you give me this reference
again please yeah
no it's okay it's cd 6.01 it's the core
strategy
6.01 i've got the volume yeah and what's
the reference volume and then it's page
107. um
no
no no um
it's not six points
right thank you
yes yep and are you on page 107 i am
yeah brilliant and then you see their
policy t2 yes
now this is a
policy that was adopted in december 2011
10 years ago
and it says
the council will work with essex county
council or highway authority to ensure
that highway improvements are
implemented to address issues of
congestion road flooding or poor signage
in particular highway improvements to
the following will be prioritized and
you see the second bullet point down
ashington road to improve traffic flows
and reduce congestion now that's a clear
recognition in the development plan
isn't it that congestion on ashington
road needs to be reduced
uh yes yep and that's the position 10
years ago
i'm sorry i did tell you to put away the
um spatial options document that you
just had
if we can take that back up
there's cd 6.04
we'll be getting into the modeling soon
so there won't be as many planning
documents
6.04
6.04 page
um it's the same page we were on before
um
so
sorry let me just get it up i think it's
one two nine
hundred and
one two four you told me one two four
yes
so this is a paragraph we went to before
now this is a very recent document we've
seen the position 10 years ago
congestion needs to be reduced this is a
document from the last couple of months
same paragraph
um
after talking about the important
inter-urban routes including ashton road
is then a sentence can you see it
halfway down rochford's road network is
known to have congestion can you see
that
half halfway down the paragraph yes yeah
rochford's road network is known to have
congestion issues primarily focused
along the main routes detailed above and
at key junctions along those routes
now one of the main routes d is held
above is the ashton road isn't it
yes yeah and you've already said the
whole road junction is one of the key
junctions along those routes yes yeah so
this is a recent up-to-date position
from the local planning authority
confirming
that ashington road and the hall road
junction is known to have congestion
issues
i don't see the whole road junction
specifically mentioned it says
well let's let's do this in stages main
main routes detailed above are known to
have congestion issues that includes the
estrogen road doesn't it
because we can see that in the list
above yes yep
and you've already said yes it doesn't
break it down but you've already said
that the whole road junction
is one of the key junctions on the
ashton road route
yes yep
so putting the two together
this is a confirmation
that
both the washington road and the hull
road junction are known to have
congestion issues
i can see i can see why you would think
that but it doesn't say that
well can we at least agree that it says
that the ashington road is known to have
congestion issues yes yeah okay we'll
leave it there
because we also have finally on this
topic
the appellant's own transport assessment
and i want to go to the addendum so
that's cd 2.07
and once you're there if you could turn
to
page 14 and it's paragraph
250. yep
yep
so this is in the concluding section of
the
the report
and it says as per the conclusions of
the original assessment work contained
in the ta it's been demonstrated that
for the most part although the local
highway network is congested
and then it goes on to talk about the
ability to deliver the proposed scheme
without significant detrimental impacts
and we'll come on to that but this is a
recognition recognition in the ta itself
isn't it
that the local highway network is
congested
yes yeah and you care very carefully
went through in your proof we can go to
the section if you'd like
and went through all the parts of the ta
that you agreed with and disagreed with
and this was wasn't one of the parts was
it
the existing conditions section you gave
a tick and said that that provided an
accurate account of
existing conditions
well
i did my own site visits to see the
existing conditions but i would accept
that ashington road does have congestion
right and the whole road roundabout
as i say i've seen it flow freely at
peak times and i've seen cueing there
it's not congested all the time due to
my site visits or the recorded queues
okay well let's let's look at your site
visits and and what you saw
um we need to first of all
just establish the peak periods and
we're talking about because
that's an important preliminary step so
can you turn to
the ta so it's cd 1.14
okay can i put these other cds away or
do i um
you keep the addendum close the core
strategy
i think you can put away
um probably permanently
actually not permanently have that
have that within reach but not on the
table
yeah
bear with me as well i'm i can see where
the
ta is but
it's getting down to it
okay i'm ready when
and then it's um page 62
within the t8
yes
and um so we got there table 6.1
surveyed junctions and weekday peak area
peak hours
um and the amp carrier is the time when
the total flow through each of these
junctions was at its greatest is that
correct
oh yes
and what we can see is that the amp hour
is slightly different
for each of the junctions that's right
yeah
and i think that's where the typo on
your summary i think that's right
yeah okay
so if we just look the one that we're
i'm going to be asking you the most
about is um
the whole road and the amp car is 7 15
to 8 15. yes yep
a question we also have the ashington
road brackets link now can you just
explain for my benefit what's that's the
reference to
um
i don't know what that's a reference to
i think it's the distance between
rectory road and uh dallas road round
about
that that's
what i've taken it to be so it's not a
junction
it's not a junction it's the link
between the two generations between the
two junctions the two junctions okay
that's fine okay
so
and
you recognize i think that there are
times when hall road and ashton road are
busy outside of those modeled peak hours
that we have in table 6.2 is that
correct uh they are certainly busy at
times outside the model okay yeah
right
now
in terms of your personal experience you
visited the site in person on two days
you said in your proof and your evidence
the 9th and the 10th of september yes i
did yeah
and on the 9th you focused on i think
the end of the school day and the pm
peak is that correct well yeah i mean
what i did was i got there and witnessed
the the first school peak if you want to
call it that
i drove around the network with a
dashcam on so i've got the videos of it
all
second school peak i covered i went into
the school with my yellowjacket all
asked if i could have permission let
them know i was there took the
measurements that you see
drove around the network again
uh sat there with the dashcam on video
it was actually in the side road by just
watching the cars go past from about
four to four 445 and then i scoped the
network again
you weren't there
um 7 15 to 8 15 a.m on the ninth were
you that's what you did on the 10th
that's right
so on the ninth you focused on the
afternoon takeboard
and
pm
and pmp and in the
10th you focused on
the the morning so the morning peak and
until the morning after after 11 years
so whilst you visited the site on two
days in terms of your personal
experience of each of the peaks it was
one one day for each peak is that a fair
description uh my those were my
observations yeah
okay
so in terms of the amp let's focus on
that
um
if we turn to your proof paragraph 4.4.4
again just pause i know i know it's here
but it's buried
yeah i have that thank you
and we can see
paragraph 4.4.4 you say at 8 15 the west
street hall road ashton road round about
had a queue of 10 vehicles but none at 8
23.
see that
4.4.4 fifteen western washington road to
qf10
that's right yep now 823 of course is
outside the the modeled peak hours that
we've been looking at yeah yeah so
you've gone for 8 15.
um how and we can see a paragraph
4.4.2 that you noted queuing
at
the west street hall road round about
at 754.
see that
4.4.2 you say yeah yeah
yeah yes now i think this is right
because
i've sort of followed you around using
your dash cam photos and you can sort of
see where you're going like a cctv
sort of crime documentary or something
but am i writing saying that with within
the
am peak that we're talking about and
that you've modelled you went through
the whole road junction twice no well
let's
you tell me when you've gone through
because i've got you down as going
through when you first arrived at 754 as
you say at 4.4.2
and then at 815 and 4.4.4
yeah
if you turn to my appendix 3 yeah
photograph number one
again just bear with me it's paginate at
number
26.
age 26 in your volume one yeah okay 7.39
is that not
that's going along whole road under the
bridge to the
street roundabout
yeah
when i set out the photographs and
obviously when i wrote my text i had a
choice i could have put the whole video
in but i didn't want to do that
because there's six hours of it but i
was driving around the network
frequently and i put in shots that i
thought were okay so we got that
occasion
and then but then we can see that you
then
um went
so we can see the times so that's 739
but then you went up
which is in the p-car yeah yeah so
that's one occasion then you went up
bradley way round about the drive
went up the other side of the site yeah
then at 7 50 you're back on ashington
road opposite the school
yeah
then you're going up to rectory road
gold across shops
and then image 12
at hall road so that's our second
occasion
i would i would have to watch the video
back again because some of these
photographs are eight to ten minutes
apart and i was driving around the whole
time but every time that you went
through the whole road roundabout in
that period you noticed queuing didn't
you
well i noticed in photograph one there's
a queue of three yeah
and that had gone up to ten by eight
fifteen
so
i'm just looking at your proof four
point four point four 10. yeah
so in terms of the period that the
council's case focusing on the amp
you've had this one visit
on the 9th
and you've recorded the queuing that
you've seen
now you recognize and i think you
recognize recognized in your evidence in
chief that that's not a
particularly robust site visit the
further observation would be needed
which is why the the um video cameras
were set up is that correct
well i want to saw where the points were
emerging i wanted to have data outside
the school because no one else had any
data yeah and i thought that i thought
that that would be it but we're also
informed
by the traffic kind and the queue
surveys we've got queue surveys at that
junction every
five minutes i really appreciate that
i'm talking about your personal
experience okay in terms of your
personal experience we have that one day
the video that was set up outside the
school doesn't help us in terms of
conditions at the whole road roundabout
does it because you can't see that far
different location different location so
we have one day
now the inspector is going to have to
reach a judgment about existing
conditions yeah and take all sorts of
factors into account take your
observations on that one
one day take into account the q surveys
but you also accept that as part of that
the views of local residents who pass
through that junction every day needs to
be given weight well
i know that councilor eves
the inspector asked him on wednesday had
he gone down and it's very can i just
have a yes no do you accept that the
views of local residents i think
i think the inspector will hear the
views of local residents this inquiry
but
but we're talking about data versus
local experience do you accept that
those views of local residents who
travel through the junction every day
needs to be given weight by the
inspector
yes yes and those views
provide information that models can't
for example
the models won't take into account the
effects of bin day thursday will it
um
the model data was collected on a
thursday okay
inherently it does but it doesn't take a
kind of start stop behind a bin no and
it doesn't take account of road works
which is another issue that we've heard
all these factors that we've heard at
the inquiry all of these normal everyday
aspects of life on a highway yeah no but
they are something that the inspectors
you said needs to take into account and
give weight aren't they
um
[Music]
i would direct the inspector to the
normally
the normal standard approach of looking
at the models every road with a house on
it has a bin day
every road that gets repaired has
roadworks
the use of local residents and those
sorts of factors are something the
inspector needs to take into account to
give weight aren't they
yeah i've said i've said yes right
um
correct approach under paragraph 111 of
the mppf
okay if we take that up
yes
okay so i want to
just quickly run through how we approach
this
i hope that none of this will be
controversial but as soon as
anyone says that it turns out quite
often that it is but let's let's hope
it's not so
um the first point to make is whether um
an impact a residual cumulative impact
on the road network is severe or not
that's a matter of judgment isn't it
i said issue
and the mppf well neither the mppf or
the ppg actually quantifies
a threshold above which an impact is
severe or not severe that's right yep um
and nor does it prescribe what you have
to take into account by the fact that it
um includes the impacts on congestion
and capacity
well it's informed by residual and
cumulative yes but in terms of once
you've we'll come on to what residual
cumulative means in a minute
um but in terms of the factors that need
to be taken into account there's nothing
in paragraph 111 that says you must take
into account the following we're going
to go through what what they are in a
minute but in terms of paragraph 111
there's nothing that sets it out aren't
they
it says unacceptable impact on highway
safety or residual cumulative impacts on
the road network yeah and in terms of
the factors that we will take into
account would you agree that they
include
um queue lengths would be a relevant
factor
uh that's irrelevant
delay yes
the impact on overall journey times
yes
and the number of road users affected by
the impact
to consideration the availability of
alternative routes
yeah i would take that into account
okay
and we'll come back to some of those now
you mentioned residual and cumulative
residual
means well i would suggest it means two
things firstly the impact with
mitigation you've got to take the
mitigation into account i'm sure you'd
agree with that it's what's left over
after you've considered your impacts and
your mitigations yeah and also a
comparison between
in this case 2029 with the development
versus 2029 without development yes yep
okay now cumulative
that means again i would suggest two
things first of all taking into account
other developments which you do through
the growth factor in any committed
science so that what you're looking at
in 2029 takes into account
what's happening on other sides as well
yeah um well well our assessments
do do that but i don't see that as part
of this definition of cumulative okay
well maybe you you would agree with the
second one then which is that you have
to take into account what's happening on
other junctions as well and on the
remainder of the the road network those
are all factors that need to be taken
into account in assessing the cumulative
impact yeah yeah and overall yeah okay
now
if we look at paragraph 110 just above
paragraph 111
we can see that
um in assessing sites there may be
allocated development in plans or
specific applications for development
that's what we're doing it should be
ensured that a appropriate opportunities
to promote sustainable transport modes
can be or have been taken up given the
type of development in this location
yeah
now
simple point is
if those opportunities to promote
sustainable transport modes have been
taken up so you have a tick under
um paragraph 110 a
but
the residual cumulative impact on the
road network is nevertheless severe
you would still not comply with
paragraph 111 of the mppf
i'll say again so if it's not enough
to have taken up appropriate
opportunities to promote sustainable
transport moans
if having done so the residual
cumulative impact is still severe in
that situation you wouldn't comply with
paragraph 111
well
if the definition of cumulative is that
you've got to take all of those into
account then they will be taken into
account so
if there was a residual cumulative
impact after taking them into account
yeah then then that's what you'd have to
gauge
yeah so in very simple terms
you can have a severe residual
cumulative impact even if you've done
everything you can
in terms of sustainable transport and
mitigation in that situation you could
still fail to comply with paragraph 111
of the mppf even if you've done
everything you can to avoid it as a as a
development well there may be a theory a
theoretical development somewhere which
has done all that it can and has a has
an impact yeah yeah okay but we'll see
but you you agree that in principle that
that's something that could could advise
because there's there have been
um
questions and
points that have risen in terms of well
this development has taken up
all the sustainable transport modes that
that it can and it has got a travel plan
etcetera and there's boxes ticked there
the fact that all of that has happened
if the residual cumulative impact is
nonetheless severe the development would
still not comply with paragraph 111 of
the mppf
[Music]
yeah um
paragraph 111 says if the residual
cumulative impact is severe
then
it comes into force so if the final
position is
that the residual cumulative impact is
severe then it applies yeah okay
good
right let's move on then to that
question is the residual cumulative
impact severe
um i want to
do this in sort of two halves firstly
fairly briefly deal with the changes
since the planning committee
and then deal with the the current
modeling
okay
so
you've gone through this in your
evidence in chief but
i think it's fair to say that you've
made three main changes to the modeling
that was in the original ta um first the
revision to the temporal growth rates
yes secondly the revision to the trip
phones yes and then thirdly the
validation of the junction models
yes yep
okay so in terms of the third one
validation it's fair to say that's
correcting a mistake that was made in
the original
ta and taa
uh
substantially yes yep okay
in terms of traffic generation
um so trip rates um now you've
calculated this differently and we'll
come back to what you've done
when we look at your eight points
you calculated it differently but you
agree i think that the trip rates
provided in the original ta provide a
reasonable assessment of traffic
generation
well
they were reasonable in the sense of
providing a robust assessment everyone
agrees it's a robust assessment
ditto in terms of temporary growth
you've calculated this differently but
you agree that the approach that was
originally adopted is the standard
approach i think you confirm that in no
no
it was an approach and they took the
temporal
uh the different areas and got the
temporal factor but the point i made was
that that was double kind of our side so
i just fine-tuned it you fine-tuned it
but in terms of the original approach
it was a fairly standard approach and it
was an approach that the original ta
owns up to it's a fairly standard
approach for a robust assessment yeah
okay
so
on both of those whilst um you differ
from your colleagues at ace
about what's the right tempered growth
or the right trip frame you don't say
that the approach that they took was
inappropriate or unreasonable on either
of those factors do you it was overly
robust you don't say that it was
inappropriate or unreasonable it was
appropriate for what they were doing
which is a providing a robust assessment
okay
so whilst you've made some changes
they're ultimately judgment calls aren't
they
no they're led by data they're updating
and review yeah but they're not not
judgmental well they're your judgment i
mean we can see that
if we look at i'm so sorry to interrupt
sir this line of questioning um but none
of these points none of these points
were taken with councillor eves there is
no evidential basis for these points
being taken on the local planning
authority's case and there is a
statement of common ground from the
council's witness
agreeing mr flexman which has not been
withdrawn in terms of his evidence but
there's a statement of common ground
agreeing that he thought that these
matters were appropriate and finally
there's no evidence from him either in
respect of these specific points so so i
i don't understand with respect what the
evidential basis is for this line of
questioning well i think i think it's
it's reasonable for mr parkinson to
explore mr blair's evidence and i think
that that's where he's going this is
difficult i know because i don't know
where he's going to end up but at the
minute i'm content
to allow mr parkinson to continue i
think it's reasonable thank you
if we look at your proof that
5.6.1
your summary of this is i'm off the view
that the approach and actions undertaken
by a ceo are appropriate albeit i
believe they may they have overestimated
the impact on the highway authority and
the point of this and where i'm going
with this is that
whilst um
you you've taken a different approach
and you believe that they've
overestimated the impact
their figures are not unreasonable and
they don't fall outside a reasonable
range of what the inspector can take
into account when judging the traffic
generation and the growth on the network
you wouldn't say that the the ace
figures are unreasonable
i i have said here that they have
overestimated the impact on the highway
network which because it comes from the
standard modeling and the data that's
put into it
means that the figures they put in are
too high are you saying that the
approach taken in the original ta was
unreasonable there is an approach which
is a methodology yeah it's an absolutely
scoped out standard approach
but the figures that they've put in are
too high are you saying that the
original
temporal growth
factor and trip rates adopted in the ta
was unreasonable
at that point in time
that was the standard approach they took
i've identified it as being too high
it's not an unreasonable approach it's
an approach that leads to an
overestimate and a robust assessment
not an unreasonable approach but we can
then
see what that
does when we look at the modeling later
okay
now let's look at where we've got to
um on the current figures so it's your
volume to page 54.
sorry giving that one again appendix
sorry volume 2 page 54 it's the summary
table
that in technical note
3. it's the one
volume 2 so that's this one page 184
no i think i must have i've got the
wrong bit there so must be this one
so it's the um
no it's not summary table that looks
like this yes ah that that's appendix 14
isn't it yeah yeah right
yes so
it's in
this one yeah okay i'll get there
eventually
remind me of the page number it's page
45.
yeah 45.
okay thank you
um okay mr betsy you've confirmed the
amp
um 715 to 815.
[Music]
um and what we're looking for
what we're comparing is the bottom row
2029 with development compared to the
the row that says 2029 baseline tt
validated model
tt
tempo
and then we can see as well the
ace figures
in the kind of move color
so their 2029 bass line
and that that
row there that corrects the mistake on
the geometry does it where it says tt
validated model
so the road that says 2029 baseline tt
validated model that's taking the ace
temporo
but correcting the geometry area error
[Music]
yes yeah and the row below that again
is with the development
with the geometry error corrected but
using the ace temp pro slash trip frames
yes okay
right
now
the headline figure for
junction 4 in terms of
ratio to float ratio flow to capacity
is um
we don't need to go to it it's in your
table at page 184 but the rfc goes from
1.06 in your 2029 baseline to 1.15 with
the development
yes yep
so
the junction is 15
over capacity and nine percent of that
uh that's nine percent more than in the
baseline no development position
yes could it could you just make one
clarification the 1.15 is on a different
road at a different peak
the washington road in the mornings this
1.141 yeah 1.4 one point one four one
two one yeah okay
right
now in terms of i just want to go for
this table and just understand what what
the how the figures are calculated and
then we'll look at some of the more
detailed modeling
average delay that is
as you explained in chief the hours
divide being divided up into 15 minute
segments
and what's recorded in this table is the
worst delay out of those
15 minute segments yeah okay
and
um
that's an average delay so that's the
mean delay
per
pcu
yeah so half the time that delay will be
greater conversely half the time
the delay will be less than that it's
it's the mean delay per pcu
um
i i don't think it means that i think it
means it adds up the delay for each
person
and
well yes okay it's the is the average
it's the mean
yes
yeah
okay
then can you see at the bottom
there's um if we look at for example
2029 baseline tt validator model tc
tempo
we have the average delay for each of
the arms
and then at the bottom there's a figure
77
which counts 3 is referred to
and we can see the equivalent figure in
2029 with development 213. you see that
that's right yeah now am i right in
saying that that figure there is the
average delay at the junction
across all of the arms but across all of
the time period so that's not
a 15-minute segment period that's the
entire hour that's been recorded there
uh i believe so yes yeah okay just
by all means check i'll just yeah
it's reporting differently in three
places it's reported as the maximum
delay in the actual detailed results
so
if you're if you're going for average
it's it's actually reporting as maximum
delay in the detailed results
can you show me that yeah page 231
sorry page 221 did you say two three one
two three one
but i i think this is a confusion or
potential confusion i wanted to clear up
where it says max delay yeah in this
that simply saying
across the 15 minute
time segments that's the maximum figure
it doesn't mean
that that figure there isn't an average
are you at page 231 i'm at 231 right so
you'll see that in the detailed tables
at the bottom it's giving you delay in
seconds yeah
and if you go across to the next period
yeah you'll see that the
delay in the final quarter is the 450
number yeah yeah but it's it's
significantly less
through the other three quarters so
if you look at the table above those
four quarters in other words
bang in the middle of page two three one
yeah
you will see that it's quoting the
maximum delay of 450.
yeah so when when that appears here yeah
in this table it's the maximum delay out
of the whole hour
hang on it's the maximum the result
summary table ashiton road 450.63
okay
that correlates
with the
delay on the ashton road arm in the
period eight to eight fifteen yeah
yeah it just that
is correct right okay yeah now
in terms of how the delay is calculated
in that period
8 to 8 15.
that 450
seconds
is the average delay within that
15-minute time segment
it's it's the delay at the end of the
time segment it reports the end result
if we take for example um
right
and then
the maximum delay in this result summary
table
that is recording
the worst delay out of the 15 minute
time segments in the hour yes yeah okay
and that figure then is put into your
summary table
yes yeah okay
but my question was the average delay at
the bottom of your summary table said a
77 and a 213 yeah yeah sorry yes and
that's the average for the all the arms
so yes
junction yeah yeah okay right
now
we just do the same exercise with cues
you can see
the bottom of your summary on page 45
2029 with development it says maxq118
yes if we then go to your 231
we can see
it's the same time segment eight to
eight fifteen we can see the one one
eight because that's the queue
at the end of the
last 15 minutes segment
yeah and because if we flick back that's
the worst cue that then gets put in the
summary as
um
the 118 figures but what i just need to
clarify
is whether that one one eight figure
whilst it's the maximum
q in the
recorded hour whether that 118 is
recording
or what what exactly is it recording
because
my understanding is that is recording
the average
queue
over that last 15 minute segment if we
just go to mr flexman's rebuttal
we can see
the user guide on this
um i don't have mr flexman's uh
in front of me um
i have it but it's very much buried
in fact i should have it just one second
all right
[Music]
yeah i'm okay
okay and if you look within that
paragraph 2.28
there's an extract here
from
the user device
you see that
2.2.2.8 figure one
yeah yeah and let's just see what this
says
the basic calculations performed by
junctions nine are of mean cues and
delays
expected at particular time of day
averaged over many occasions now
my understanding of this and if
if we're not sure then we can check you
know outside of this but my
understanding of this
from the user guide and
looking at the figures
is
how this works and tell me if i'm wrong
is
page 232 of your
um
appendices
we have
a figure there for delay of four
yeah we have a figure of their of delay
within that time segment
of 450 seconds
we also have the q at the end of that
time segment of 118.
both of those as per the user guide are
mean figures
then
in the results summary table
we record
the max delay
and the max q
and that simply means it's the worst
figure recorded out of the time segments
but those figures are themselves
mean figures
is that correct um
i don't think that is correct
and i see the quotes that mr flexman's
put in his proof and i see the graph
that he's presented to show the
variations
and uh i don't think it is correct
why
well mr flaxman's been quite careful um
if you look at 2.2.8
yeah
when using a
synthesized traffic demand
yeah
he then at 2.2.9 says
for example
i'm i'm quoting i'm not no no no i'm
he's he's
using the wrong part of the user guide
we do not have a synthesized
demand
the issue with a synthesized demand is
that when you put in
one hour's worth of data yeah
the modeling software
predicts that there will be a peak
within the peak right so it throws a
curve into it and you get a synthesized
demand yeah some of the r's higher some
of the r's lower yeah
we didn't do that ace put in a flat
profile they said it was going to be the
same for they are yeah
the highway authority said
no
yeah do it direct that's what the taa is
about yeah
mr flecksman has been very
careful with his language you'll see
he's clear that it's for a synthesized
traffic demand
229 says for example
2 2 1 0 says in the above example now i
don't know how mr flexman got this chart
because
coincidentally
the median line
which he says
is just an example
peaks at 79 and he sent this to me when
he was talking about
a queue of 79
at dallas road sorry i need to finish
this yeah
so he has synthesized
that queue variation
and he has then provided that quote
at 2.29
which if he had included
the next sentence said don't use it for
direct proof don't use it for direct
entry okay i mean so this is wrong right
sorry
just so my notes complete there where
you said that don't use it for direct
entry where's that it's not on this
because he's he's cut the screen shot
off before it's said
i can provide you with a copy okay all i
wanted was clarification on whether the
118
and the delay
what that's a record off and whether
that's maximum or mean it sounds like
from what you're saying is maximum but
if we could just
resolve that outside of outside of this
it's just a question of getting
confirmation of that i can tell you what
i did when i got this i sent a letter to
the trl the software people right
and they've written to me to say
that
it's the it's the figure reported at the
end of the quarter
okay right and as you can see the queues
are growing so i think at that point yep
it's it's the maximum is the maximum
okay well we'll come back to that q
growing point and what that means in a
minute okay fine
um
that's that's fine okay let's see what
we can draw from
these more detailed results at page 231
um the first point to make is that on
all arms of the junction there's an
increase in delay and queuing
with the development in 2029 compared to
without the development
on on this model yeah on this model yeah
and this is the model that you're
putting forward to the inspector
well
i'll just clarify that again
it's the model results that we
submitted
that mr flexman agrees with that didn't
didn't take a point on but
had
we known that this particular point was
going to come up i haven't made any
point yet i'm just asking that on all
arms of the junction there's an increase
in cues and delays that's all
the point i'm making is that that's on
the basis of this model and and had
acute delay
had a cue and delay point being been
raised here we would have taken account
of the numerous factors that would have
reduced these figures
yeah we're going to come through your
eight factors in a minute but in terms
of
where we are today this is the
appellant's position
this summary table these are the pellets
models you've made your tweaks these are
the model outputs there's no suggestion
that this is going to change is there
we'll come on to your eight factors peak
spreading alternative routes etc but in
terms of the modelling results this is
the appellant's position isn't it
those those were the that is the
position that we submitted
as a robust model right yeah
at the time but then this point was
raised there's no other model out there
that i haven't seen this is this is the
summary of the appellant's evidence and
the appendage model
it's it's what's before the
inquiry because we didn't have a point
to report okay but that's what i'm
interested in what's before the inquiry
so on all arms
there's an increase in cues and delay
okay
now the second point is um
[Applause]
this point about the individual segments
so let's look at page 231 where we get
the breakdown per segment
and what we can do is we can do a
comparison between page 231 which is
with the development
and page 223
which is the base case without the
development
so 223 is the same
figures but without the development is
that correct uh yes that's right yeah
okay so let's look at the ashton road
arm
715 to 730
delay goes up from 51.7 to 87.9 is that
correct
sorry
let me follow that
i'm on page 223
yeah 7 15 to 7 30. the ashton road it's
the um
penultimate
column okay yeah the 51 delay yeah
i'm so sorry to interrupt certain again
you may want to hear it in which case
that's obviously fact but i i
specifically asked councillor eves if he
was taking a point in respect for any of
the other time segments he said no and i
didn't therefore explore further points
with him in respect of other time
segments now it's it's therefore too
late for me to explore other time
segments with the council's witness and
further there is no information in any
of the proofs of evidence or rebuttals
in respect of other time segments
i do accept that but equally this is
evidenced before me and and if mr
parkinson wants to get mr blair's views
on
these bits of the evidence then i i'm
keen to hear what mr blair says so
i don't think it's unreasonable it's
information that's before the inquiry
and i just need to
understand mr blair's response to
questions that mr parkinson has put into
him on it
so 7 15 to 7 30 delay 51 up to 87.
if we flick between yes we've got it yep
then 730 to 745 delay
up from 101 to 226. is that correct yep
yep
and then 745 to 8 to lay up from 119 to
338
and then the final
segment
up from
138 to
the 450 figure
yes yeah so in all time segments
there's a material increase
in delay with the development compared
to without the development
that's right
okay and we do the same thing with cues
just so we can see
how this works across the hour
um the
baseline case the end queue
and you've clarified what that means
thank you
in 750 to 730 is 19.4 pcu
yes
and that then goes up
to um 39.5
yep
and then
745
23.3 goes up to 63.
then 745 to 8 goes up from 27 to
89.6 yes
and then final period 139
to our
friend 118.
yes yeah okay so again across all time
segments in the hour there's a material
increase in queuing
um
that's that's correct do you mind if i
just make a quick
calculation please
okay yep now
just a quick question for my
information
uh next to that there's a box that says
unsignalized level of service
and these have f next to them what does
that mean yeah that is just a general
parameter for how the junction is
working at that time and f so is a low
level of service
is is there anything below it no okay
and what does f stand for what is it
what's the kind of explanation of what
an f level of service means uh i i don't
have the specific quote but if you do
i'm happy to hear it you know
it's probably printed out in one of the
uh the sheets here it's not actually um
which one i was asking that's fine okay
so that's point one material increase
and cues and delays across the hour
then i want to deal with this
well it's all the last 15 minutes and
there's only 25 additional
vehicles in that period
um
you said and
when i was doing my
maths i reached the same figure that
across the hour
there were 103 additional cars arriving
at the junction because of the
development
okay
and they spread
across the time segments don't they so
um
they're roughly 26 additional cars
arising from the development in each
time segment i
did it 26 then 25 then 27 and 25. so
he's fairly consistent yeah okay
right now let's just see
how this all works because if we look at
page 232
so this is with the development
can you see
the
column that says junction arrivals
it's next to total demand
are we looking at the right
are we looking at the same thing um
there should be a column that says
junction arrivals and then has ashington
vote 240.
on page 232. we weren't looking at the
scene we weren't looking at the same
thing okay okay
yes yep so this is
140 pcus arriving at the junction in
this quarter of an hour period is that
right 240. okay what did i say you said
140 240 240 arriving
and then can you see the column that
says throughput
yes
and throughput is 211.
yep
so two we have 240 vehicles arriving 211
get through the junction
yeah yeah now if you do the maths if you
take
and
240
minus 211 you get 29.
yep yep right
so
can you see that there's
a box that says start queue 89.6
yeah that's the queue from the previous
quarter yeah exactly
so at the beginning of this quarter we
already have a queue of 89.6 pcus
we have 240 pcs coming along only 211
can get in so our 29 get added to the
back of that queue that was already
there at the beginning of the period
well
25 get added to it and the queue becomes
29 longer yeah the queue becomes 20 so
we're up in this sort of exponential
area yeah the q becomes 29 longer
because if you add 29 to 89 you get the
118
right
and that's a very important point isn't
it that at the beginning of this period
15-minute period there is already a
queue at the junction of 89.6
yes because let's just track back where
that cues come from and what's caused it
that q at the start of the period
is the end of the queue
at 8 o'clock segment yes yeah
and the beginning of the queue at the
745 segment is the end of the queue at
the previous 15 minutes and you can
track it back and forth right yeah
and if i if i could just say that's also
the proof that these are reporting the
figures at the end of the quarter
because it's taking those into the next
quarter yeah yeah yeah
so
we've got to bear in mind
that in each of these quarters we have
25 additional cars
yes as a result of the development yes
yep
and the reason why
so we have 25 cars um
as a result of the development
that queue that we have of 118 at the
end of the hour
that is a product
of what's happened between 7 15 and 8
o'clock isn't it because
between 7 15 and 8 o'clock the junction
is operating over capacity which means
that the queues and the delays are
getting bigger and bigger and bigger
which means that
when your 25 vehicles come along at 8
o'clock
we've already got
a queue of almost 90 pcus yeah yeah okay
so it's not right is it to say
let's forget about anything before 8
o'clock and let's just focus on the 25
pcus between 8 and 8 15
because they are joining
a junction that is already over capacity
and already having significant cues
that's correct isn't it
the the queues continue to arrive and
will build
up to the point where the network flows
go down yeah
but
yeah but what we need to focus on is the
103 additional cars across the hour
because this isn't a problem that just
suddenly springs up at 8 o'clock this is
a junction that is over capacity
through on the ashiton road arm
throughout the entire hour which is why
we have increased delay in increased
queues
the queues are building because of the
additional traffic that's added to the
back of it yeah from seven o'clock from
7 15. yes
right
and that additional traffic includes
your
103 additional vehicles doesn't it it
does right so we need to focus on the
103 additional vehicles that means that
this junction is over capacity from 715
don't we
yes yeah okay
right
and then if we just look at where we are
at 8 15.
we're in a situation where
we have a q
118 delay of 415. that junction isn't
going to revert back to where it was
at the beginning of the peak hour
immediately will it there will be a
period where it'll step back down a
period when it will step back down okay
fine
right
um
fine so we'll come back to the 103
figure because your
eight factors
to take this down to i think you said
betterment but your eight factors to
take this junction down to nil detriment
or betterment or something in between we
actually need to reduce um the flow by
103
angles don't we
to achieve total
mitigation of 103 you need to offset
103. 103. that's what you were talking
about offsetting
and it was 25 so it's now 103 isn't it
no it wasn't it was 25 in 15 minutes and
we still need to offset 25 and 15
minutes but you will see in every
quarter in every quarter that's the key
thing isn't it it's in every single
quarter so it's 103 overall yeah right
okay
fine
let's deal with um this
topic of blocking back and can we just
establish the the factual points first
can you open up mr
flexman's rebuttal
just
sorry if you could just bear with me
can you give me the page you're going to
oh sorry it's page six
okay
right i just want to focus on
the factual points rather than
anything else because i appreciate
you've got your your eight points that
mean this won't happen i appreciate the
point about how the points are risen but
let's just deal with with the point so
we can understand it and i want to take
your view on
on um what you say will happen or not
happen
so
2.2.13 the distance between the
northbound giveaway line of junction 3
and the inscribed circle junction 4 is
410
meters now going the other way the
distance is similar or exactly the same
isn't it
yes yep
yep okay
um and to work out the length of that
maximum q at the end of the peak hour
the 118
using the favorable pcu length we times
118 by
5.75
yeah
which takes us to 6
7 8 0.5
okay
so do you agree that as a matter of fact
if
what your
you've modelled happens on the ground
at 8 15 there will be a queue
that goes back and extends well beyond
daley's road
from the issues at junction 4.
on on the model which is 118 q that goes
back through the roundabout right yeah
that goes back through the roundabout it
goes back through the roundabout
between the period of
8 and 8 15
but if we just have a look
at
the 7 45 to 8 period
the your 231 again
and we can see ashington road on
eight o'clock
q length uh 89.6
if we times that by 5.75 we get
515
meters so again beyond
daily's road
yes
now what that would mean on the ground
is that if you're traveling down action
road towards the town centre
you will not be able to travel through
junction 3 because the exit of the
roundabout will be blocked by traffic
that's queued back from washington road
uh hall road roundabout that's correct
isn't it you wouldn't be able to go
straight ahead into you wouldn't appear
but you could turn left yeah but you
wouldn't be able to go straight ahead
would you
we'll come on to alternative routes et
cetera in a minute you wouldn't be able
to go straight ahead that's right okay
now
rkd as i understand it models junctions
in in in isolation it doesn't deal with
interactions or effects between
junctions is that right that's right
right now you said that they could go
left but in terms of the modeling the
modeling all assumes that they've got as
councillor eve says free flows they can
leave
the junction and travel on down ashton
road towards junction 4. that's right
yeah so the blocking back effect isn't
captured in the the modeling is it
that's right okay fine
so
i appreciate you've got your eight
factors but that's the the agreed
position okay fine
and what that will mean is if we look at
um
the 745 to 8 am position on page 231
we've got
sorry this is the wrong page this is
junction forwards now we need to go to
junction 3.
um so let me just get the reference
this is page 186
sorry 1 8
186 186
so this is
your
this is slightly out today because of
the changes with the rebuttal i think
but it's your junction free with
mitigation
what i wanted to go to was the
junction of rivals that presumably would
that be changed by the mitigation as
well or not not south point
not southbound not southbound right okay
so we can do that so if we look at
it's page 189
ashington road north so arm-free so
that's
southbound yep
we have in the period 8 45 to 8 o'clock
256 pcus sorry
you said 8 45 to 8 o'clock sorry 7 47 7
45
yeah yeah
7 45 to 8 o'clock
we have 256 arriving pcus
yep yep
and then in the period 8 to 8 15 we have
231 arriving pcus yes
and those are all arriving pcus that the
junction assumes
um so the modeling assumes will travel
through the junction they won't be able
to so that will manifest itself as
queues won't from junction free
backwards
it's a cue but traffic's still
progressing through
what it would be
it would be a key it would be the
queue's there but it's moving yeah it
might be moving but it would be cars who
want to travel through the junction but
can't
yes that you would have a queue starting
a whole road
traveling through junction 3 and then
beyond junction 3
up the road because these additional
460 whatever pcus aren't able to travel
through junction 3 as anticipated in the
modelling
i i
i don't think that's right
tell me about the position okay because
if you have
um
let's use 231
if you have 231 coming down ashington
road in our model yeah that comes from
our trip generation and our network
flows yeah
it's the same 231 that then goes on down
the road and is in the queue at
the whole road
so
it's not
building the same traffic it's
it's the same it's the same trips and i
tried to explain this earlier for a
different point yeah
it's it's a pipeline if you want to call
it a throttle or whatever you know um
those trips coming down the road
approaching that junction then go on
through and those are the same trips at
the junction at the bottom now there
might be a minute difference but it's
substantially the same volume of traffic
it's not added on to the back no but
what about the next 15 minute time
segment when you have a new batch of
trips
it's coming through
so
you you've been in a position i think
you've agreed the cues the queues from
back from whole road yeah in that time
segment are the trips
that are assumed to be the same coming
right through right i take a point yeah
so okay yeah that's fine queue back
through the roundabout but you can't add
them on an infinite otherwise 200 trips
coming out of the development would end
up with a couple you know a thousand
trips yeah but you would have a queue
from hall road back through daley's road
and extending then in that last period
about 200 meters on beyond daley's road
towards the site
on the basis of that one morning on the
basis of the modeling yeah and then we
need to look at
your eight um
factors
yes
on that um
so i don't know what we're doing in
terms of lunch but i mean this is a
natural
pause and it is still twenty two
so um
how much more do you think you've got to
go
probably
another
hour or so
another hour um 12 40. well if we have
we i mean we could have a an early lunch
now we obviously had an early start if
we were to come back if we would have
um
trying to cut it down a bit if we had 40
minutes for lunch is that acceptable or
do people want longer than that that
would bring us back at 20 past one
we can go to half past one i'm just
conscious of you then got another that's
half
good to hear from mr foster
re-examination pushing things on
should we say 20 past and see
how that is okay so i'll adjourn then
now we'll resume at 1 20. okay
[Music]
well it is 20 past one so the inquiry is
resumed ladies and gentlemen
um
mr parkinson just before you continue
you say you've got you think about
another hour up to an hour with
mr blair mr foster have you formed any
view as to the length of time you think
you might want to put questions to mr
blair
declining because some of the things
have been covered yes i'm guessing an
hour but it's a guess an hour that's
going to take us till 20 past three
isn't it there and then
okay
any of the interested persons who spoke
earlier in the week have any questions
for mr blair
i can only say that haven't already been
put but obviously they've uh
he's not had the full range of questions
to him yet
sorry sir would i be writing
assuming that the
air quality
thing will now get slipped into next
week almost certainly yeah
yes yes
okay thank you
okay yeah of course you don't know how
much re-examine no not yet at sorry well
sorry sorry it's just um
[Music]
um
no i think it's mine actually
right i think that's okay can i be heard
is that okay can everyone hear me with
it here
right that's okay
um it was just in respect
it was just in respect for our air
quality witness and if we i mean based
on those timings i would anticipate it's
unlikely that we're going to get to him
today i don't know i think almost
certainly not today yeah definitely it
was it was really just so we can give
him an indication so he's not sat around
him down sand him down for today and
back on yeah well on the basis of the
timings i've just been given then we're
going to go later than i wanted to
anyway it would be good obviously to
finish to finish off mr blair
yeah politely yeah
yes i i don't think we're we're likely
to get to air quality today and and
obviously when we do get to the end of
today we'll then just have to have a
review as to how we're going to progress
next week if we're still on target for
what we said yesterday okay thank you
i'll um we'll pass that on to him okay
thank you
right i won't delay matters anymore then
so mr parkerson would you like to
continue thank you sir good afternoon mr
bear good afternoon um i just want to
where we were before lunch we talked
about the queue back from junction 4.
and we're going to go on to your eight
factors i just want to ask a few
questions just to clarify the extent to
which those factors need to work in
order to avoid this issue
um so the first thing i just wanted to
pick up with you is you mentioned that
this cube battlefield juncture 4 will be
a slow moving queue it won't be
stationary traffic
have you still got mr flexman's rebecca
up in front of you i do not
um if you could get that
sorry about this could you give me the
core document reference
it's not a core document it'll be
separate i think i'll dig it out of my
own my own system here
okay
and then can you go to paragraph 2.2.14
on page six
and if you recall we've so we calculated
the 678 meter q on the basis of pcu
length measurement set 5.75
but given your comment that this will be
a slow moving crew if we just read on
he says in practicality
in the queue of slow moving vehicles one
is likely to observe some gaps between
vehicles which are much larger than
would be the case based on 5.75 meters
which assumes hardly any gap now
as a matter of practicality do you
agree with that proposition that we have
a slow moving queue there are going to
be some gaps between vehicles for safety
reasons and other factors as well well
the way i understood it was 5.75 was a
standard pcu six six meters was a
typical
pc using queues
so you would take this if it's a slow
moving queue the 5.75 will go up to six
potentially yes okay it depends you know
people people can punch up as well yeah
um if we just
so that would be then
708 meter cue
okay yep okay
thank you um
right
now in terms of what
needs to be done to deal with this
problem can we just clarify in the
baseline position that the problem
doesn't arise at all there would be no
blocking back
oh yeah you can put that one side the in
the baseline position in 2029 there
would be no blocking back
as far as junction three we can go to
the
trigger if you want yeah okay fine
and
um the distance
between
junction 3 and junction 4 and pcu terms
is 71.3
pcus yeah
so anything more than 71.3 pcus we have
this blocking back to junction free
if you're not taking into account any of
the eight reasons and yes if you're not
taking into account any of the other
reasons okay yeah
so
um
118 pcuq
in the
last quarter of an hour
of the
hour
uh minus the 71.3 pcu which is the
distance between the two junctions
gets you to
46.7 pcu
just check you're happy with this so
the pcu
q length
and the n815 is 118 pcus yep
the number of pcus needed to avoid the
blocking back effect
is 71.3
yep
so the difference between those is 46.7
[Music]
so to avoid this effect which doesn't
occur without the development
in the peak hour
we need to reduce the number of um
trips by
46 points sorry the number of pcus by
46.7
i'm not sure we'll go about it that way
well let's just
118 pcu is the
q length
yeah from junction 3 function 4 back to
junction 3.
the distance between junction 4 and
junction 3 is
um 71.3 pcus so in pcu terms
46.7 pcus need to be taken off the road
in order to avoid blocking back at the
junction is that right
well the queue is moving slowly through
you've got the exponential position i
mean
you're getting to 46.
um
let me just do a quick
quick calculation yep
okay
you're prepared to agree that yeah
that's a rough and ready measure and
they are
in the hour yeah in the hour yeah 46
yeah in the hour of course yeah 46 pcus
yeah
your development
flow through this junction in the hour
is 103. yeah yeah so the development
flow going
through
um in the amp needs to have more than
half in order to avoid the blocking back
effects no
why not because the network flows could
could change as well
the network flow yes
you're going to have to explain
well the concept of peak spreading
going through the issues quickly oh no
we'll come to the issues on the modeling
on the modeling no you don't we don't
need to reduce our trip generation by
half we need to remove 46 pcus from
everyone
from from the into the approach flow
yeah which is everyone yeah it's the
network and the development okay network
and development some of your factors are
development specific some are network
specific but
yeah so there needs to be 46.7 less
pcus on the road to avoid this blocking
back effect in 2029 and yes in this
example yes okay so that's the figure we
need through all these various factors
we need 46
um
less pcus on on the road going through
these junctions okay so let's look at
the eight factors that are going to
result in that
and i just them down as you were going
through them i'm afraid i've missed one
so i'll just run through them and you
tell me which one i've missed i've said
the same one twice i'll i'll double
you were wrestling through them okay
peak spreading just just bear with me
yeah
yeah peak spreading pig spreading time
of travel
um oh sorry hanging out that is peak
spread
i mean by time travel
i've got a list i can read them out if
you want to
yeah why don't you run for your list
that'll be the easiest way just just the
summary of what it is rather than going
through the detail pig spreading peak
spreading yep trip diversion
yeah
the education trips um
internalizing yeah the trip
internalization
yeah yeah um
the travel plan yeah
the uh sustainable enhancements
to active travel you know the footways
the cycleways the the new bus stops all
of that yeah
yeah
um
i need to kind of help myself
working from home
yes um
study area
now is that eight i hope so sorry what
was the last one you said after working
from home
the fact that we wrote the trips right
through the study area and assumed that
no one stops in the town centre yeah um
that takes seven
maybe it is only seven let me let me
just please
take the time so i'm going to say peak
spreading
diversion
the school
uh there was i i cancelled them out when
i said them that's why that's shorter
there's the general the general uh trend
in trip rates reducing because of
working from home internet shopping et
cetera i've already got working from
home in my seven is there another was it
the exponential growth point
was that one of the eight
maybe that wasn't me
that wasn't one of my yet but it was a
reason why the results were
unnecessarily okay the other
the other point actually on my list of
it i didn't say at the time
oh we got new evidence then well it's
not new evidence i'm a bit more flexible
go on yeah
well the situation is that by taking
tempo into the growth astonishing
temper i'm sorry for that that's that no
that's that's for other developments
when we put our growth factors in for
the other developments yeah
their
their traffic is assumed in the model
that's what grows the traffic to 2029
but there's no assumption of the
mitigations that they provide in the
model
we're modeling their traffic but not but
not their contribution to highway
improvements
okay fine
fine
let's let's get through as many of these
as we can
start off with travel plan
yeah
um so
let's look at the travel plan it's in
your actually before we do this can we
just close this off there's no physical
mitigation proposed at the junction
um no there's no physical mitigation and
there's no long-term scheme in the
offering for physical improvements to
the whole road junction i think i say
somewhere in my proof that it cannot
easily be improved and that's certainly
the the position around that
there's a minor curb kicking that you
could do but it's not much so in terms
of the inspector
writing decision um
he can proceed on the basis that in 2029
there won't have been an improvement to
the whole road junction i don't think he
can proceed on that basis i mean the
council have an undertaking in policy
with the highway authority to work
together to try and achieve improvements
um
what we're saying is that it's not
easily done at that junction not easily
done okay fine i mean there's a railway
bridge which is a you know
an impediment to any private developer
there's a water course there
which is an impediment
to development but then there's land on
the corner which is in third party
ownership now highway authority
proceeding under its powers
could acquire that and do a junction
improvement
but it's not something that a developer
can do because it makes the scheme
viable yeah i've got not likely it will
i say not easily done yeah
not easily done that's fine right
um
travel plan yes we let's have a look at
it it's um your appendix 7
page 147
of
volume one
yes
um and can we then turn within it to
page 151 there's a heading target
yes
and
and it says the last sentence is then
common practice within a residential
context to target a 10 reduction in
number number of two-way
peak period vehicle trips yeah yeah
and the first point is that's a target
isn't it yes yeah okay
and the ultimate
quantum of reduction is unknown at this
stage
it's unknown but all the indicators are
because of the travel plan pyramid the
location the accessibility and the
funding
you know that's the target but it can it
can be beaten as well and this is a
better travel plan than you would
normally expect yeah and the second
point is
you've said
in evidence in chief that
your models
don't take and you said in your proof
don't take into account travel plan
reduction already so the modeling that
we have doesn't take into account travel
plan reduction no i said the ace trip
rates trip
didn't take into account travel well
most of them
did not have a travel plan yeah exactly
this is what i want to explore because
you're i just want to see how your trip
right which results in the figures that
we're talking about
what assumptions well
have been used in terms of travel plans
let's just go through this in stages so
um if you turn to your technical note 2
so it's page 12 of volume 2.
yes
just give me a second give me a second
please
so page 12 of volume 2.
yep okay thank you
[Applause]
right now as you've said
we can go to
the ace ta if we need to but as you said
their
um trip rates were derived from
trick sites that didn't have a travel
plan
generally mostly i mostly i think it was
something like 35 days without eight
weeks
but let's look at yours and the changes
you've made so paragraph 3.1
of this note the tetratec tricks output
for private houses attached appendix a
the key alterations which have been made
is follow a number of bullet points you
went through some of these in chief but
i just want to look at the
fifth bullet point
only sites which are subject to a travel
plan are included
yeah so let's just so that means that
when
selecting your trip rate your traffic
generation figures
they are derived from sites from the
tricks database
that have a travel plan included
they are derived from sites which had a
travel plan when they were approved
yeah
so the
traffic generation figures from those
signs
which you've then adopted to derive your
trip rates which then results in the the
flow to which we we grow
that's all derived from sites that as
you say had a travel plan when they were
approved yeah yeah so your
flows
which then are growthed up and we then
see if we go to page 45
and the summary table
the
2029 figures
with and without development
so the 2029 figure with development
is tt validated model fine tc10 pro fine
and then tt trip rates
and those trip rates derived from sites
that have a travel plan
so these flows that we see here
we don't see the flows here but the
flows that result in these delays and
the queues are from sites that have a
travel plan
had a travel plan when they were
approved what's the difference if they
had a travel plan when they were if you
look at page 23
yeah
sorry was that page 23 did you say age
23 yes
yeah
[Applause]
i mean there's there's two points here
really but those are the survey dates
2005 7 5 18 11 13 13 18. yeah
so
the two the two points are that travel
plans are in there to try and instill
active travel benefits and some of them
will have physical measures which we
have which are good and long lasting
there's a slightly you know with the
older sites then then that that phases
away sometimes but take the point yeah
that
you're trying to discount the benefit
that can be given to the travel plan
here because some of the sites that are
selected do have travel plans
from 2018. yeah say 17. it's a double
counting point isn't it well
you got the the outputs
and you're saying
well don't worry one of my factors is
we've got a travel plan so the flow
through the junction will reduce
but
that flow is derived from sites that
have a travel plan it would be double
counting
to
to take it into account both when
deriving the flows and traffic
generation and then use the travel plan
to reduce it you said you took my point
do you agree with that i do take your
point it's a matter of
the quantification of that if you look
for example at the table that
ace put in
and use their trip generation rates
then you could take the travel plan
discount from that but i take your point
i do take your point and and the
inspector has to take that into account
when deciding how much weight to give to
your travel plan
reduction the fact that there is already
an account for traffic traffic travel
plans sorry in the um in the base flows
there is an element of travel plan in
the base flows
and as i said in my
evidence in chief
we believe this is a very good
travel plan both in terms of the
hard and soft measures
okay
now even without that element of double
counting
on a very simplistic level if your
um travel plan is successful and
achieves the 10 target i'd say your
pointer might achieve more but let's go
for the target
103 extra cars going through the whole
road junction in the am peak that would
go down to 93 additional cars wouldn't
turn
in respect of the target applied to the
residents
yeah exactly yeah
so thinking about the 47 pcus that we
need to remove from the road that would
remove 10.
[Music]
yes yep
and as i said that's even whether not to
have been double counting in the
in the first place okay so that's that
one but but also in a side column
persons who may be entitled may be
attracted to travel sustainably because
of the travel plan measures that then
reach out
further the bus services the bus funding
et cetera
real-time bus information etc yeah okay
alternative routes um let's deal with
this
so in neither your
travel assess
traffic assessment
um or the addendum or your proof did you
set out what the alternative routes were
that could be taken to avoid um
congestion or hall road is that correct
that's right
and when ecc
signed off on this scheme in their
consultation response they didn't rely
on the potential for alternative routes
did they
no because
in discussion with the highway authority
they set the study area
and they appreciated that setting a very
robust scope involved putting all the
traffic through the key junctions
that's why it's all written down through
hull road to the south okay and nor as i
recall where any potential alternative
routes put to councillor eves
even though this point is made in his
proof
what i want to then ask is have you
carried out any survey has the appellant
carried out any survey of whether or not
people would be willing or not to take
alternative routes and if so what routes
they would take
um i personally have not carried out any
survey of that but we do have data on
the potential for it
the appellant has data
well in the flow diagrams in the diagram
of the approach to hall road
you will see that
[Music]
the 2019 count
599 people turn left
right and 253 turn right so yeah but in
certain simple terms two-thirds of
people have a destination
which could
be achieved by turning left on dallas
road those are people who are already
turning left and they're turning left
under your modeled outputs aren't they
yes
you need more people to turn left people
who aren't already
predicted to be turned left
now what i'm saying is that people
driving down the road and turning left
at the bottom at the roundabout
could equally achieve the same
destination by turning left at dallas
road
how do you know that
well i've driven the road
a bit
without carrying out a survey of people
and asking where are you going can you
take an alternative route it's just an
assumption isn't it no it's a highway
network
the route the main route that you've
taken you've referred to is the dailies
vote dailies uh voted alternatively yeah
yeah okay
now
um
if you're then
going down daily's road and traveling
into south end you go through junction
five don't you
you do yeah
has there been any analysis by the
appellant to determine
what well how many people would need to
divert down daily's road what the impact
would be on
traffic and daily's road and what the
impact would be on the capacity of
junction five that they'd ultimately go
through
well they go through junction five on
the same approach anyway so that
when they come down to this road they
come out at south road
so they don't so they they
south street so they they show up at
junction 5 in exactly the same way but
these are people who aren't already
modelled to go through junction 5.
that they approach junction 5 on the
same arm irrespective of whether they
follow the whole road route or the time
center of it
i'm sorry but your
your models show outputs for junction 4
and junction 5 right yes we can see that
page 45
and 46 yes
now in order to avoid blocking back
effect you need to remove
cars that are currently heading towards
junction 4 yes right
now those cars will then on your
analysis go down dailies road
some might yeah but we don't know do we
well
it it's
we're talking about a situation where a
queue grows delays grow and people
people change their route yeah
but there is no objective analysis by
the appellant that you can point to to
say this is where they will go this is
the likely reduction in pcus this is the
impact on journey times yeah
there is there is no survey but i have
driven both routes
uh
not once i've driven back can i have
less muttering in the background please
i've tried i've tried to not have to
interfere because i want it to run
smoothly but i i know there are people
here who clearly disagree with the
evidence that they're hearing but i need
to hear the evidence i need to make
notes of it i don't need a lot of
interruption from the background thank
you
mr parkerson okay so sorry are you
relying on then you're
you driving through the route on the
10th of september uh look i'm looking at
the highway network
it's marginally
it's maybe not even marginally longer
to go the diversionary route but the
roads are slightly smaller
um both sets of roads go through the
conservation
area um
bradley ways in the conservation area as
a matter of fact
if we're if we're saying that there's
going to be
a large queue with a large delay
people will turn left and go in the
other direction it's
it's how sat navs work it's how
travel information works
counselor shaw yesterday said that's the
way she goes
councillor shaw goes that way because
her food bank is in that direction she
doesn't go that way to avoid junction
four that's where she was going anyway
and that's the key point
well
and in fairness she could be doing that
journey at other times of the day that
are not congested
right alternative times and peak
spreading
and again in your proof um you don't
provide
any positive evidence of
the extent of reductions that will
result from peak spreading if i take you
to
your
paragraph
and
as you know it's not that paragraph
there's no positive evidence of peak
spreading will result in a reduction of
x or
when people will spread to or what the
impact would be
on um for example the school run peak if
people move their journey from 7 15 to 8
15.
that analysis is completely lacking
isn't it
there are some journeys that you can't
change the timeline yeah
yeah there are other journeys that you
can yeah and we just don't know
whether people are already peak
spreading do we we do yes mrs wright
introduced evidence with the survey okay
which set out the people peak spread so
your your positive evidence for the
inspector is miss wright's survey
well
it wasn't contested when it was
submitted that is evidence
to please his answer the evidence that
the appellant is providing to inspect to
say peak spreading can occur
is evidence produced by miss wright
i'm sorry i got distracted for a second
the evidence
that you're presenting to say peak
spreading can occur
is the survey produced by ms ryan
peak spreading is a widely recognized
phenomenon as i said earlier it's people
saying i got here early to avoid the
traffic
everyone evaluates that sort of thing in
their journey
all the time
mrs wright has presented evidence that
confirms it yeah but you need to show
that
more peace spreading will occur that is
already happening to get some
additionality here don't you if people
are already peak spreading and already
adjusting their journey times then
that's all built into your model outputs
well
peak spreading from the development
traffic isn't
it's generated in the r that it's coming
out of tricks and being rooted down the
road if if the development trips peak
spread
that will be an effect yeah which mri
survey doesn't tell us anything about
does it
well it tells us that people do peak
spread
let's look at it if this is the main
thing that's been relied on
beyond a sort of general it may be
possible
have you got a copy i'm sorry it's not a
general might be possible because
counselor eve's evidence was that there
was a significant potential for it to
occur
if we which which document we were just
going to go to so it's ms wright's
survey
[Music]
got it
um and once you've got it let's just
look at this can you look at question
one
yes
um
so when what is your primary time of
travel on the ashington road
and we can see
various options during rush hour
so 7 to 9 30
during school rush 8 30 to 9 30.
outside rush hour i use the road at all
times can you see that
i do
um now
in terms of your am peak that the model
outputs deal with that's the period 715
to 815 isn't it yes
okay
so neither of these
um
the people who are traveling
during the school rush
all that completely outside of your
modeled peak don't they because they're
traveling
um 8 30 to 9 for 9 15. um in in this
survey they do we know that there is
another school peak for king edmund
that's earlier than this but yes
yeah
and the
people in the first box during rush hour
7 to 9 30.
that overlaps to some extent with your
peak but there's still a significant
period from 8 15 to 9 30.
of people was ticking yes to that
question but aren't
um people that we're concerned about
with your amp are they
well your a.m peak is seven to
eight fifteen
there are people here who are traveling
between 8 15 and 9 30 who would fall
within that category
the time periods are correct
this just basically says that
38 of people surveyed
travel within that time because those
people who
tick yes to
questions one and two so they travel
during rush hour then go on to
question two if you're a rush hour user
could you change your am time of travel
in the future to avoid rush hour
so i could be answering this question
if i traveled between 8 30 and 9 15
couldn't tell
yes yeah and i could be answering this
question if i travel between 8 15 and 9
30 couldn't tell yes yeah so what we're
concerned about though is people who
travel between 8 50 8
7 15 and 8 15 and whether they could
change their travel time
uh for the purposes of this yes for the
purposes of this yeah
okay
so
we have 9.68
of responses
people who said yes i could change
my time of travel
yes
and we have no idea
what proportion of those were traveling
in the first place in your
a.m peak of 7 15 to 8 15 do it
well
we don't but
the question didn't get any more
specific you could assume that that's
evenly spread yeah we could but this is
this is the evidence that that you you
pointed to
those people ticking yes i could change
my travel time the only 10 of them
they could be traveling during the
school rush
8 30 to 9 15
and be thinking i could move my travel
time to 7 15 to 8 15. that doesn't help
us
what we need is evidence that someone
already going through this juncture
between 7 15 to 8 15 could move to an
earlier or later time and we simply
haven't got it from the survey have we
i think we do
it is not as granular as
every 15 minutes but
you know if you were making your point
about trips between 11 and 12
that might be something but
the period that we're looking at is
exactly within the period to which the
data pertains
okay um
trip internalization
sorry could we just quantify that
because you were taking numbers off your
list
please
what how far free are we
well on the eight points you mean or no
i mean quantify you i thought you
started out to quantify and count down
from 47.
i don't know how many we've taken off
because
i would like to venture a number here
okay yeah okay so
this tells us that 38
percent of people travel
in the rush hour
but the key number is that
point six six percent of people say
they could change their time of travel
yeah
the number of people coming down the
road and entering that junction
is just short of a thousand
right
so nine point six six percent of a
thousand is about 90 people
right
no no within the 50
no
no miss right please observe the
hearing
well you you've indicated you'll have a
question to put to mr uh blair later so
you can do it then i need to follow
what's being said now
mr better if i could just pick up you
said 38 percent of people
travel during the rush hour and then you
you did your calculation with the nine
point
um
six eight percent yes but the point is
that you need to
have a reduction because a peak
spreading for people who would otherwise
be traveling between 7 15 and 8 15. yes
this survey the rush hour period
is seven to nine fifteen is it two two
and a quarter hours
okay
so you're not comparing apples with
apples or like with like are you
as you said we would need much more
granular data
to work out whether someone traveling
between 7 15 and 8 15. no no i'm sorry i
was specific to apply it to the number
of people traveling in the r
if you want to apply that percentage
to the two and a half hours of the
survey then we need to be multiplying
that nine point eight six percent by
something closer to
two thousand two hundred trips
i'm focusing down in the one r
and i actually said to the inspector
earlier that i wouldn't seek full
benefit from this because people might
not move their journeys by much
but this is helpful because it says
could you change your am time of travel
in the future to avoid the rush hour
yes one could write the word completely
at the end of that it's to avoid the
rush hour
that is 90 people who could change the
time of their journey
to get out of that peak car
mr you said at the beginning of your
evidence your experience and number of
um transport assessments etc that you've
carried out have you ever relied on a
survey like this to justify the peak
spreading will occur
third party
survey
one thousand people response rate the
peak times being measured being
different from the peak that you're
modeling
have you ever relied on something of
this nature before i
i would say that
years gone by i used to
conduct surveys like not unlike this
myself
but i haven't picked up one from a third
party in an inquiry and used it thank
you
trip internalization and i just
want to understand
this
um so we need to go back to your tricks
summer issues i think um so we're volume
two two of two
sorry just one second um
page number in that again yeah this is
the one where the page numbering breaks
down so it's
i think it was page 15
yeah
sorry did you say 25 ta page 55 i think
is that where you were going oh from the
original ta yeah okay let's go there
first then
so back in the ta
yes
is this um
appendix i in the original ta
oh no it isn't it's um you take me where
you want to go well it was i just showed
that page there which was page 55 57 of
the original ta the original ta right
which page in the original ta
57 57
so is this table 5.2 correct okay
um
right 5.2
and you made the point
look at the
education journeys 10 education
was 34
sorry hang on let me get this right you
pointed to the number of education
journeys and said those would be trips
by car
but this site is close to a number of
schools and therefore we can assume that
people will walk is that a rough and
ready summary of your point
yeah i said that if you build a school
on site you would internalize but this
is the same thing inside out yeah
now you have um
this is based on the trip rates in the
original
ta though isn't it
yes yeah and of course you've tweaked
adjusted and changed those what we need
to be
yeah different selection different
selection
completely different selection yeah so
we need to look at your selection don't
we okay yeah
so we go back to your
proof appendices
and
these are numbers
so it's volume two of two page 23.
um no it's not your private homes are
it's page 17.
yes
and we can see
on page 19
the five sites from which you've then
derived your trip points yes yeah and my
question is are you able to tell us how
many of those sites were within walking
distance easy walking distance of a
school
um no i'm not able to tell you that
i would be able to tell you that
four of them are most like two of them
are definitely too small to have a
school within them and two others are
most unlikely to have a school within
them but i can't give you the specific
details yeah and do we have an
equivalent
of table
um
[Music]
yeah okay we don't have any information
of how
i'll leave it that okay
so four of them hang on sorry
three of them are did you say too small
to have a school within them yeah but my
question was within easy walking
distance of a school
um
i don't know the answer to that but i
can see that
four of the five are edge of town
because of course if
the sites that you derived your
traffic generation from
had schools within them or within easy
walking distance then
the um
your your trip rates
would already take into account a degree
of
walking to school won't they well they
would need to have primary and secondary
schools close to them and we've got five
okay
fine so we don't know the position
we do know that
six percent of
car travel
is
education based in the morning
from these sites well no i think that's
from the national trip end model i think
that's just general statistics
i'm asking about the sites that you've
derived
yes and i don't know about the schools
but i think the percentage in that is
from the national trip end model so
that's general statistics for cars on
the road yeah but i'm not interested in
general i i'm interested in the sites
that you've
selected to drive your traffic
generation rather than general figures
okay fine um now your point about
working from home
um if you can
go to
your proof
paragraph 8.4
page 28.
sorry i'm a bit disorganized
yep
um
sorry i'm just mentally
going through the ones that we've done
so i think we've done
four
we're only eight we're halfway there i
think we've done uh peak spreading
uh diverting
school
yeah yeah okay and travel plan yeah
working from home
sorry could you give me the reference
again please oh yeah 8.4.1
and then
0.2
you said it's likely to be a significant
increase in the practice of working from
home as compared to the situation when
the sites contained and trick's database
was surveyed
since its traditional am and pm peak
period success increased home working
could have a significant beneficial
traffic reducing effect i do not propose
the model like that as its quantum is
unknown at present but it's a beneficial
factor to to bear in mind
yeah
and that
the position isn't firstly the the
quantum is unknown
the quantum the extent to which home
working is going to reduce
traffic flow that's unknown isn't it um
the quantum at this point in time is
unknown you can find you can find
information from employment agencies and
stuff like that but it hasn't filtered
through into traffic data yet yep okay
and what we're concerned about here is
not how many people are working from
home
in
whatever year we're 2022
we're concerned about the position in
seven years time aren't we in 2029
yes and there's an overlap again which
may help
your point here which is the flexible
working
um
arguably could be seen as peak spreading
but certainly working from home we're
looking to 2029. we're looking to 2029
okay
and you'd agree it's inherently
uncertain as to whether
current the current um position in terms
of working from home
um and
um
some existing trends the extent whether
they will continue up to 2029 and the
extent to which they will
no i wouldn't agree with that um the
data that we collected is 2019. yeah
that's the kind that's the traffic flow
data the trick state house spans
from 18 back 10 years
the trend is clearly
towards more internet shopping more
working from home more flexible working
ancillary you've described working from
home is becoming the norm it's certainly
my personal experience in our business
of a thousand people yeah but we just
placed in context there needs to be 47
less pcus on the road
especially needs to be confident less
for 47 spc use on the mode to avoid a
640 meter queue on washington road
and in terms of
working from home and these trends
i would suggest he can't have any
confidence
that there will be a reduction or
significant reduction as a result of
that would you agree no i wouldn't agree
because again
we're not trying to take
47 pcus off our development i didn't
save the development because the working
from home trend is not just i said it's
not just your development it's off the
vote that's what i said off the road
yeah so so we just need to achieve
a working from home
flexible working internet shopping
uh
number
in the morning p car from from
approximately a thousand people
approaching the junction temp pro and i
think that i think this is a point
that's been added
during cross-examination but i think the
point is
temporo doesn't take into account the
growth factor am i right in some ways
like this it doesn't take into account
mitigation
traffic mitigation that might arise from
back background growth
that point
sorry but the point was that
temporal reflects developments that are
allocated but it doesn't but our
modelling of the network doesn't reflect
the improvements that they may bring
right and i think and they will go
through
the same scrutiny as this and they'll
have to do highway works you know so the
point is
that we've we've modeled their traffic
but we haven't modeled their
improvements yeah and that's a
completely standard approach isn't it
completely standard and if and if
improvements at junction 4 are difficult
then they may not be doing any there
either you know
yeah
um
sustainable enhancements yes um
and presumably the transport
contribution comes into this as well
there are transport contributions yeah
okay
now
um
sorry let me just find
that
yeah
now
to some extent
the
travel plan
part of the
large part of the 10 reduction
in trips that result from the travel
plan are because people will be using
the additional bus services or
the pedestrian connections cycling
connections that's where the 10 percent
comes from doesn't it within the
development
well there's encouragements to walking
cycling all the rest of it but yes the
physical the physical
measures and the contributions will be
the most prolific yeah yeah so to some
extent they're at the same point the
travel plan will encourage people to use
your sustainable
transport improvements in terms of trip
generation from the site
in terms of trip generation from the
site yes okay
so what we're interested in is people
um
so non-development traffic people who
don't have the benefit of the travel
plan taking advantage of the sustainable
transport improvements
um
now
a couple of factual questions
which
i think were passed over to you um from
councillor shaw
in terms of what the contribution
is likely to be spent on
yes
and conversations that have been had
with transport operators can you just
confirm so we can put some sort of meat
on the bones of what the transport
contribution is likely
to result in
i can
um
counselor shaw's
question the first one was
is the bus going to divert into the site
i think you asked that question someone
did
yeah
go on you can answer that one but it's
more yeah what's it going to be spent on
in terms of new services or additional
um additional buses can we just have
some sort of meat on the bones yeah i
can absolutely give you that and my
difficulty is in finding it
so
there are
bus stop upgrades shelters
um real-time bus information et cetera
those are the physical things but then
this is the contribution
yeah
so this is a letter from
um where are you so where are you
reading from i'm just reading from an
email that was sent to us from the
highway authority
which describes what the bus
contributions are going to be in terms
of the
what what page in the evidence is it
no you ask it's not it hasn't been
submitted in evidence this is this is
part of the ongoing discussions about
how it could all work
this is a letter from
the highway authority i mean it's i've
highlighted a few bits it can be passed
up if you'd like to see it first
but it tells you what it's going to be
spent on well
it it sounds as though
it's an important part of your uh
evidence mr bless i i don't see any
reason why i can't accept it as part of
as
an inquiry document
with that i've got no issue with that
it's just more whether mr blair's got
more than one copy
i've got
i've got fewer than two copies i have
got one copy and it's got highlighting
and pencil on it so
i don't know if my colleagues could
print it off um um
okay
sure it's it's just this i can read it
if
well do you want to
for my purposes is
okay to read it and then hand it in you
know a clean copy later is that
satisfactory to you
if someone could be photocopying it
while mr blair is answering other things
that would be helpful
yeah
no i wasn't looking to use facebook
whether there's another copy that can be
photocopied
i think mr players only got
oh you haven't got a copy okay
um yeah if someone could photocopy mr
blair's
[Applause]
it's got
yellow highlighter on it but i've taken
all the pencil marks off
right while we just wait for that i
think we've completed your eight factors
let me double check
we'll come back to sustainable transport
once we've got that
um
the point about the study area
i don't think we've done that
yeah um thank you um
the trip generation comes out of the
site gets rooted right across the study
area yeah
and that's a robust way to do it because
then those trips as we discussed impact
at each junction down the pipe
some people will have a destination
which is closer than the extent of the
study area
principally the town centre
but we haven't modelled those people
coming down
diverting down dallas road into the town
centre we've modelled them right through
the system
now
i don't have
evidence
in the sense of a hard piece of paper
but
we could
we can easily see that the town centre
has businesses there car parks there
shops there
all of the rest of it and
a significant number of trips will be
down to the town centre
we haven't modeled that
and it would only apply to the trips
that are coming out of the development
so any discount that we could be seeking
for that
in the amp car period would be
as a percentage of
the 103.
yep but if
six people
who come out of that 100 have a
destination in the town center or up a
side road or somewhere like that
then it's six trips yep so that's what i
was going to ask so this is something
because the factors that apply to
development trips and there are factors
that apply to wider trips
travel plan for example is the
development trips reduction and that
will always be a percentage of the 103.
and this is one of those other ones it
will always be a percentage of the 103
development trips that come into the
junction did you just say travel plan
will always be of the 103.
yeah
um
apart from the bus initiatives that it
funds but i'm saying travel planners in
terms of the yeah yeah
um
but also
um the other point is presumably some of
these people making the challenge
centered trips you'd be saying well
they'd be taking the bus there because
of my sustainable transport benefit or
they'd be walking there because of my
travel plan so again we have to not
double count here
that's right but that's the entire
benefit of this site because it's that
well located
but i'm we're talking about factors that
are going to get people out of cars
off the road and i one one of the points
we need to be sure is we're not double
counting and saying we've got a travel
plan we've got sustainable transport and
there are people who
um
who will um
drive to the shops because some of the
people driving to the shops
will have been taken out because of your
travel plan i've explained it very well
but it's okay
do you agree with that point
i see what you're saying yes i'm saying
do you agree with it
the double counting of
yes
okay
fine i think that's your eight factors
then we'll come back to sustainable
transport when we're at the sheet
um
i'm going to be submitting in closing
that those factors are
either involved double counting both
with your existing flows that result in
the problem or with each other or
uncertain
um but i think i've explored it as much
as i can now what i do want to do though
is finally
deal with
um
your appeal decisions that you put in
because
um
let me just
yeah actually sorry just before we do
the appeal decisions i just want to deal
with
the significance of this site being
allocated
in terms of
paragraph 111 of the mpp thank you
and this is severity test
now i think we can probably do this
quite simply if we look at your
page 45 in your appendix 2
well it was at 55
45 45 in appendix 2.
sorry which one again um says the
summary is it two of two is two of two
yeah two yes
oh sorry it's page 45 and appendix to
the summary table
and you've put there
um a row 2029 with allocation 500. yeah
and we can see
for example washington road arm
rather than 118 we have a 95. yes
um
sorry 95 pc uq
um
and delay 364 as opposed to 4-5-1 now
just to be clear the the 95
pcuq
with the allocation that would also
block back through junction 3 wouldn't
it
in this set of assessments yeah yeah
okay now my simple question is
appreciate that
sites allocated in the call strategy
sorry identified and called strategy
allocated in the allocations plan
there's been no assessment
by
um
highway authority or
an inspector examining that plan that
has seen junction modelling like this
and concluded that these impacts from
the allocation are acceptable
um no junction modeling like this that
shows that these impacts are acceptable
they haven't seen this they've seen much
worse results and thought they were
acceptable
where do i see that in the taa and the
ta
i'm sorry i'm talking about when the
site was identified in the core strategy
in 2011. oh i'm sorry an inside
allocation i don't have information on
that okay
if we
we can
draw
an influence though from the site
allocation inspectors report
i don't know if you're going to have
that it's cd 6.14
i'll try okay
um
and once you're there can you turn to
paragraph 23
paragraph 23 yeah it's on page
six
got it
um
and this records the highway authorities
view in 2014
which is that a district-wide transport
model
would not accurately identify changes to
the local network arising from
development due to the scale total
provision and distribution across
rochford instead the use of more
detailed individual junction models is
preferred taking into account existing
permitting and planned development
transport assessments would be expected
to accompany planning applications
arising from the allocations
in the site allocations plan now i take
it from that tell me if you know
otherwise that in both the
site allocations plan
and also the core strategy
we didn't have
a district-wide transport model or
detailed individual junction models
because paragraph 23 is saying
we prefer detailed individual junction
models but those will come forward
through
planning applications
are you aware of any
junction model carried out
um looking at these junctions when the
site was identified in the core strategy
in 2011 or the allocations planned in
2014.
well
i wasn't involved in at the time i don't
know what the background
in all of this is
um i've read the same paragraph as you
perhaps interpret it differently
but
um
i can't really comment on on what they
had in
2012.
if we then go to
paragraph
17.
i think 17 and 18 are planning planning
points in terms of
um
there was a cap on development that was
then removed
um
we don't need to cover those with you
but then paragraph 20 says
so this is a cap above 500 which is then
removed and the site allocations planned
subject to land supply triggers
and timing triggers if we look at
paragraph 20
this is the inspector saying however in
dispensing with the cap the areas
allocated for development would be
unaltered so that this in itself will
not bring about additional intrusions
into greenbelt moreover other factors
such as highway capacity and drainage
would limit the number of units that
could be accommodated within any site
these another detailed issues would be
considered through the normal exercise
development management policies
as part of the planning application
process
so
putting the 500 allocation to one side
that's a clear statement from the
inspector isn't it
that highway capacities um constraints
could limit the number of units that
could be delivered even on a site that's
allocated
i have seen this one before yeah
um
and the subsequent one where he deletes
the cap
he says other factors such as highway
capacity and drainage would limit the
units
these and other detailed issues would be
considered through the normal exercise
of development management policies
and as part of the planning application
process and that's exactly what what's
happened yeah exactly yeah precisely
that's my point and the additional
information that they did have
was the ringways jacobs report that gave
them all the detailed information to
help them assist in defining the scope
okay and then final couple of questions
on appeal decisions
if we look at your proof paragraph
11.3.1
excuse me
eleven points
okay um
and you say there there are several
inquiry decisions which assist in
understanding how secretary of state and
inspectors
have viewed the mppf test severity i
refer specifically to two decisions and
attacks extracts
now both those two decisions to appeal
decisions where the impact was found to
be not severe is that right
yes
there are of course other decisions
where an impact has been found to be
severe on them yes yeah yeah you haven't
referred to those in your
uh proof have you
uh no yeah and would you agree it's
important that the inspector has a
balanced picture and also takes into
account to pill decisions where an
impact has been found to be severe
um
well the whole the whole process is to
reach your balanced views
yeah
yeah
and
are you aware of appeal decisions of
that nature before
inquiry have you seen
um
mr flexman's
rebuttal
a paragraph
2.2.28
he refers there to two positions former
bath press
and then
um
lancaster appeal decision
seen that
have you seen that before
i have seen it yep and would you agree
that to get a balanced picture which is
as you say is the purpose of an inquiry
the inspector can also take into account
these two appeal decisions and mr
flexman's summary of what they show
below
um
well mr flexman's now agreed that he
doesn't have any
issues and doesn't believe there'll be a
residual yeah but he's ever it's a very
cumulative impact so yeah i presume that
mr flaxman doesn't really think that
these are relevant anymore in view of
what he's saying well otherwise he
wouldn't be claiming that
it was severe well mr flexman signed the
statement of common ground confirming
his position but it doesn't mean we
throw his evidence and everything in it
in the bin there's still appeal
decisions before the inspector that
would you agree
need to be taken account of well mr
flaxman's raised two that say
yeah
hills have been decided with severe
impact i've presented three that say
they haven't yeah i don't know how many
thousands of appeal decisions there are
out there that go one way or the other
on it yeah um
and that's my i'm sure the inspector i'm
sure the inspector will look at all of
the appeal decisions thank you that's
all i wanted to check the inspector can
take all of them into account
um
thank you sir i'm sorry i'm
slightly over my overestimate
can we just be clear though on the
document that was handed in about bus
contributions
because
i forgot mr blair didn't end up reading
anything because we diverted copied so i
completely forgot i'm sorry
if you just want to go back to the point
and how you were dealing with that one
then please
it's quite difficult to deal with on the
hoof that's the only difficulty yeah um
because it's the first time
at the information um
well we've got the document now i don't
know um
yeah i don't want to make any points on
it sir other than the fact that you
asked me if i had information and that's
the information yeah the information
okay
so just so i'm clear the
when the last paragraph says i was
stressing the present this is an
aspirational service is that referring
to
the link between the airport employment
zones
what what's the aspirational service
when i read this when it came in i
thought it was referring to a service at
the top the 700 000 contribution will go
towards a half-hourly service
between etc etc
link the development to both
greater anglia and coast c2c rail lines
rochford and lee town centres operate to
the tesco superstore critical well as
well as close to south end hospital
aviation saxon way
employment zones also provide
interchange opportunities with other bus
services so it
that aspect of it seems much more wide
reaching than just a you know a bus
specific for this development
um the money would be pulled with
existing section 106 fund that are
currently being held by ecc
not only provide a number of important
additional links for the ashington road
development in addition it provides a
new link between north rochefort and the
western side south end borough
and would when further funding becomes
available then extend on
yeah
and so it's quite difficult for me
without
speaking to
and
taking instructions sort of
asking any more on this i just wonder if
the way forward might be
for
um we've seen this for
councillor reeves to put in a very brief
note with his view and then obviously mr
blair can then respond to that and then
at least the point can be addressed no
i'm so sorry sir i'm i'm not happy with
that because because there has been
negotiations in respect of the 106
obligation
occurring in respect of the two parties
for a lengthy period of time which has
included which has included the
contribution and respect of the bus
service
if there were points that were going to
be raised in terms of this as to be
honest is my position in terms of other
points that have just been raised in
cross-examination which is not supposed
to be a fishing expedition then with
respect they should have been raised
earlier council reefs has given his
evidence and have cross-examined him on
it if there are points of clarification
that the council wishes to pick up with
us or the county outside of the inquiry
and then we are more than happy to
discuss it with them outside of the
inquiry but i think the time has gone
for extra notes and points of that
nature with respect
sorry mr parker can you see your bit i
was just going to say i'm just just to
clarify the
the point here is about
what this contribution will deliver in
terms of reduction of trips on the road
so that's the point and as with all
these contributions they're agreed on
the basis that if planning permission is
granted contrary to the council's case
they will be necessary adequately
mitigated et cetera and that's an
important
important point to make um
so it would be a note from councillors
saying now that i know the details my
view is this will
work not work
whatever in terms of but the extent of
trip reduction that it will deliver
i'm not i'm not sure that that
the the point is this this is part and
parcel of the 106 and i've had the
council's
sill compliance statement in terms of
this haven't i and you
you you had that in a sense
without the knowledge of this
letter here so i'm not quite sure how
this letter changes
what's in the seal compliance
while sarah i think i think there are
two points i think mr parkinson's point
if i understand it is that well there's
what's going to come forward as the
obligation we accept it's necessary and
he's saying but i want to understand a
bit more about it because there might be
a point that it's not going to go as far
as the appellant suggests it will in
terms of mitigating the impact of the
development
my point in terms of that substantive
point that he wishes to raise is it's
not being raised in evidence by
councillor eves in his proof or his
rebuttal
if there was an issue in terms of
wanting further detail in respect of
this matter it could have been asked for
way in advance of now because because
not least the council has been
negotiating the section 106 obligation
with us and with the county
for a very lengthy period of time when
the total amount of the contribution is
known so if those further details wanted
about that they could have been asked
for irrespective of the 106 obligation
frankly if they'd have wanted further
details they could have asked for it and
finally none of this in terms of a point
a substantive point
is in the evidence that the council has
produced i've now cross-examined
councillor eves at numerous points have
been put to my witness that don't have
an evidential basis
and now we are on another effectively
with respect fishing expedition
based on an email that my witness
referred to in answer to a question
where there was no positive point put by
the council about it so i'm afraid i do
strongly
strongly object to further notes and
evidence being presented by the council
in respect of this not least because the
council has confirmed in evidence that
it has no objection to planning
permission being granted
yeah
i think in terms of
i i asked for for this because obviously
mr blair was going to read from it and
so i've i've got the copy of that
but in terms of um what i can do with
this i think it just confirms the
this element of the contribution within
the section 106. i don't think it's
it's an area for further debate
so i think we'll have to draw a line
under that and i'll just have to put it
down as a
a document submitted by mr blair i
i see the point okay
i'm relieved of that thank you
so um
how had you
you you were just about to tell me that
you had said or i was just about to tell
you i'd finished yet yeah okay thank you
very much to mr parkinson thank you
a little bit later but obviously we've
diverted on a few things there
mr foster
questions that the rule six party wanted
to put to mrs blair that haven't already
been covered by mr parkinson have you
got a ballpark figure for your time
scale i'm just thinking i didn't i
didn't want us to have to have uh an
afternoon break but obviously i'm not
going to force people to to sit
unnecessarily long if if
if we can't get through okay um
i think if anything it's the reverse in
the sense that some of the
answers we've heard generate extra
questions i'd like to place
so if anything the amount of time for
questions has gone up in my in my belief
secondly i have to say so that um
whilst normally i would say we can
extend times we do have a media
interview at five o'clock which has been
booked since a couple of days ago on the
basis of wrapping up here at 3 30. yeah
well i
i i certainly don't want us to be going
on until five o'clock but we might have
a bit of a die dilemma if we if we're
not going to get through
mr blair um this afternoon
wha what's the consensus here what's
next i'm i'm really re really reluctant
to have a witness in purdue over the
weekend it's just not fair on the
witness frankly
um and
i do understand that third parties want
to ask questions obviously no no
objection to sitting later in order to
do that although of course you
um
take the point in terms of wishing to
finish a bit earlier but it's going to
be problematic if mr if mr blair's input
and then we're into next week and it has
it knock on implications and we've been
told that there's a request for our air
quality witness to come no objection but
all of it has not knock on implications
with the timetable
well i mean all we can do is crack on
all i would stress mr foster is is
please obviously
ask the questions that you want to ask
but try and be as concise as you can and
let's see how we we get on through this
i can't see any more than that would it
not be the case if i don't start then mr
blair wouldn't be in purder no because
he's still in the middle of
cross-examination okay yeah
okay
we'll give it a try sir excuse me sir
i dutifully sat at my station all
through lunch and i would like a comfort
break if that's possible but certainly
yeah it's it's 14 41
it is a 10 minute break sufficient now
for you i hope so yeah
okay i'll adjourn then we'll resume at
14.50.
hello
so
stevens
oh
[Music]
well the inquiry is resumed ladies and
gentlemen please take your
seats mr foster just before i ask you to
begin your questioning please forgive me
for saying this
but um
it's quite clear obviously that
the rule six party and many residents
take a totally contrary view to the
points that mr blair's
put forward in his evidence that's
understandable you're on different sides
as it were
but the
the the purpose of this next session
isn't for any attempt to try and
change mr blair's
position so the reason i say that is ask
a question
ask your questions but when you get an
answer from mr blair
don't then try and seek to to change his
view by continuing and pursuing a point
i say forgive me for saying that i'm not
not trying to as it were to teach you to
suck eggs but i know that
in terms of um the inquiry process you
need to respect the fact that you know
i'll make a note of the question i'll
make a note of mr blair's response to
that um but we can't often take these
matters to the bitter end as it were
sure i understand that sir
um before i actually uh start the
questions i'll just make a couple of
very brief statements if i may
well
it depends because this is meant to be
cross-examination you you've had you've
had the
chance to put forward your case so if
it's something that relates to your case
then you you ought to do it when you
make your closing submissions this is
really the opportunity to actually put
questions i understand that
and perhaps i can make my comment at the
end of this
well it is relevant i must say
i'm not saying it's not relevant but
this this is a cross-examination session
so that's that's what we need to stick
to please
right
mr blair good afternoon
and thank you for your kind words
yesterday
um
first of all
um you've mentioned your visit
uh on the 9th and 10th of september
um
are you aware that the furlough scheme
was still in operation until the 30th of
september
yes
do you have any understanding of the
impact of the furlough scheme on
traffic numbers on those dates
um i did look at some
traffic national statistics and by that
time it was back up to normal but i
would accept that the furlough skin was
still in place
okay
also related to
the subject of
being at home or specifically working at
home are you aware that the uh chance of
exchequer has today announced
the scrapping of the tax break for
working at home
no i've been uh here all day i haven't
heard that yeah i expected that response
and my point is i would anticipate
that that will affect people's working
from home
i
if you're looking for a comment from me
i would suggest that it
is unlikely to i think the tax break was
something like six pounds a week from
memory
which pales
compared to normal
commuting costs
okay thank you
the analysis that's been undertaken
measures junction performance is that
correct
yes
is it the case that it does not measure
junction to junction performance in all
cases
there are two different types of
modeling and the modeling that has been
undertaken here to the agreed scope
is individual
junction modeling
the other form of modeling is actually
called a network model where they're
linked together and that runs them all
together yes so not done here not done
there okay
so therefore for example
the traffic pile up after the sutton
road junction saw the ambulance junction
when you turn left into sutton road
is it's normally in the morning rush a
huge jam basically all the way from
sutton road from the berlin pretty much
most of the way to south end because it
services um
two industrial estates and feeds the
west the eastern side of south end my
question is
given that the
assessments don't include
the
road network
between junctions and so
on what's the point in adding an extra
turn lane at the ambulance roundabout
okay can i can i just write down a few
points there's two or three points to
come please
i just don't want to miss anything um
in terms of the network model had a
network model been used because it links
all the junctions the traffic tends to
move through that pressurized system if
you like to find the path of least
resistance so invariably they give
better results so when someone talks
about modeling junctions individually
it's usually the worst case situation
the ambulan roundabout is right on the
edge of the
study area it's the last junction out
away from the site that got assessed i
drove through it
i don't want to say five times it could
have been four it could have been seven
but i drove around it a lot that morning
because i was aware of the queuing which
had been reported from the industrial
estates and my videos and my dictaphone
at the time recorded that i didn't see
anything like that i think the maximum
iso was about four i could be wrong it
could have been five but it wasn't it
wasn't much it wasn't a
string of traffic back to south end as
you say um
and the question about what's the point
of a small
curb kicking
improvement at that junction
the highway authority have asked for a
financial contribution
towards a bigger
better future improvement
and the client is prepared to give that
and that is in fact the proposal
to go towards a future scheme i just
wanted to be covered for the scenario
where someone said that will never
happen so i designed a small scheme
basically to show
what could be done very easily to
mitigate the development impact and the
purpose of that very small scheme
is simply
to mitigate the development impact in
the worst period
so that if we have to fall back on that
scheme we might get our impact at that
junction okay but we but we agree that
we agree
that there is sense in the highway
authority
going for something bigger and better in
the future and that's why we're prepared
to pay the contribution towards it okay
so but not to
the roads
off of that junction
well to one of the approach
sutton road and
south end road
not changing the capacity of those roads
leading from that junction yes we we
don't put any traffic on that on that
arm
sorry sir repeat that
we don't generate traffic on that arm
but in the model the junction worked
within capacity so there was no need to
do that we
the intention is to provide the money
towards a much bigger improvement and my
understanding is that the council do
want to open that junction up a bit to
serve all the things that you've just
described okay but in terms of us
mitigating the impact that this
development will bring
there's an alternative scheme that's
very minor that achieves that
okay
the um
the the reason i've raised the question
about junction to junction and so on is
you'll be aware i think from the
evidence i submitted
that
a development in kent was rejected a few
months ago by the appellant by the
inspector
and that decision was
supported or confirmed by the secretary
of state
and one of the issues that was
identified in that
was that the
inspector
rather preferred junction to junction
modeling i.e network modelling rather
than just junction modelling
yes it also comment not a question sorry
i shouldn't have said that it's okay my
response would be his inquiry decision
also said that the surveys which were
underpinning all of that were flawed
so he couldn't have confidence in the
results and that was part of his
decision too
okay
um earlier on
mr blair you rebutted my comment that
the ringway jacobs report did not
include the cumulative impact of scr-2
and scr8
the report page 21 identified
all considered it considered all the
plans which were ser 1 2 6
bfr1
scr3 scr 7 ser 4 and ser 5.
there was no mention of ser 8
and page 6566 of the report described
the key congested corridors we've heard
that before ashton road and its junction
with newton road to hall road does this
not mean that essex has not established
a cumulative effect of scr-2 and ser-8
on the severity of the road of the road
network
i've got the report in front of me um
i'm looking at table 2.5 southeast
ashington is in it
page
19.
is this a report dated
25th october
yes
[Music]
the thing sir is mr blair is that um
one of the two
um the whole road slash
scr8
one of them is missing from here
they're both for 500 plus
so one of them is missing i believe that
southeast ashington is
is
potentially the whole road but whole
right either the whole road is missing
or the str8 is missing whichever way
they've not fully considered both the
developments
would you agree
that only one of the two developments is
included on that list i i can't comment
on what's
not in the report okay you know
it's not here southeast washington 500
dwellings is in the report let me
rephrase it
ser 2
is 500 plus
ser 8 is 500 plus
would you agree that they are not
both included on that table
i don't know all the sides what is west
rochford
west rochford west rochford is um
that's uh west of raleigh
you'll see that that was in the 400 and
450 that were built by 2015
not in this discussion
look this is this is a report that
you've introduced
no it's not sir that's what was
submitted with my evidence
and it's i've just referred to the
report i meant it was in my evidence
that that's what i meant to say
it was introduced in your evidence
that's all i meant to say it was an
appendix
um
sorry just would you agree though
that
that table does not show
the two 500 plus
developments
in the hall road ser eight area one of
them is missing i'm so sorry to
interrupt sir but it's just in case it
assists with a reference point
i can't hear you oh i'm so sorry it's
just in case it assists with a reference
point
um
and it's just at page 58 of that
document because mr blair said well it
could be west rockford the scr2 page 58
of that document
paragraph 5.2.1
it says west rochford brackets
allocation plan str2
yes it does yes thank you yes it does
i'm sorry to interrupt but it was just a
clarification point in terms of the
that is the one that is included in the
table right and then i think mr blair
said the other one i faced washington
500.
sorry would you repeat that last bit
in the table there's also south east
ashington at 500.
right let me go back to the table so
remind me of the page sir i've lost it
again
1919
yes right
dwellings 2015 through 2025. okay
550 north london road raleigh
500 south west holbridge
500 south east ashington 250 great
wakering
okay
one of either hall road or ser 8 is
missing from that table
now in the
let me just interject there because
that's that's not how i'm just
understanding the clarification i've
just been given let's see if i've just
understood this correctly
if if i turn to page 58 of that document
it tells me west
rochford
and then it says
the development on land west of oak road
and north of hall road
and it says ser too is
i'm taking it that that means that's
west rockford in this table on page 19.
so the second entry on page
19 i'm taking to be the same as the
description on page 58
and then
so basically my take on what i've just
been told is that both s e
r 2 and s e r 8 are in that table one
under the heading of west rochefort and
one under the south east ashington
west rocksford is not in the area we're
talking about west rockford is the
rayleigh end of uh the district of
rochford well no no well sorry it's just
when you turn to to page 58 does it not
clarify it there
i hope i'm not
okay misunderstanding what i'm being
told here okay
page 58 mentions um hall road
well it mentions west rockford to start
with doesn't it so i'm cross referencing
that to the west rockford that appears
in the table on page 19.
okay yes allocation ser two
my point sir is if you look at the
table
okay
what's described here as west rockford
scr2 is actually 600 plus houses
ser 8 is 500 minimum
plus houses
in this area
in the period 2015 to 25
there is only one
500 item on there southwest holbrook is
not in this discussion so what we have
in the 2015 to 25 time frame is 500
southeast washington
and
i believe possibly wrongly described in
there
but should have been the whole road but
the point is in the evidence only hall
road
number the only whole
sorry hall road plan ser 2 is mentioned
and there are not the appropriate
numbers in the table on page 19 to
reflect ser 2 and ser 8.
both of which are over 500.
well the west rockford there is is a
total of 600 isn't it by uh it says by
2015 and then 2015 to
i'm
2025. i'm so sorry sir just just oh i'm sorry
sorry sir
um the the dwellings in uh the hall road
development
uh started construction round about
2017.
don't know what was supposed to be there
by 2015 where west rockford is
west rockford covers a whole area of
to the west of rome and so on but in the
period 2015 to 2025
which is in the ringway jacob's report
it does not cover scr-2 and scr8
okay the numbers just don't match
so so just if it assists as well just in
terms of the i'm not i'm so sorry i'm
not trying to interrupt or it's just
just a reference in the core strategy
and how scr 2 is referred to in the
sorry in the um allocations plan
policy scr 2 it's page 43 and it's 6.2
with respect to with respect i'm
cross-examining no i'm trying to help
with a reference for you because in the
allocations plan we're talking the
ringway jacobs player but it's it's so
sorry if i may finish it's the the
reference in the plan is policy ser to
west rockford
it's just a heading point i think isn't
it
okay well i'll revisit that but i don't
want to disrupt you anymore from
continuing mr foster
i'll reiterate
the
area known as ser 8 is not mentioned in
the report anywhere
the term ser 8 is not mentioned at all
all the other ones i read out are
mentioned in the report
um in the statement of common ground
process um watchford's
supporter group submitted factual points
of agreement
especially in relation to horror and
ashland road west street could you tell
me why the appellant refused to answer
the statement of ground statement of
common ground uh inputs
no i can't tell you that
the process was controlled through the
planning consultants
okay
very happy for us to answer that point
but it was mr pycroft dealing with the
statement of common ground so perhaps
that's one you could put on your list
for mr pycroft yes i was going to say if
this witness can't answer that question
then he can't answer it but you can put
the same question to mr pycroft when you
get the opportunity okay thank you
a few minutes ago
you suggested that councillor shaw
should change her journey time to avoid
the hall road ashland road west street
roundabout
and she mentioned in in quiet response
that she has to hope and open a food
bank a specific time
is this not a good example of the
hopeful but unreal assumption by the
appellant that people will change their
travel time
no it isn't
and i didn't suggest that she change her
journey i merely pointed out that she
did use the route that i think other
people will
i think miss councillor mrs shaw does
believe you suggested that she change
her journey time
because she interjected and said no i
can't because i've got to open a food
bank
my point is you know it's uh it's a big
assumption in all of this that people
will change their travel time in fact in
the in the survey that
mrs wright
introduced it was much was made of the
fact that 9.6
of the people
could
not will could change their time
which means more than 90 could not
yeah um
mr foster
just
yeah
questions not not statements of your
interpretation of things please no i'm
i'm reflecting on the comments that were
made which is why i'm asking the
question
9.6 was quoted
if if
surely the point is if people could
change their travel times as has been
suggested
they would be doing anywhere
but they don't so do you agree on that
conclusion they would be doing it if
they could
no why would they not
because we're looking at 2029
and the scenario where traffic volumes
build
and what people's response
to traffic conditions is the primary
response
in modeling
the big network modeling not the
individual junction where we put all the
trips in the primary response is to
shift the time that you travel
mrs wright's survey
said not only that people could shift
their time
it said they could shift it right out
of the rush hour period they could move
their time
considerably
real time traffic information systems
everyone driving on a journey
most of the time is considering when am
i going to get there which route do i
take
we do it all the time when we drive mrs
wright's survey was now
and my question was if they could change
their travel time and they were surveyed
during the rush hour
traffic jams
why would they not change them anyway
i'm sorry could you just
say that again please
mrs wright's survey
was current time current traffic
conditions yes and if people that are
stuck in
the heavy traffic
could change their travel times i would
suggest that they would change their
travel times but they're not
would you not agree
mrs wright's survey question i i won't
get it out but i can
said
within a period of 7 to 9 30
if if you travel then how many how many
of you travel then 38
there's also another category at the
bottom that said i travel all the time
so some of those people will be in that
numbers will be added to that number
because the total percentage is actually
added up to 100
so there will be some people in the
bottom category in the morning peak car
as well
and it said if you currently travel
in the rush hour could you change your
journey and 38 to
to out with
the morning rush hour which she had
defined is seven to nine thirty
what was the number nine point six
percent of 9.6 something
said that of people who currently travel
at peak times
could change their journey completely
out with that two and a half hour period
i think that's a very significant number
significant but my point is
if they could and they're stuck in
traffic now
wouldn't they change anyway
therefore the questions a little bit
sort of hypothetical almost well if you
put it the other way change it they
would change it well if you put it the
other way around if they haven't changed
it then they're not stuck in traffic
then why would they respond that they
could change it we're getting nowhere
with this shall we move on
shall we move on sir
please do yes i mean you you've asked
the question you've had a reply to it so
right yeah you mentioned the growth in
internet shopping yes
um do you agree that internet shopping
equals deliveries to the home equals
parking in the road equals more traffic
jams
uh no
because one delivery van is better than
25 cars
sorry again one delivery van is better
than 25 cars okay but if you see one
delivery van parked in the ashland road
or many delivery vans parked in nation
road through the course of a day
does that mathematics stand up we see
a tesco van or an amazon van parked in
the ashland road causing chaos
okay we won't agree on that will we
in my evidence i described percy cottage
road
as i mean blind bends
narrow streets
off street parking
and the mitigation that's described was
a small widening of the short paths in
the entrance to persicotis from the
proposed exit from the phase two
so it's a small widening of paths and a
small increase in displays
now do you not agree that the phase
two exit will increase traffic
in the route around percy cottage road
yes and the
trip distribution in the ta
shows that
okay
[Music]
do you not agree that the mitigation
on the plan only applies to a small area
of that the environs of that road that
exit yes that is the agreed mitigation
yeah okay so all the other blind bends
and so on still remain a risk
no
there will be a slight intensification
of traffic the highway
layout on site is designed so that a
diversion route through the site will
not occur
it's intended to serve i think twenty
percent of the development and that is
additional traffic on persecotis road
there is no evidence that that
additional traffic
will lead to any road safety issues
i wasn't suggesting that
traffic taking diversion routes through
the estate i was talking about the 20
yeah no
the road the percy cottage road we
should show you pictures it's very
narrow it's it's
features a great deal of
on-street parking yes with little
off-street opportunity
sharp bends blind bends
and pedestrian traffic to the school
so it's so committed i'm just asking you
whether the mitigation for that small
entrance to percycottis the persicotis
entrance
and the widening of the splay there
actually has any mitigation for the
traffic impact on the whole of that
particular area yes or no
the mitigation on the
short section
obviously does not provide anything for
the rest of the estate so that's a no
that's right thank you
i'm
in the
various reports
it's suggested that people will take
alternative routes
to avoid congestion
could you explain to me what those
alternative routes are
um yes if you were coming up from the
roundabout you suggested at sutton road
um amberlyn roundabout
and you thought that there was going to
be a queue at
west street
hall road roundabout you can turn right
up south street
and you can go through the town centre
and come out up at the dallas road
roundabout
okay
i think we've seen from other evidence
that
directing traffic through the town
centre is undesirable
well it mentioned high court judgement
traffic does divert through the town
centre through the other junction
mentioned earlier on routes of
stanbridge but you've taken an example
there what about traffic traveling down
the mainland the ashman road either
northbound or southbound what are the
alternative routes
traveling northbound
if you were at dallas road
you wouldn't be able to take an
alternative route to get further north
across washington roads effectively the
only route north across that section
sorry what if you're coming southbound
down the ashland road
well um
i want to get my pronunciation what
alternative routes will you be able to
take to avoid the hall road uh ashland
road
west street mini roundabout
well you can go down dallas road again
but when you get into the town center
it's a one-way centre of the town again
yes
yes
the traffic impact of which has never
been measured in this assessment yeah
that's right the highway authority
asked us to look at the primary road
network and put all our traffic there
if i were able to cross-examine the
highway authority i would ask those
questions but the fact is
and i'm sure you would agree that
that route through the town centre which
previously has been the subject of high
court judgement has not been assessed
for traffic impact
is that correct it has not been assessed
for traffic impact thank you
i i would i would add that i have driven
those roads many times on my site visits
and
their town center roads
they go down to one way in places
they're narrowing places
i was never held up in a queue but it's
not the preferred way the way through if
there was no congestion
on the highway network you probably
wouldn't use them
but they are an alternative rate
they are
excuse me sir
they are generally not taken as
alternative routes
local knowledge i'm afraid
and i would say
reminder
that in a high court judgment
against
an appeal by a builder a developer
the
judge ruled that it was undesirable for
traffic to be attacked attract uh
attracted through the town center
i'm so sorry to i'm so sorry to
interrupt
and it's a point of law and i'm sure mr
parkinson will also be able to assist in
respect of this that the cogent land
decision made the comments that um mr
foster is setting out in the summary of
factual
information that informed the judge as
to the legal point
that was being discussed in that case
which was essentially and in summary
whether or not the
essay and sca this had been produced in
respect
of that plan
um had been through the appropriate
process essentially so it was a
challenge to the adoption of the core
strategy
on that basis now i'm not saying that mr
foster is right in terms of the comments
that he draws out of it were made
factually in respect of the background
there but the judge neither endorsed
those facts or otherwise because that
wasn't his remake that wasn't what he
was looking at no he wasn't no i i
understand that
yeah give him
i'm hearing what mr foster's saying you
you've referred to the high court report
a number of times i've got it in front
of me there you don't need to repeat
points about it as i say please try and
just concentrate on putting the
questions to uh mr blair and
when he's answered it you don't need to
give uh the background as to why you
take a different view yes i'll take i'll
take that point but i must point out
that if i ask for a yes or no answer and
it gives me a yes but
as ms reed has demonstrated admirably
over the last few days i i always allow
witnesses to clarify i like the yes or
no and then the clarification but what
i'm trying to point out now is some of
the things that you're saying are giving
me a repeat of the supporters group's
position which i know
what i want you to do is put specific
questions to mr blair
so and just to remind myself the answer
to your question was
yes
there hasn't been a traffic assessment
of the town center traffic
that's right i'll move on to the next
one sir
um there's much in the travel plan about
mode shift
do you have any travel evidence of mode
shift the the effect of mode shift the
percentage of a
successful remote shift
uh from car to public transport
resulting from development for an area
with similar social economic and
geographical cool
geographical characteristics as a
rochford district
um
as i explained
the travel plan expert was to be called
as a highways witness but his
presence has transformed into
his report in my appendix
he is the expert on the travel planning
and has all the mode shift figures at
his fingertips i
do not have the figures that you
have asked for in such specific terms
okay is that something mr pycroft will
be able to answer later or on another
day
i don't think mr pycroft's the
the man for this it was the uh the mr
hacker whose um statement we have in
lieu of his appearance in
one of the appendices to mr blair i
think so will somebody be able to get
the answer to that question
well the mood shift target is ten
percent
that wasn't my question
my question was do you have travel
evidence
of mode shift from car to public
transport resulting from development for
an area with similar socio-economic and
geographical characteristics as a rocher
district uh i personally do not hear
okay does somebody
have access to it in the team
well
we weren't expecting a question on
the travel plan because it doesn't
feature in the case
okay
i okay the sorry the um
the various evidence has suggested
and including the original original
ardent assessment on which the
application was made
talked about
mode shift travel plans and i'm asking a
simple question for the evidence
of the effectiveness of that
in an area
to put it in simple terms like rochford
socio-economic and geographical
so
i do not have that specific evidence
um
right
in the evidence i showed yesterday
[Music]
i showed
stills from a time lapse video
which i demonstrated can make a busy
road look quiet
or relatively quiet
in your proof of evidence
i saw stills
from
various
videos i think they were dash cam videos
that's right
[Music]
variously there were some you know
multiple minutes long
but
there were 10 seconds 14 seconds 2
seconds 11 seconds 10 seconds sixteen
seconds twenty eight six eleven three
two and so on
so
stills from short videos of that
duration can provide a
perhaps uh misleading
view of the traffic would you care to
comment on that for me please i i don't
understand when you give the short
seconds i have about six hours of videos
i'm referring to the times on the um
your still pictures yes
it reflects the time they were taken and
the duration of the video from which
they were taken
i just want to see an example and then
i'll be able to comment on it please to
see what
you're asking
um
yes
time of day 7 40. so i'm looking now at
page
28
or
well
take a look at page 28
time of day
so it's image three bradley way time of
day zero 7 41 a.m
so that's obviously the time of day
sorry i'll i'll
it's paginate at page 28.
as i said sir i'm not claiming that
they're all like that no
it's friendly way
time of day 741 video time uh 14 seconds
right can i just explain what that time
is and what it means
um 7 41 am is fairly obvious
a dash cam
records five minutes of video and then
another five minutes and then another
five minutes
that's just recording that that happened
14 seconds into that video
in case i needed to go back and find
that on the video that's my marker to
tell me where that is it's not saying
that the video was 14 seconds long it's
just saying that if i had to find it
it's it's like a
digital version of the old counter on a
tape deck it's just so that i can know
where to go to okay so selective to
rephrase it there's selective stills
from a long video
bit like i showed yesterday i didn't
want to put in six hours of video for
reasons yeah we showed a few stills
yesterday which showed a busy road is
looking like a quiet road just by taking
stills from a long day's worth of video
i will move on sir
um
now i'm not sure whether i should ask
this it was a mr gasquen question i
think
uh i'll ask it to see if it works or not
well
ask ask a question if this witness can
answer it then uh or well and good if
you can't then it may be one for mr
pycroft okay
and various parts of the of the evidence
described a wide variety of facilities
within walking distance
of the proposed development
for instance it shows
holt farm schools
which object to the proposal
it shows a doctor's surgery which
has a shortage of doctors
okay
massive shortage of doctors they may be
interested in the
potential new primary i think
mr foster you you you you you're
drifting into
not a question here that i'm sure
there's a question at the end of this
but
there is a question and the third
example sir is uh on the on the um
on the statement it shows rockford
hospital being a few minutes walk away
it's actually a mental health center and
an elderly care center so day center so
you know what do you in in presenting
that evidence what are you expecting
people to take from that
the hospitals 10 minutes walk away but
it's actually a mental health facility
i'm not expecting
people to take anything from that when
you locate a site
you consider its accessibility and you
mention all of the facilities that are
in the local area that are within a walk
distance or a cycle distance
if the wrong names on that then i
apologize it was it was done before my
time
okay
okay i accept your apology i just hope
in understanding the evidence presented
sir
that some of these errors will be
recognized rockford hospital
demonstrated as a close walk is not
hospital in the sense that people would
imagine it's a mental health facility
and a day care center for the elderly so
in that respect the reports are
misleading
it's got the wrong name but people will
work there
and they will live within a walkable
distance to their place of work
the people that work there
already work there
and they drive or they walk or they get
a bus as appropriate today
um
also in the report it says again this
may be a mr gascoigne item cycling has
potential to reduce trips
up to 10 kilometers
um good theory
and i do understand the cycle
infrastructure within the development
but once you get out of the development
this report is describing all these vent
all these places can you explain to me
the re the cycle network that gets
people to leon c or all the other places
listed
i can't describe the cycle network to
leon c
but
um
there are cycle contributions towards
uh key cycle routes
and they are
off to the south
west of rochford
okay there's the rdc flagship cycle
routes one and two
they go down um
just past roche avenue and turn across
flagship
i can handle this plan but flagship
one goes along here i accept that like
true
um
the point was made and the question i'm
trying to ask is that
the report
was offering
access to
up to 10 kilometers worth of
cycle
destinations which are all very nice
destinations
but there's a big assumption there about
there been cycle routes beyond that
beyond that area you've talked about and
there aren't
i i don't think that's what it's trying
to say if you were locating a site
somewhere else in the country
that was isolated
then the same approach would say
you can't walk anywhere you cannot cycle
anywhere you can't catch the train to
anywhere because there isn't a train
station and there's one bus a day
and sites like that exist and they don't
come forward because development's put
on accessible sites where
in this case you can ride on cycle
routes that will be provided alongside
the side
there are cycle routes
key cycle strategic flagship routes
being developed
and you may have to cycle on the road
to get to some of these destinations but
the point is there are
destinations within 10 kilometers so
cycling is a choice
for some people
right and you know thank you to the
reference to other places
but in in our area most of those places
that you mentioned you would have to
cross a busy a127 for example which is
pretty much rammed
constantly
all right thank you i'll move on
um
again the the um
the evidence describes the area in close
proximity and well serviced by a public
transport network
reality is the frequent services seven
and eight so rayleigh station hockley
south end travel centre north shubery
service 1668 which i think is mentioned
somewhere uh doesn't go through rochford
others are two hourly or three a day
with the services reducing on saturday
and available sunday
the school service is suggested as a
positive as a source but it's actually a
source of traffic congestion
for students out on the catchment so
i know that there's been
section 106 money put into this
proposal to improve public transport but
we know currently public transport is
not particularly well used in fact it
only grows when the bus passes kick in
at 10 o'clock so
my question is really about this
contribution and how
how
how can you evidence that it's likely to
be effective in in transferring people
to buses and also
if it's not the case that the bus
companies will continue to provide the
service when the 106 money has run out
there's a few points there the travel
plan does provide bus passes
so
six six travel
travel passes for people to try i think
six months of bus buzzfeed six passes it
says
i'll check that i think it's something
it's it's a
yeah it's a bigger uh contribution than
that and in fact i've been advised by
the client that it's significantly more
than essex county council usually ask
for
there are physical bus improvements such
as real-time information
at the bus stops and i heard someone say
just in passing that people would have
to wait
you know you never know when the bus is
coming along but these real-time systems
tell you when the bus is coming along
which makes it more attractive you can
stay in your house longer and walk out
when the bus is about to arrive it's
it's on a nap
and then there's the uh public transport
contribution now that's been said
in conjunction with the highway
authority
it's not a sum of money that has been
negotiated down or anything like that
they have identified
the contribution that they think is
appropriate and the developer has agreed
to provide it okay thank you for that so
i have to the speech the point i wanted
to make earlier on
is that we don't have an opportunity to
cross-examine the highways authority
because they're not here
and many of the questions that we ask is
the highways authority but we don't have
an opportunity to challenge them
um
right in the rebuttal of evidence rule
six party evidence
you described uh
large load movements has been abnormal
um
well actually we think they are not
they are increasing especially with the
baltic wolf growing on the river crouch
so why do you how how and why do you
describe them as abnormal and what it
what do you describe does what what do
you define as abnormal
i i can't recall using the word abnormal
could you just point me to it i may have
done but i think okay
i'm probably more likely to have said
that they were
4.1.3 says those include abnormal load
movements all right sorry yes
my general train of thought was that
such movements
could be typical you know that the sorts
of vans parked on the cycleways that the
photographs that i saw
are you know as you said tesco vans
parking by the side of the road etc
fairly typical um there was one abnormal
load photograph in your um
out in the back of the trailer yeah
excuse me they're all so they're all
there are also
big lori's moving up and down the road
quite frequently steel is pretty is
brought from uh wallace the island from
um
it's not it's not not not a question is
it this this foster is against it's part
of your case
so what would you do how would you
define abnormal and why do you believe
that
they are abnormal
um an abnormal vehicle is something
that's wider than 2.9 meters i think
from memory and possibly needing an
escort beyond that and where's your
evidence that they are
abnormal in terms of that area
i don't have evidence of that thank you
um
there's also there's also a length uh to
the abnormal load thing of more than 12
meters
okay but sorry yeah
i was going to ask some more about the
shared space but i think we've probably
done that to death um
right
i'm going on to the um
ardent report page 84
7.15
it states we've assessed the impact of
predicted development upon the operation
of all junctions in the study area
requested by ecc
it's been demonstrated for the most part
although the local highway network is
congested there is the ability to
deliver the proposed scheme without
significant detrimental impact on
junction operation so the question is
what is
the most part what does that mean
so
it means not all and secondary what are
the parts of the highway network that
can't cope
could you give me the reference to that
paragraph please it's uh paragraph
7.15
thank you
just takes me a little bit of time to
get the document so that's that's in the
transport assessment is it is that where
you yeah
sorry let me just check that i don't
want to mislead you
sorry it's page 80
sec
paragraph 6.79
well you you say that but i've turned to
your first
reference what you you said page 84
para 7.15 and i can see those words
there no that's right it's i've written
down both pages it's actually written
twice
i think it's a reflection into the
summary and conclusions so go back to my
question so so if that's for the most
part that means not all
so what are the parts of the highway
network that can't cope
could i ask you to turn to
my
volume 2 appendix 10 please i haven't
got it right here i'm afraid perhaps you
read it to me
i will yeah
can you give me the page number please
it's the results table which i think 184
184
i just want to read this paragraph again
before i answer it
[Music]
okay
so
unfortunately i'm going to give you some
numbers um
but in the
in the ardent work
that you're referring to
in 2029 at rectory road it was going to
be 9 over capacity
with no development
and with development it was going to be
it's
it's a ratio rfc
1.11 and i'm sorry sorry i
don't want to be rude but my question
was
what parts of the network can't cope
um
yeah they don't say it
they don't say it can't cope
well it says
we've assessed the impact of the
predicted development traffic on the
operation of all junctions in the study
area requested it's been demonstrated
that for the most part
although the local highway network is
contested there is ability to deliver
the proposed scheme
without the significant detrimental
impact on junction operation yes so my
point is the most part doesn't mean all
so my question is what parts of the
highway network can't cope
it doesn't say they can't cope
i was about to read i was about to read
through the junctions and tell you which
ones get mitigated and which ones don't
it's a logical question based on the
words he said for the most part
the highway network is congested
okay
and the proposed scheme can
without significant detrimental impact
on junction operation so for the most
part
so
what
parts can't go
if the most part i understand that if
there's ten junctions nine is the most
part but what's the one that can't so
i'm asking the question which is a
junction that can't cope
or junctions
okay
it doesn't say they can't cope it says
without significant detrimental impacts
okay so if you go to if you go two
paragraphs down let me try again
if something says for the most part
can cope
most part doesn't mean all so i'm asking
you what is the bit that can't cope
i may be reading a different paragraph
let me just get the other reference
i was on page 84.
are you on a different one
if we're on page 84 paris 7
15 yes
i think
what i'm taking from this is mr blair i
think is saying that he can't see within
that paragraph
it's saying that any junction can't cope
i think they're they're words that
you've
interpreted
mr foster and are then putting that to
mr blair
am i correcting that so far mr blair is
that yes
because i i can't see the phrase can't
cope here so so that's that's your take
on it isn't it and so you're
you're asking mr blair something that
isn't actually contained within that
paragraph
and i think mr blair was going to tell
you the
the way that the junctions are were
predicted to operate in the ardent
report
but anyway i'll
i'll say no more it's not
trying to cut through this i accept that
i put the
definition in there but the words
i'll try again and i'll ask it in line
with the words in here if i may
okay
although the local highway network is
congested there's the ability to deliver
the proposed scheme without significant
detrimental impacts on junction
operation
okay for the most part
so which are the parts
that can't be delivered without
significant detrimental impacts on
junction operation
yes took two paragraphs down it says
that the ashington road hall street has
been improved in recent years
and it's forecast to operate above
theoretical capacity as a result of
general growth
in either uh or both weekday peak cars
the additions of development traffic
will add to delay in queuing
so which are the ones that can't
operate
without significant
detrimental impacts well
the reason i went to my results
was because the aca work
was forecasting
significantly higher levels of operation
than my work
and at this junction that was because
they'd used the wrong geometry
before i say again they had used
in a
model of a junction
yes you add in the traffic flows and the
directions that they're going but you
also have to put in the geometry of the
junction
the radius of the roundabout the widths
of the lanes all that all of that
um they had used the wrong geometry
they'd used the old layout so our ardent
didn't use the correct geometry correct
where else didn't they use the correct
geometry at the side access
anywhere else specific ones we looked at
all of the junctions everything else was
fine there were a few minor tweaks we we
looked at modern data and made a few
minor tweaks and that's all set out in
that table of results where it shows
that the differences are immaterial at
all the other junctions but the
differences were significant at the
whole road junction so the ardent report
yes it's a basis for the planning
application by law yes is wrong in that
respect it is wrong in respect of the
results for that one junction
and the point i make repeatedly in my
proof is that it has been accepted on
the basis
of performing
much worse than will actually be the
case
doesn't i mean going back to the
comments you say doesn't this cast
further doubt on the modeling that was
in the ardent report there was a whole
bunch of things in it where it talked
about
it can be ignored because it's exceeding
queue length and blah blah blah blah
blah
no um
i i believe the ardent report despite
that error
stands as a robust piece of work it's
very comprehensive
it's a robust piece of work
and the error that it that it
introduced with that junction
made the results worse
so anyone reviewing this
now
can have even greater comfort that the
actual reality of the junction operation
will be far better than that which they
previously found to be acceptable
and i'm not going to go through this but
i've got 11 errors in the arden report
here i'm happy to read them out if you
wish that's that's not a question is it
you you you've asked your question
about this if if
if there are points there then really
they should they should have come
through in your um presentation of your
case mr foster i did point out
one significant one where they said on
page 38
yeah
that's fine
i didn't want to delay the
the um inquiry about going through the
nitpick of every little
or big mistake in the ardent report
there were 11 and uh okay i won't uh
read them out but nonetheless they are
there and they cast down on my mind in
my mind and as a recent discussion we've
just had sense to emphasize there were
quite a lot of flaws in it
right i shall move on sir i'm almost
there i think
on page 63 6.12 of the arden report
it says it's generally recognized that
background growth in traffic is
constrained by network capacities and
therefore where parts of the network are
either approaching or at capacity full
traffic growth projections are unlikely
to be realized
put into layman's terms my terms simple
laymen this would seem to mean that the
network working places can't cope with
the forecast increase in traffic
if that is not the case
could you please explain what that
paragraph means
right
what that means is that you can't get
more than a pint into a pint pod yep so
what they're saying is that where
junction capacities are constrained
where
traffic's uh constrained by network
capacity
where parts of the network are either
approaching or at capacity in other
words if the junction's full you can't
get more through it so traffic can't
grow if you stood beside the junction it
doesn't say junctions it says the
network
it does say the network
yeah
so if you were standing there counting
and it was full you would always count
the same number
because it's the capacity that would be
moving through not not a free
so what it's saying is
for our assessments of the future
we're still going to apply
traffic growth anyway
and that's why the results show them all
going over capacity the results that i
was about to read out to you
but is it not true that
we said earlier that the
junction to junction and beyond junction
parts of the network are not um
tested through the through the um
algorithms or measures or whatever
because it says here it does say it
doesn't say junctions it's generally
recognized that background growth in
traffic is constrained by network
capacities
and therefore where parts of the network
are either approaching or at capacity
full traffic growth projections are
unlikely to be realized
my interpretation is that means the
network can't cope with the predicted
predicted traffic growth
does it mean that or does it not mean
that
it means that if you add traffic to a
junction let's say
sutton road again if we were to add
i don't want to give you a number
because people latch on to numbers but
any number of trips to sutton road
if the network capacity was constraining
it it would never happen
because
it couldn't get to it
but what they've done
is they've added the percentage traffic
growth modeled the junction as if that
traffic was there and then designed
their mitigations on the basis of that
higher number okay
the network hasn't been tested
improving a junction
may increase the capacity of that
junction to feed vehicles into the
network
whose capacity hasn't been tested and
who on hit what non-ear says
unlikely to be realized
i think um
i'm close to the end now sir i just um
reiterate the um
i've got several questions which should
be aimed at essex and i think they're
legitimate questions but uh there's
nobody here that can answer for essex
so i mean all all i can suggest and i'm
sure it's no great comfort to you at all
mr foster is
try and put those questions to us at
county council outside this inquiry i
know that doesn't help you in in the
current position but clearly as you've
rightly said there's no one here from
essex county council they've made their
position quite clear in the statement of
common ground so
yes you may well have points you would
have wished to raise with them but that
just isn't possible i'm afraid if i
raise them sir and i get unsatisfactory
answers can i pass them on to you
no because as as i said at the
the outset
only exceptionally will information
received after the inquiry is closed
be
accepted
and what i have in front of me is a
statement of common ground signed
between the highway authority and i've
also
high authority and appellants and have
also got quite clearly the position of
the highway authority
in the various committee reports etc so
i i understand your position but in
terms of this inquiry i've made it clear
what
what information i have under understand
and respect that sir but i must put on
record that the
highways um
expert that was hired by roswell
district council and seems to be in the
primary source of defence for the
appellant
is not here to be cross-examined and
essex which is a major source that
several of the questions have been
answered with
that's essex county council but we can't
ask yes it counts council but if i can
just make it clear
had mr flexman have been here you
couldn't have cross-examined mr flexman
either or at least it would have been
very unusual
you're on the same side it's only
if
parties on the same side are
dramatically divergent that that might
be a possibility but
we're not there so i'm afraid that we we
are where we are okay
in that case i i close sir i i could
probably
drag it out with a few more small
questions but we'll call it a day okay
well thank you very much mr foster thank
you
thank you
um
bear with me
so in terms of those interested persons
it was
miss wait you said you've got a question
to put to mr blair
if you've got one could i ask you could
you find a microphone to speak with i
just know that if you speak from where
you are
it's not going to be picked up at all on
the
live stream it looks so ones
either find it
to the end of the table there we've got
an empty chair here
i should have a copy somewhere
this
sorry ms wright was it um
the survey you've asked mr uh
i've got it somewhere but
okay
[Applause]
um
could you turn to question one please
yes
i'd like to ask you mr blair why you
keep quoting
38
is my answer as the answer
to rush hour traffic
i i i totally understand that your
barrister's definition of
the morning russia or the russia was
limited to one hour and somehow that got
down to 15 minutes
but since you've seen fit to quote my
survey i wondered if you could explain
to the people here why you've chosen
that percentage of 38
for my definition of the russia
well
i read the question
what is your primary time of travel on
ashington road
and the answer choice is where during
rush hour
and there are two rush hours there
there's the am and the pm
and there are two rush hours in the
morning which actually i said oh i see
yeah right okay so
just just just for clarity i would just
like to say
that my definition and therefore the
1200 people not a thousand as is keeps
being said
i would suggest that 1200 is a lot more
than a thousand
okay so my definition of the russia
in which the school russia was included
is from seven till 9 30.
therefore i would like to ask you if you
agree
that the the proper definition of the
rush hour for the purposes of this
survey
is
38.48 of people who are traveling
between seven and nine thirty
which will leave the afternoon okay
added on to that
11.02 who are specifically
within that time yeah yes okay and then
as you very kindly alluded to
there is a further 16.11
and you said okay maybe half okay so
we'll go along with that so i would just
like to say for the purposes of clarity
that the morning rusher
is from 7 till 9 30 and it comprises 58
of those that are traveling not 38
i would put it to you i'm sure you'll
agree that that there is a huge
difference between 38
and 58
can i be clear where your 58 came from
58 comes from
the 38.48
of people who travel between 7 and 9 30
in general yeah
on top of that there are people who
travel purely during that time but for
the school
which is 11.02
and then
um as mr blair also kinda did
i use the rush the road at all times
okay
with so we he kind of said and i kind of
agree that the 16.11 let's say that half
of them might be on the road during rush
hour and half of them once okay so 58
so you've taken half of the 16.11 and
added to those other two yeah okay thank
you okay
um i'd just like to ask if you could
remind me of something
um could you clarify what percentage you
gave us
uh this is um i i think when you're
talking to mr parkinson
um
what percentage did you give us for
school car use
can you remember that and i mean
maybe that's a bit unfair
no it's in the ardent ta
i appreciate that this isn't before
everyone
[Music]
it was table 5.2
and what it's it's from the
um
the national trip end model statistics
and
the table are up
i'll just
say it yeah i'll just i'll read it
across because because what it says that
is that for car drivers so we're not
talking passengers for car drivers
at 34 percent work
six percent education five percent
shopping
uh holidays one percent
the total is 47
so it's it's critical that that's just
car drivers because you've also got car
passengers bus passengers all of that
yeah so what we've got is that out of
all cars the four if the 47 percent are
all car drivers
six percent
are going to education and if you
express six percent over 47 percent
it means that 12
of trips on the network are associated
with education
okay great so um
as you know from my survey i did i did
um separate
those on the road at school rush from
those within the normal russia
so would you would you be prepared to
accept sir that
that the that our uh percentage of
school rush hour travellers is probably
likely to be
traveling to the school
or stopping at the school or else they
would have been included in the first
part wouldn't they because the first
part of the answer is during the whole
of that period so if they've chosen not
to be included in the first part of
their of
the first part of the figures as 7 to 9
30 but they've chosen specifically to be
included in the school bits
would you accept that they're likely to
be
for whatever reason either going to the
school or
or dropping off at the school and
carrying on yes i would okay so i'd just
like to point out that our figure is
11.02
which is nearly twice the national
average no because
six percent over forty seven is twelve
percent your figure is very close to the
national average okay
sorry
so obviously that's my bad because i
don't understand okay
the last thing i'd like to ask you is
about the queue towards daley's road
and
yes okay so you agreed to mr parkinson
that at various times
when it's really bad there's going to be
a queue that goes from the whole
roundabout and he's going to go past
daley's road i
didn't agree that
i said that the model results on the
basis that that model was undertaken
demonstrate that right we um
we get the other side's case and we see
the points that we have to address some
points came out through
the proofs through the rebuttals we've
addressed all of those okay this point
came up
fundamentally as far as we're concerned
in the course of this inquiry
had we been
faced with that
in time
we would have then
quantified those eight issues
and we would have responded to say
that
the traffic approaching that roundabout
to the south wouldn't be that bad and
the queue wouldn't go anywhere near
dallas road roundabout and that's why mr
parkinson was saying you need 47 pcus
and the reason i'm quoting a thousand
isn't because it was your survey 1200
it's because there's approximately a
thousand trips going down the road right
so any percentages that we want to take
off are percentages off that thousand
okay the point i wanted to ask you about
was that you seem to be saying
that when the traffic is backing up
beyond dalys road
because of the accumulative effect of
the the cars that were already there
being joined by cars in the next quarter
you seem to be saying the in mitigation
of that
even though
not with saying what mr poster said that
it was an alternative to go through the
town yes right okay so let's let's just
just humor me that that there's we've
got a situation there where the traffic
is backed up beyond um
the back of the beyond the dallas road
roundabout and people are queuing up
going and they're going to turn left
onto dallas road to go into the town to
try to avoid that next section yeah
are you aware that it's actually not
possible to turn left
in off the dailies road roundabout until
you're actually on the roundabout
are you aware of that
sorry it's not possible to turn it it's
actually
so
imagine there's like a hundred queues
going back there hundred people yeah see
what you mean so you can't buy
passengers are you aware he actually
can't turn left
okay so you've given in mitigation the
fact that
this will be helped because people can
turn left
but now you're actually
accepting the fact that until you
actually get to the roundabout you can't
turn left so
do you not agree then it's actually not
going to make any difference to the
queue
whatever that queue might be well
no for two reasons
um
i don't think that people would only
turn left if the queue was at the
roundabout i think if they saw the queue
in front of them they'd probably turn
left before that
they can't turn left
there is no
they can't
they can't turn left before then
i'm sure there's a misunderstanding here
i i i i think
can can i give you my take on it and
then see if i'm understanding you
correctly
i i i are you saying ms wright that you
can't turn left until you get to the
roundabout
and therefore if you join a queue that's
coming back from
that roundabout
you can't turn left until you get
actually to the roundabout itself yes i
thought i thought you were thinking that
my take on um mr blair's answer is yes
but it's not simply those who are
joining the back of the queue those
actually at the front of that queue will
be at the roundabout
and they're the ones who he's saying
will turn left you you quite clearly
can't turn left until you get to the
roundabout yes but but more than that if
you thought that the queue was coming
back towards the roundabout you might
also turn left pre-empting that
where
before the queue builds back up to the
roundabout
if you were driving down the road
and the roundabout was clear
but just beyond it there was a queue
yeah but we're not talking about that
sir we're talking about when there is a
traffic backed up that goes past the
dailiest road roundabout
yes if you're driving around down a
free-flowing traffic and you are
approaching dallas road roundabouts and
you can see in the distance
that there is a there is a jam waiting
that hall road okay which i
can't always see because it's been there
but anyway yeah you can take the choice
to turn left but why would you the only
time you would want to turn left and go
through the very congested one-way
system in the town
is when you are approaching the dailies
road roundabout and you can see it is
backed up past the dailies road
roundabouts then you think i'm not going
down there i'm going left my question to
you is are you aware that until you
actually get to the dallas road right
about it is not actually possible to
turn left that's all i asked you um
it isn't nice it is not possible
in the design junction that's coming
forward there is a left turn there
that's it
thank you that's right
thank you
[Applause]
no one else who spoke on the first day
has indicated they
have any questions
sorry remind me of your name
okay do you want to go
mr blair
it's um in regards to
the pyramid that you showed us oh yes
mode shifts or eight reasons or
something like that
and one of the benefits you were talking
about was upgrade to bus stops yes
and that's at holt farm school
so i'd just like to know how
the proposal is to take away the lay by
which will mean that buses will stop in
the roads which will cause traffic jams
so i really like to understand how you
think
that's an upgrade to a bus stop
okay
um
the designers of this ace have advanced
this with the highway authority in
respect of the design in the plans that
were submitted my understanding is that
they thought that stopping the bus there
it actually allows them to widen the
footwear all the talk has been about
reducing the pad cycle when this is the
shared section this actually
widens the footwear ever so slightly
maybe only by a few hundred millimeters
in that in that location where the bus
lay by cuts in
and if you look at the still photographs
you'll see that that's where people
congregate as well
so it widens it there
but
i wasn't party to those conversations at
the time but my understanding was that
the bus stop there would actually add to
traffic coming and that may be seen as a
benefit
but that surely that will cause more
traffic jams our cars would stop behind
it yeah there isn't a negative impact
rather than a positive impact um
it depends what you want to the road
network it depends what you want to give
priority to yes
okay
and just one more question
um
you talked about reducing single
occupancy
obviously to improve and improve the pcu
how do you suggest this could be
achieved
well
in travel plans there's a travel plan
coordinator
and their purposes or their their role
is to engage with all the residents on
the side
and try and uh
you know
introduce initiatives that can help to
reduce single occupancy cars and one of
those could for example be a car share
scheme
okay yeah have you got any evidence
where that actually
works it happens all over the country
and even local authorities even run car
share schemes as well but it's one
initiative the thing about having a
travel plan coordinator is the drive is
towards the target
if they promote something and they do
annual surveys and if at the end of that
year something's not as effective as it
was hoped then they can divert their
funds to that or they can try something
different but the impetus is there to
drive towards reducing single occupancy
cars
so we have a travel coordinator that's
going to be trying to implement these
plans within the new development will we
is that what you're saying okay
oh
oh so
with regards to the bus stop um that's
not not going to be in the lab anymore
it's just going to be on the road
um
and we've got another bus stop on the
opposite side of the road which
could effectively meet not not directly
but quite close to that which
potentially means that traffic will be
stopped simultaneously on both sides of
the road how
do you feel that's going to impact on
traffic congestion
well
you you may have to wait behind a bus
while it's in a stop but with the levels
of traffic on the road it won't make any
difference the bus will move off you'll
follow on behind it
yeah but delayed journeys and
and and everything that we've been
talking about
that's it's going to have a negative
impact on the residents of of this area
and then we've got traffic and then the
traffic is going to be backed up to
roundabouts which we already know are
pinch points
um
we've got the
crossing for the children
i just
i'm struggling to see how it's to
benefit i don't think you've managed to
persuade me yet that it is
i just want to know that really
okay thank you
thank you okay thank you
okay so
no more questions from
interested
persons
um let me just try and find
where your proof's got to mr
mr blair
here we go
i think although i've got
a lot of flags on here when i looked
through them earlier
it seemed to me that as the inquiry has
progressed
all of these have been
responded to
i think there were just two
two points that i just did just want you
to clarify for me though please
you took me earlier to
the tricks information that had been
used to produce the trip generation
predictions for the uh development
and
um
i've not got them to hands i'll i'll
look at them again later but
what i wanted to be clear and i thought
i'd got at the back of my mind a figure
of a 167 or something like that
trips generated outbound from the
development i don't know if that was
going south down actually i'm just
trying to relate that to the 103 that
you've referred to a number of times
at
the
hall road junction um let me see if i
can help you um
the fact that they did this for every 15
minutes just means that there's four
figures for everyone
give me the table reference that you're
looking at and i'll be able to
revisit that afterwards
okay
the figure in the
ace report in very small print
is fd 25
what page is that on
it is not paginated sir all right um
but it's it's one of the
stick flow diagrams one of those yeah
so would you like a photocopy of that
page just so that it's easier for you to
locate if it's unpacking um not that but
if you can no no i think yeah yeah
i'm trying to print you a clean one
yeah
we do one of that that'd be helpful
there yeah
then i'll know it's in the document but
at least i'll have an easy easy copy of
it here
if when you get this you're scratching
your head over nine trips
it's because of the car park on site for
the school trips so it's defining
some people diverting in and coming back
out okay so it looks like you've got a
slightly bigger number coming back out
but there's a minus number going through
i i understand yeah okay thank you
i think the only other point that
um
well another point i just wanted to hear
your response to because it was raised
on day one i can't remember which member
of the public it was who said it but i i
was told how many
cars
there were likely to be
on this development as a whole if it
went ahead and put it bluntly if they
were laid end to end we were going to
have six miles of traffic yes i just
wondered what your comments were
on the way that was expressed and what i
should take away from that you should
take nothing from that it was expressed
completely
incorrectly
okay
as i say i i got a lot of other points
but i'm content that what i'd flagged
you you've answered one way or another
or at least it's it's come forward um
as the inquiry has progressed so i don't
need to ask you
any of those so i think um
i can ask if you've got any
re-examination then please miss reed
thank you sir um
now
good afternoon mr blair good afternoon
i'm going to take you back to the
beginning of um cross-examination
um you by mr um by melon friend mr
parkinson um you're asked a number of
questions about your site visits and
whether you'd observed congestion at
junction 4 in particular do you recall
and you said you'd seen queues but you'd
also seen it free flowing within the
relevant amp qrecor that's right
there then appeared to be some queries
about how extensive your site visit has
been and whether it was representative
of conditions
um just just
one point please can you turn up your
appendix 3
just tell me what page it started i'm so
sorry yes it's page 26
yes and that's that's a um an image of
the hall road ashington road roundabout
junction four yeah
um and um have you had the opportunity
to um compare your observations in that
photograph for example with the traffic
survey data for the similar period
and is the were your observations
reflective of the traffic survey data
yes thank you
um and do you have any reasons to think
based on your site visits and
observations that the traffic survey
data was unrepresentative uh no the
traffic survey data was represented
thank you and what information was used
to used in the models was it your
observational
um was it your observations or was it
the traffic survey data it was the
traffic surveys which were accompanied
by the key service which is how we know
that they're validated in terms of
demand exactly and highways authority
we've heard that they have compared that
data against their own surveys and um
considered that it was
appropriate there's reference to that in
the planning officer's report
what comfort does that give
in respect of the robustness
of the relevant baseline data well the
death has effectively been checked and
validated three times against well by me
by the queue surveys and that data has
been checked against the highway
authorities on records thank you
great confidence yeah
thank you
good
uh next point um you were
um all set sorry well sort of similar
point actually you were asked a number
of points about the fact that the um ta
recognized a particular level of traffic
on the network you recall yes
um again if the ta recognizes a certain
level of traffic on the network
is that that then reflected in the
models that you've considered
sorry
well if the t if the ta is making a
comment because the ta if the ta is
making a comment that there's a certain
level of traffic on the network yes
well will that be reflected in the
models
well it should be reflected in the
models but the ace models
over predicted
what the performance was it's the reason
it drew me towards looking at the
validation of it exactly next point
please
next point you were taken to policy t2
in the core strategy could you turn that
up please call document 6.1.
and i'll just get a page reference just
bear with me
page 107.
sorry just yeah no problem
it should be within this but
no
looking at point zero four six point
five
sorry page reference
one zero seven
policy t2
[Applause]
and um a point was put to you by mr
parkinson that
policy t2 says well
um highway improvements to the following
will be prioritized and well look those
include to washington road to improve
traffic flows and reduce congestion you
recall i do at first point policy t2 who
is the obligation on within policy t2
yes between the um the council and essex
county highways i say in my proof that
it's not upon the developer thank you
second point in any case in any case
are will the scheme improve traffic
flows and reduce congestion
at the junctions where it is possible
for the developer to do that on
ashington road well i described before
how there's a double mitigation because
it's felt that the
sustainable enhancement mitigations etc
are sufficient to mitigate the west
street hall road
and will apply equally to all the other
junctions
but all the other junctions are
mitigated
fully and indeed over mitigate it
slightly
by the highway works that are proposed
there
next point is there a requirement in
policy t2 that any particular scheme is
completed by the highways authority
before the development within the plan
can come forward no no
third point third point if you look at
policy
ser 8
ser 8 which is the allocations policy
core document 6.2
it's page 74-75
yes
is there any requirement in the
allocations policy that any particular
wider highways scheme um
that
comes forward pursuant to t2 before
policy scr8 can come forward no no i
don't see that no um there is agreement
between the local planning well there's
agreement with the local planning
authority yesterday that we comply with
the highways requirements in policy scr8
do you agree with that mr blair i do
right
um
thank you
next point you were taken to the
preferred options
paper
the preferred option no sorry i keep
calling it preferred option i think it's
actually
new local plan spatial options
consultation paper 2021
core document 6.4
and you were taken to page 124 of that
document
page
page 124.
now we know we know because councillor
shaw agreed with me that this was the
case yesterday and we'll explore it
further with mr pycroft next week
we know that the allocation of the
appeal site is carried forward in this
document that the council has approved
you recall that cross-examination of
council ashore i do um can you can you
just look please um at the bottom
because it's under the section road
connectivity you were taken to by my
learned friend
what does that tell us
what does that tell us that last
sentence about the type of the
appropriateness of the type of measures
that the appellant is bringing forward
through this scheme please
well it tells us that they should be
given a priority that they are the
important
measures over the car
at next point
you can pop the plans away
um
next point
um you were asked a number of questions
about temporo and tricks you recall
temporary growth and tricks
and um one of the and you
you set out um the approach that you had
taken in respect to validating the
models
and you indicated that the original
approach that had been undertaken in the
ta was overly robust and an overestimate
you recall that's right right
um it then appeared to be put to you
that well
um even if that's the case the original
approach might be a reasonable approach
you recall that line of questioning i do
um tempo first please and the issue
there as you explained is that our site
was effectively double counted that's
right right
which on that basis which set of modeled
results should be relied upon now that
we have both by the decision maker to
properly understand the impacts of the
scheme the updated version my version
thank you trip rates which trip rates
are likely to give a more accurate
understanding a more accurate
understanding of the position yours or
the previous ones
right
um on that basis on that basis which
model is more likely to give an accurate
understanding of the impacts of the
scheme
of mind right
that's agreed i was just going to say
that statements of common ground with mr
flexman yes right what's his position mr
blair now having discussed those matters
with you
through statements of common ground
discussions as to the appropriateness of
your validated model he specifically
states that the modeling approach is
appropriate and that the validation
approach is logical and then in the
statement of common ground 2 that he has
signed has he indicated that there's any
issue and it's the last paragraph of
that statement of common ground surf
your reference any issue between him and
you at all in respect of any matter he
says he has no issues plural
yeah thank you
have you seen any evidence from the
local planning authority or any other
party to this inquiry to indicate that
it would be more appropriate
in understanding the impacts of the
scheme to use the previously modeled
approach no thank you
next point you're asked about a number
of questions about um delay and queuing
on ashingdon road junction 4 you recall
those questions
um i just want to be clear
just bear with me a second
let me just find the
um
relevant
page
that's yours not mine isn't it that's
why i don't know why
never mind it's okay
um now um i just want to be clear so
it's pages two three one and two three
two
and it was this point about cueing back
from junction 4 to junction 3.
how many time segments in the am peak
does that issue relate to
well as shown on page two three one and
two three two
it would relate to two time time periods
right so half an hour period
and second point second point you're
asked um
in respect to this point
uh about cueing back between junction
three and junction four um is that a
point either taken by mr flexman in any
of his evidence uh no queuing back from
four to three sorry four to three i'm so
sorry he did he did two he did take
three to four but not fortunately no no
i understand he's not two three i'm
sorry
um to four to three right so not a point
taken by mr flexman
and mr flexman has um carried out um a
review
of your work yes yeah
um
if he had considered that there was an
issue what would you have expected to
see in his evidence to the inquiry
undertook a very detailed review he went
very deep into every aspect of this and
i think the fact that he doesn't raise
any or retain any issues at all speaks
volumes
but not only does he not mention it mr
blair but what does his statement of
common ground tell us about his judgment
as to the residual cumulative impacts of
the scheme he believes there is no
severe residual cumulative impact
now page two three two
just want to put this point in context
page sorry not page two three two page
two three two three one
page two three one
um and um it's it's this point that well
you would need to remove
46.7 pcus to stop this queuing issue
that's been identified you recall i do
recall that yeah um
if we look at um page
231 and it's under the heading results
results summary for the whole modeled
period yes um what are the total
junction arrivals
please
987 this is why i've been saying roughly
yeah roughly a thousand so that that was
the first point where i just wanted to
indicate to the inspector where that
figure comes from so that's 987. you
might need to do a quick calculation for
me now
so what percentage of the development
flow needs to be removed to stop the
issue that's been identified
i'm sorry sorry it's sorry percentage of
the total flow yesterday
sorry i said development i meant total
flow
so 47 divided by 987
is
4.7 percent
4.7 percent
just understood in that context
the realism of your points please that a
combination of your eight points
can reduce
traffic to that degree
absolutely i think one of the points
alone i was writing my totals down as
well one of my points alone had a
potential for 90 i think
okay
it's also worth mentioning this
exponential curve the closer you get to
capacity the better it performs
now it was put to you on a number of
occasions a number of occasions that you
hadn't quantified these eight points
that you've got
just want to understand how fair that
point is
one
two reports to committee by the local
planning authorities professional
officers
where you have and seven pre-application
meetings was the appellant ever asked to
quantify or carry out further surveys by
the professional officers of the local
planning authority in respect to this
issue now the only thing was to make the
assessments more robust through
providing the taa right no but no
further surveys etc
next point ever asked by the highways
authority to provide any additional
information in respect of these issues
no no
third point mr flexman in his
comprehensive review and as you say he
did ask you numerous questions
i think including at 11 37 at night i
think was one of them mr blair but in
any case
mr flexman in the numerous questions he
asked you when he was carefully
scrutinizing your evidence on behalf of
the local planning authority did he ever
ask you for any further information in
respect of any of these points no no
councillor eves counselor eves in his
proof of evidence and his rebuttal did
he ever ask you for any further
information in respect of any of these
points no
thank you very much and in terms of the
professional the professional
um
the professional witnesses and members
of the various authorities so the local
planning authority officers the highway
officers and mr flexman
in terms of all of those professionals
what is their professional consensus in
respect of whether there is a residual
the residual cumulative impact on the
highway network and
111 across all of those bodies
all of paragraph
have confirmed
that they do not believe there is a
severe residual
cumulative impact
appeal decisions appeal decisions please
next um page 224
think
of your appendices
no just bear with me a second no no no
no it's not in the placement oh it's in
volume one isn't it
very second i think it's in volume one
i think we've got our papers mixed up
appendix 11. and happily happily we're
going right to the back of appendix 11
so it's nice and easy to find
and um it's appeal an appeal decision
an appeal decision in fact it's a report
to the secretary of state
in respect of an appeal cease devon yeah
and um it's page 54
and it's paragraph 224 yes of that
appeal decision
and what does the inspector tell us at
the bottom of paragraph 224
as to whether it might be appropriate to
take into account factors such as peak
spreading and the diversion of traffic
she says even if the latter scenario
does not occur there are also other
factors that would tend to reduce the
impacts such as peak spreading and the
diversion of traffic along science park
drive clearly the diversion of traffic
point is going to depend on the local
circumstances isn't it to a degree but
in terms of peak spreading how relevant
to those comments well they're very
relevant as is the diversion one of the
reasons i put this
precedent and is because i was the
highways witness on it
right
thank you
and councillor eves councillor eves his
position in respect of peak spreading
that there was significant potential to
reduce trips
in respects of peak spreading
and based on his local knowledge and
experience
might have got to it in a different way
to you
mr blair is there any difference between
you and the local planning authority in
terms of the potential of peak spreading
to make a significant difference
in respect of the anticipated trips
there is no difference they think it's
significant and in fact i think mr eve's
estimate would have been
perhaps even bigger than mine okay
next point please
put those away
um
core document 6.14.
back
now um this this is the report into the
allocations plan that you were taken to
yes no the allocations plan not the
course strategy
okay
um and um we know
we know from paragraph 25
and council ashore accepted
that what the inspector said there in
respect of the appropriateness of the
allocation was that most significantly
the scale and location of development
had already been assessed
you see the words assessed
and determined through the core strategy
yeah
what does that tell us about whether the
appropriateness of the location of the
development in principle had or had not
been assessed through the core strategy
yes it looks like it's assessed and
considered yeah thank you
and then turning to the point um which
was well um detailed highways issues
this was mr parkinson's paragraph 20.
would need to be considered through the
normal exercise of sorry the normal
exercise of development management
policies
as part of the planning application
process
um
in respect of that point in respect to
that point if we then please look at
paragraph 26
of the inspectors report and it says
this
the policies themselves are lengthy and
they include the site context site
capacity and concept statement
they repeat many of the requirements
which stem from the policies of the core
strategy such as those relating to
there's a number of factors but we also
a number of factors there and then we
see this
infrastructure requirements are also set
out in appendix h1 and you recall i took
councillor shaw to those yesterday
although not a model of good practice
the form of the policies does provide
comprehensive detail about what is
expected
so that
major changes are not necessary
so the policies provide comprehensive
detail
about what is expected
in view of the
agreement of the local
planning authority
yesterday the agreement of the local
planning authority
yesterday
that there was no
conflict
with those policies of the development
plan yeah policy ser eight and also
appendix h1
in the core strategy which was referred
to
in the relevant policy of the core
strategy but no conflict with those
policies of the development plan
what does that tell us
about whether this development complies
in highways terms with what was expected
by the plan yes it tells us it complies
thank you very much there was then a
general point put to you by mr parkinson
which appeared to be oh well the
inspector has to take into account
everything before him including appeal
decisions by mr flexman you recall that
line of duty
in respect of that point we know
that appeal decisions are material
considerations to the extent that they
are relevant to a point being put by the
party okay
now
uh what is mr flexman's what we know
what mr flexman's view is as to residual
cumulative impacts because we've noted
it on various occasions and it is
clearly set out in the statements of
common ground
on that basis
do you take it that there is anything in
those appeal decisions that the local
planning authority relies upon to
support a country conclusion i don't
believe so mr flexman has changed his
mind thank you mr flexman has changed
his mind presumably aware of the appeal
decisions that he provided
in his proof of evidence
on that
on that basis can those appeal decisions
be relied upon to support the point that
now appears to be taken on behalf of the
local planning authority if not by its
witnesses
they shouldn't be given weird no
uh raynham decision next please raynham
decision um i don't think we actually
need to turn it up unless you need to
but i'm just going to you'll recall the
raynham decision it's the secretary of
state one it was referred to by the rule
six parties and referred to by the mp
but you were taken to it by the rule six
parties in questions
and the the point that was taken by mr
foster was well in that case the
inspector and the secretary of state
formed a judgment in respect um
formed a judgement that's an alternative
type of modeling was appropriate you
recall that line questioning yeah
in that case did the inspector have one
or two models in front of him for
consideration uh i'm trying to remember
that i think there was certainly an
insane model model and yes i think he
had two in front of him yeah yeah one on
behalf of the local planning authority
and one on behalf of the appellant
now just in respect of the position here
and whether the position here is similar
firstly
um is there agreement between um the
appellant and the highways authority as
to the appropriateness of the model
that's been used here yes is there
agreement between us and the local
planning authority is the
appropriateness of the model that's been
used here yes
is there any other modeled approach
that's before the inquiry to consider
are the circumstances that exist here
comparable to those that existed in the
raynham appeal no no
thank you very much mr blair thank you
sir i have no further points okay thank
you and just for information the note
passed to me from mr foster was simply
an apology that they have to leave for a
media interview
at 4 50. so it didn't relate to any any
evidence or anything simply courtesy to
let me know there
no i think i think no i think i'm going
to call today's proceedings to a fairly
rapid close now hopefully and we can all
be on our way thank you for the
uh re-examination miss reed let me make
a note
okay
so nothing more than today so all i need
to do now is ask for the attendance list
back is that winging its way to me now
anyone present who didn't sign it was a
few hands would you mind just
thank you
um and then i'll join in a moment we'll
resume um next week unfortunately i'm
told we do have to empty things from the
room here so um and we can't start until
10 30 on tuesday
but the plan for tuesday uh is uh mr
pycroft
possibly your
well not possibly your air quality
witness i did tend to call him first sir
if that's acceptable um just i'm just
mentioning that so the local authority
know in terms of arrangements to beam
him in
um and um but i'd intend to call him
first so that mr pie cross my final
witness because he's dealing with yes no
that makes perfect sense thank you and
and yes that'll give a definite time for
him as well so easier to schedule there
um
rule six part you've got questions for
the air quality witness i know as i
mentioned earlier mr gardner said he'd
got a question
for air quality so
that will take place first thing on
tuesday
hopefully then we'll move through with
that evidence and mr pycroft's and deal
with
conditions and the section 1 of c 106
agreement in the afternoon
may have to go on a little bit later if
if necessary
site visit i won't go into detail now
but site visits sometime on wednesday
morning covering whatever period is
deemed appropriate and then closing
submissions on wednesday afternoon
possibly starting at say two o'clock
so that's the plan okay let's hope we
can
bring that to fruition as it were so
thank you all for your attendance this
week and on that note i'm going to
adjourn now we'll resume on tuesday at
10 30. thank you
you